foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
competitive chess the weight of a win
draw or loss is all on one's shoulders
it's easy to feel alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my gosh
the pro chess league is back
once again in chess teammates matter he
is just upset he's got a hand in his
head he can't believe it what what what
are you doing
welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes there are gnomes
and knights chess bras and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives
can win this game that's winning for
black how does magic Carlson do this
entering its Fifth Season 16 teams will
reboot the PCL Legacy with a new format
and new schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL Champion it's tough out here India
is just a Powerhouse
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 2023
Pro chess League yesterday was Tuesday
and it was Breakneck action all the way
we expect the same today as we have two
exciting matches on that deck I'm your
host Grandmaster Daniel nerdinski
alongside me today commentating for the
first time Anya it is an honor
International Master Tanya sajdev I
guess it's evening for you good evening
are you as excited as I am for the
matches that we have in store today
thank you so much Daniel I am absolutely
pumped I have to say that I am a sucker
for team events and the protest league
is such a dogfight it is entertaining it
is competitive it's everything that we
want and more I'm super excited about
the action
I am as well and we will give you all of
the information about these matches but
first let's start broad let's talk about
the dates just so those with a Google
Calendar and mark off the appropriate
dates we have of course the five-week
regular season in February and March it
began yesterday March 24th is a very
exciting event called The Arena Royale
where all of the teams participate in
one big arena then the two most
important sets of dates March 30th and
31st are the playoffs and of course the
PCL finals occur May 11th to 14 the
Tanya it's just month after month of
Breakneck action unmissable dates coming
right up
we've got we've got a mohawk Islanders
is that Arena Royale that all star
matchup that we see it is the best of
the best the creme de La Creme of the
Chess World fighting it out in online
theme chess format and what I love about
this uh Team events uh Daniel is that it
is so much to do with the termination
for your team but also personal ambition
to be the MVP for your team and of
course it's uh it's a grueling grueling
format here at the protest League
it is indeed and we wouldn't have it any
other way I agree completely just the
melding of individual and team
components makes this so fascinating and
also of course the time control and just
the overall format let's go over uh that
format the time control in each of these
games is 10 minutes with a two second
increment there are four players per
team per match uh those four players
play another team of four players and in
total they play up to four rounds and
the team that scores eight and a half
points wins the match so points are
accumulated in every round and the team
that hits eight and a half points first
wins the match in the event of an 8-8
tie round four will be replayed in a
blitz and then a bullet time control
until a winner is declared Tanya it's a
very simple format that's what I love
about it first team to eight and a half
that's all you need to know that's the
dream that's the mark that you want to
get to but it is of course not an easy
Road there's so much strategy that goes
in planning your team roster in the
lineup what gives you the best shot in
getting to that eight and a half and of
course 10 minute with a two second
increment I have to say that the
increment component is barely enough to
to make a move you can't really add up
on the clock so there's always so much
pressure and we saw that Daniel in the
matchups from yesterday
and let's go over uh yesterday's
matchups I can confirm firsthand Tanya
that two-second increment those two
seconds they evaporate faster than I
don't know rain on a hot day it's just
incredible how stressful it is to be in
the hot seat we had two very exciting
matches yesterday a blowout in the
morning match between the Indian yogis
who destroy the Brazil capybara is eight
and a half three and a half and then a
certain team called the Charlotte cobras
I don't know if I want to talk about
that Tanya it was a nail biter and the
Canada chess bras featuring Magnus
Carlson win by a single point I don't
remember who played on that Charlotte
team I'm I'm having some memory issues
Tanya I really don't remember anything
about that match
but you really shouldn't because there's
so much to be proud of you gotta
remember all the good takeaways I mean I
was watching that what a day of just we
had two very different matches now I
have to say the Indian yogis were on top
farm and that felt like a destruction uh
they wrapped it up in just three rounds
achieved that golden Mark of eight and a
half but the next match that we saw with
chess bras and the Charlotte cobras that
was a nail biter and Daniel today you're
a commentator but yesterday you were
team captain and a player now it started
rough for you but what a comeback you
made a terrific fight in the end how are
the nerves take us through the day as a
player and a captain what's that like on
the protest League
listen Tanya it's a great privilege to
be wearing two hats as a player and a
commentator and you know I've played in
the Pro chess League before but there
was a a three-year Hiatus and I just
remembered yesterday just how stressful
it is uh to be sitting there knowing
that you know Robert Hess and uh other
commentators thousands of people are
observing your games of course Magnus
Carlson carried the chess bras with four
out of four I gave Magnus a very good
fight but uh at the end he ground me
down I played okay and obviously just
heartbreaking stuff for Grandmaster a
wonderla Yang who just played fantastic
chess but could not pull through it's
the Magnus effect Tanya the Magnus
effect is real you sense that the win is
near your fingers turn into thumbs your
brain stops operating and in the end you
know we gotta congratulate the chess for
us it was an amazing match and
definitely a lot to take away from it
but you don't have to wait long because
today we have two matches that rival
yesterday's in terms of their
entertainment value Anya it's the levit
of Chess was Wizards against the pastors
coming right up and then later the
Norway gnomes against the Spanish Maniac
shrimps
I love it I look at the theme names and
the theme logos and it just feels like
we're gonna have a magical day of Chess
or as the French would say and Shantae
I'm not sure if they say that or I
completely butchered it out but look at
that we've got a lavator against the
Garden State passes the Wizards against
uh James Canty III he'll be captaining
the Garden State passes and we've got
the Norway norms and we've got Anna
Rudolph there along with John Lubbock
Hammer playing against the maniac
shrimps this is gonna be a fun day of
chess what are you most looking forward
to today
well I just love the fact that almost
all of the teams Tanya are evenly
matched and this is really what makes
each day of PCL action so exciting and
what I look forward to the most is the
possibility of upsets I love to see you
know the more lopsided mattress because
some of these players do not be fooled
by their ratings they're coming in
hungry they're coming in well prepared
and the story lines that I really love
to observe is you know board three or
board four scoring a couple of crucial
wins and on that note let's have a look
at the overall roster rules these roster
rules ensure that the teams remain
relatively evenly matched each team must
include at least two females one Junior
born 2003 or later although on yet it
feels like I'm ancient or in 1995 I mean
everybody I'm playing now in tournaments
seems to be born 2003 or later so that's
not a big problem and players must stick
with the team from week one but they can
continue to add players to their roster
throughout the season
and I think that point makes it super
fun the fact that you can mix it up even
during the season and Daniel I want to
get your thoughts on this because of
course you know you've got all these
insights as the captain and a player in
one of the big teams here in this season
what what do you think is the correct
strategy here where you stick with your
team players and sort of build this
camaraderie build the team spirit
throughout the season or get fresh blood
in the mix and mix up the roster during
the season
less tempting as it is Tanya I think to
add to continually add fresh blood I
think it is important first of all not
to overreacting right just because one
player has one bad week doesn't mean
that they're not going to come in
Hungary next week and redeem themselves
and obviously nobody is playing from the
same location but there is still very
much a sense of Team camaraderie right
week after week you struggle together
you fight together and I feel like that
adds meaning to each player's
performance and it makes you try harder
and I think it makes you play better so
I'm on the camaraderie side of this
question but obviously the captains have
uh big shoes to fill and a lot of
decisions uh to make and decisions uh
that are quite difficult to make for
teams like levitov chess which have
rosters as rich as the one that you see
in front of you I mean that is just a
mouth-watering assortment of names
captain of course in headlined by
shakuri armamadyaro this is amazing
stuff I mean some of the most creative
top Grand Masters in the Chess World are
in this mix look at that we've got the
shock attack leading up front and then
Daniel dubov the most creative player of
our time some amazing opening prep
expecting that we've got Serana who of
course uh qualified for the recent
Championship Star first division mamadov
as well in the mix this is incredible
stuff but what stands out for me Daniel
is look at those two female players
we've got kostanuk as well as gunina
this team is it's I mean I have to say
huge favorites in this protest League
completely agree they are one to watch
castenoke is a women's world champion
she's incredibly experienced in Rapid
time control Valencia gunana the same
could be said about her the levitov
Wizards really have no holes in their
roster and you know all four of their
boards are very much capable of scoring
I think at least uh two points and in
chakra's case he can definitely put in a
four out of four performance and another
player who can put in a four out of four
performance as we saw uh throughout his
performances in the um rapid Chess
Championship is Samuel sevyan who
headlines uh the mouth-watering roster
for the Garden State passers James Canty
where the commentator had yesterday and
now he is a player he is a captain and a
look at those grand Masters Lenderman
and ABI Manu Mishra the youngest
Grandmaster uh in history just amazing
teams being assembled this year in the
PCL
and Sam is in such great form he just
recently beat pregnant and I in the
third division of the Champions chat
store final so definitely looking good
in this uh a roster that we've got you
mentioned James was commentating
alongside Robert yesterday a switch of
rules here and I'm sure he's feeling the
nerves going into this big matchup
against the levitor Wizards
yeah he most certainly is I think on
paper we can say that the levitov
Wizards are favorites they've got Shakur
yarma midara if they've got that
overpowered roster but we already know
that absolutely anything can happen
let's take a look at the match breakdown
we have the Wizards this is the big
moment passers here it is Tanya and here
we see all four of the boards in round
one board one plays board four uh Donnie
I was gonna do the drum roll for this
because this is the reveal of the lineup
for today and so exciting to see who the
teams have chosen to go fight in the
battlefield and we'd love to get our
chats views on who they think is a
favorite in this one playing today for
the lavender of just Wizards we've got
Shak attack we've got David paravia now
David has won the Gibraltar Masters in
2020 where he beat Al where he beat as
the pienko and Wang how in the playoffs
a very dangerous player we've got the
youngster Dennis lazovic and of course
she is so competitive fights it out till
the end he'll be playing the Garden
State passers and look at the lineup
there we've got we've got Trisha Kanya
morala who is the only women
International master from Ireland and
she's a very very strong upcoming Talent
this is going to be a big fight and of
course we've got London man as well as
gusunov and Sam Savion uh Danny what are
your thoughts on this lineup
well just to bring this back to you know
one of the reasons to watch the PCL is
you're able to discover new players who
you might have heard of tangentially but
whose games you might not have seen and
this is exactly what I see here Tanya
Alexander Lenderman is such a dangerous
player he has been up and down in terms
of his OTB performances but he has a lot
of super Grand Master victories under
his belt I remember him crushing vasel
ivancic a couple of years ago at the
world team championship and gadir
gussenov another player who is known for
his split skill he has been Atop The
Blitz leaderboards now for well over a
decade so again Lev it off chest Wizards
they've got four grand Masters I think
they are the favorites sort of
statistically but you cannot sleep on
Letterman and gusana and I think for the
passers to score an upset Tanya
Lenderman and gusainov need to put in
probably at least two and a half maybe
three out of four and let's see if Kanye
morala can score an upset or two as well
and even on that lowest board we see
we've got Sam Savion against Valentina
gunina now even though gunina is Bored
for for levitov she is one of their star
players I remember back at the London
chess classic rapid I think it was in
2016 and correct me if I was if I'm
wrong it was a rapid championship and
she won the tournament ahead of over 50
strongest Grand Masters uh she is the
European Blitz Champion the farmer the
urban Blitz Champion we've got liftoff
already
seat belts fastened ladies and gentlemen
day two of the PCL is underway here we
go in board four faces board one it's
Kanya marala against Mahmoud Yara of
Tanya the pressure is obviously on
chakra though he has the black pieces he
essentially has to win this game and you
can already see an unbalanced opening
Knight F6 and B6 is kind of a second
rate defense but it can be very
dangerous if white doesn't react
precisely
he's making his intentions very clear
now of course for Trisha this is a huge
opportunity to play against the world's
best players and that is the other thing
that I love about these formats and this
event is just players you know upcoming
talents they get to really fight it out
with the very best in the world and
chakriya chooses the opening the most
dynamic reply with the black pieces to
make a middle game that is absolutely
unclear by fiance shadowing both Bishops
along the long diagonal meanwhile Trisha
says I'm gonna block one of those with
the pawn Central advance and Daniel this
is the problem with the structure that
black has chosen yes you take out your
pieces but where is your control with
the black pieces in the center it
doesn't exist
other than B6 and G6 black so far has
pushed absolutely no Pawns in the center
as you're saying but that is the kind of
General philosophy of these hyper modern
openings where you say hey I'm going to
let you control as much of the center as
you want and then I'm going to chip away
at it with my pawns and you see shocker
are doing that right now he's just
played E6 and you might see him
following up with C6 trying to get rid
of this Pawn on D5 and if he can do so
then his Bishops start getting active
but he takes a slightly more
conservative approach he plays D6 plays
this king's Indian style the Knight is
probably going to come out to D7 and
Black's position although cramped is
very Compact and it's hard to find a
plan here for white Tanya and that is
why I think these King's Indian type
openings are really good choices in
Rapid games
foreign
definitely has to look at scoring that
four out of four today for his team he
is the uh the star player the MVP at
least on paper for the levitor visit and
right now uh by the way there was a
notification that just popped up on my
screen that today is World hippopotamus
day and this opening that shark has gone
for at least the structure is called a
hippo because if you take a look at it
it's it looks like a hippo peeping Out
of Water you know with everything not
going beyond the third rank so I wonder
if this is shark's homage to the world
hippo day
that's really interesting I I didn't
think of it that way I guess chess
players they are known they're not
always known for their originality but
the hippo is one of the more originally
named opening setups and I like the way
that Trisha is handling this so far the
queen comes out to D2 she has
established her minor pieces in such a
way as to keep you know these key pawns
well protected on e4 and C4 now a big
question for shockery are
how is he going to resolve the tension
in the center is he going to play E5 and
lock the center up or is he going to
take on D5 there's our answer Tanya and
I think a knight might be coming out to
E4 this is where things can start
getting a little bit difficult to handle
for white
well Trisha's got to make a decision now
and it looks like she has to capture
with the e-pawn otherwise as we see two
knights and the black Rook hitting that
pawn which is only defended uh by the
Knight and Bishop and shark doesn't care
he says sure take that pawn I won't win
it but I want to create a minor piece
material imbalance imagine if everything
gets created off Daniel right now chakra
will end up with a bishop pair uh in a
reasonably open position the C4 Pawn
will be under Fire the e-file will be in
control and this is what shark wants
also watch out that Bishop from G7 is
also eyeing that B2 Pawn so some
difficult questions here for white
already
absolutely and don't sleep on the bishop
on B7 which could come out to A6 and put
further pressure on C4 you can kind of
see the appeal of this opening as Trisha
figures out a way to handle the pressure
heat she does trade on e4 and follows up
with Rook 8 to C1 I think she's likely
to support her Pawn chain with B3 I
think the position is about equal but
chakra has got to be pretty happy with
his Bishop pair now let's go quickly to
the bird's eye view Tony because we've
got a fascinating opening on the second
board it's a very very even matchup
between Alexander Letterman and David
parabian so uh let's go there because we
already have a major opening in Balance
Tanya I'm struggling to make heads or
tails of the position that we have here
help me out
well I'm just loving it I'm kind of
taking it in what is this Pawn structure
that we've got both kings in the center
I'm loving this middle game already uh
David's last move is targeting the pawn
chain on the queen side white ignores it
says it's more important to get safe
with the King and I agree with that but
in the process we see some trades and
now black has to watch out because if
you pick up that C5 Pawn you line up
your Bishops on the same file Daniel and
that would mean the queen can
potentially step forward hitting not one
Bishop but Bishop behind it as well you
might defend it once The Rook will come
into the game just continuing to attack
those pieces and this could be big
trouble for black this could be a
disaster especially compounded by the
weakness of Black's King which does not
find a lot of Solace on the king side
black can technically defend the bishop
of The Rook A5 but an Insidious move
like Queen C3 followed by Knight bd2 and
Knight B3 good Spell instant Doom for
black imagine trying to handle this
position with five minutes left David he
doesn't touch that with a 10-foot pole
as we go back to the live board he has
instead navigated his Bishop to B5 and
now Tanya I think he's got a good
opportunity to pick up the pawn on C5
Bishop B5 of course came with the tempo
it attacked The Rook on E1 it was a very
smart move Lenderman brings his night
out and really the big question here uh
I think to me is can white use the
mobility of his Knights can white use uh
the post on D4 to put immediate pressure
on black skin because from a positional
perspective blacks Bishops they do look
pretty menacing super menacing but time
is of the Essentia this is one of those
positions where it doesn't matter what
the eval Bar says it might say Black's
fine but one mistake and the game is
over we've been talking about developing
the pieces with Tempo the bishop is
attacked also don't forget in the air is
this Central break with the pawn from E3
moving forward to E4 trying to open up
the position it has to be timed really
really well for it to work now I'm still
trying to get a headcount on what is the
pawn situation because it's sort of me
too harder than it looks but it looks
like it's yeah this entire time you know
societies have risen and Fallen
civilizations have uh collapsed and
risen all I'm doing is trying to count
who is is either side up upon no
material is equal uh as far as I can
tell see I'm still not sure five fawns
each the bishop on B5 is hanging uh
Tanya and clearly David is trying to
figure out where to position it Bishop
C4 makes some sense but the other night
could drop back to D2 uh and harass the
the bishop even further maybe bishop A6
but that runs into a potential check on
A4 so I like lenderman's opening choice
he's gone for the type of position
that's hard to handle with 10 minutes on
your clock and that is part of each
player's opening strategy right you do
play differently in the 10 plus two time
control uh than you do in a long time
control classical game Bishop C4 is
paravian's choice and I'm expecting 92
maybe Letterman will also start pushing
his passer what an interesting position
Tanya hard to evaluate
super fun and you hit the nail on the
head when you were talking about A
lender man's opening approach because
we've been saying that the levitto
wizard on paper are the favorites in
this match which means that the Garden
State passes on every board have to
create their chances and opportunities
right out of the opening no playing safe
here and that's what Alexander's done he
develops the queen further always eyeing
the Bishops on the C file there are
threats of the Knight jumping to E4 as
well Daniel in certain position taking
advantage of that Bishop but you have to
again be careful about the tactics and
of course with the queen on C2 it
defends not only the A2 Pawn but eyes
the eight seven Pawn on the other end of
the board as well
yeah David cannot be feeling comfortable
with the the sort of General State of
his King now choosing between two two
evils I think castle and kingside is the
king side is the safer place to be
relatively speaking and then the kid can
tuck itself away on h8 and later on
black could actually use the G file uh
to his Advantage positioning a rook on
G8 White's gang it might be feeling
comfortable now but that could change in
a couple of moves so the engine seems to
prefer black by a little bit but
practically speaking three minutes up on
the clock is Alexander Letterman and I
think he's gotten the kind of position
that he's looking for as he tries to
generate winning chances right out of
the gates with white so as Robin Ponders
his next move he's already spent half
his time let's go back to the bird's eye
view for a moment and take a look at
these interesting positions that we have
Tanya lazovic and gusainov seem to be
playing a very peaceful game but on the
other boards we've got pandemonium
all over the board and take a look at
this I mean at the top right we saw a
shark against Trisha there's so much
happening there and I see that eval bar
seems to say that Trisha's still holding
her own but the position looks
absolutely wild we've have some we've
had some trades shock did get the bishop
pair but maybe not more and I think all
the action is on the paravian uh
Alexander board but this one if Trisha
can hold this position with the white
pieces it's not going to be easy against
shark but oh my God that would be such a
big result for the Garden State passes
a huge result right half a point and
this is what you want to try to do as
board four yes you've got an uphill
battle you're playing four grand Masters
but hey you score a draw you motivate
your teammates you might even score a
win that is the game changer as we saw
in that Charlotte match yesterday Bishop
d8 uh Tanya is an excellent move it
attacks the pawn on C7 and you might say
well I mean that just seems to be a
prosaic one move thread but it's not
that easy to defend against I think the
only thing shock can do is trade Rooks
on E1 yielding the e-file and then
dropping the queen back to D7 and then
Trisha could calmly maneuver her Bishop
back when no shockery are taking a big
risk he sacrifices the pawn and I'm
trying to puzzle out his idea what if
white takes and then takes this he want
Bishop takes H3 let's bring up an
analysis board here for a second what do
you make of this
this is very very tricky and Trisha's
down to four minutes to figure out all
these tactics that you've been pointing
out and I think we have to take a look
at this line notice how that Knight on
F3 hangs so you can pick up the pawn on
H3 with Bishop takes H3 uh the bishop is
not on free if the pawn captures back
you pick up the Knight and White's King
is super weak Also let's just point out
that after Bishop H3 it might look wait
a second the Knight can't jump to G5
forking the queen and the bishop but uh
oh Queen G2 Checkmate game over
absolutely and something that occurred
to me Tanya is that Shakura could also
drop the queen back to E7 and the bishop
is actually trapped so perhaps this is
what he was aiming for and this is what
Trisha has tried to avoid with her last
move just a devilish concept by chakra
we go back to the live board 94 is I
love it Trisha's Choice it's an
excellent move it's a practical move
there's no reason to delve into these
complications I think white is flat out
better Tanya and now Shakira's hand is
forced I think he's got to trade Rooks
and that spells pretty bad news for his
winning chances because you also give
the control of the only open e-file to
White's Queen to enter at the right
moment the only way black can the fan.c7
pawn is falling back with his own Queen
to D7 and that's not a happy Retreat
Daniel in this position now also notice
how shakriar's previous move of moving
that Bishop from the diagonal also gives
access to White's Bishop to land on F6
we might be seeing this playing played
out now white can make the move Bishop
to F6 take control of this diagonal
absolutely I think one move that should
be avoided is Knight to C6 that may look
tempting but after Bishop E7 uh White
needlessly puts herself uh in a fragile
spot Bishop F6 is on the board good call
by you and I think the best that Shakura
can do is play Bishop G7 acquiesce to
the trade of Bishops and the only
scenario that I see in which black wins
this game is If eventually he can get to
these pawns they are on a light Square
so you could imagine if the Queens get
swapped maybe the light squared Bishop
somehow picks up the pawns from behind
but that's a very far-fetched scenario
the most important thing Tanya right now
for Trisha is to play quickly and leave
time on her clock and that is exactly
what she is doing with another excellent
move I'm super impressed I mean this is
just amazing stuff by Trisha now I'm a
huge fan of shock but I'm also always
rooting for the underdog and of course
Trisha is a big Underdog in this match
but she's been so strong up till this
point she has to keep the clock under
control and also not make any big bad
moves because other why shark will be
all over it she Retreats with the Knight
it's still fine everything under control
look at the Pieces Just compare white
pieces to Black species that Bishop on
F6 a monster the Knight on D4 nicely
placed but chakra are here trying to
create a mess on both on the board
trying to make it quick chaotic he
breaks on the queen side with B5 and now
it's a big question for Trisha how does
she react to this Pawn break
and I just don't like Trisha's last move
Knight C6 back to D4 I think a loud
shocker yard to expand and unbalance the
queen side instead I thought the Knight
on C6 could have been supported which
would have taken the sting out of B5 but
still no question of the position
probably objectively is still balanced
I'm expecting Shakura to trade on C4
then that pawn chain is going to be a
little bit more vulnerable later on it
could be attacked more easily By the
Light squared Bishop big question when
is shucker going to go Bishop G7 or is
he just going to live with this bishop
on F6 I would be terrified to live with
that Bishop on F6 Daniel imagine if we
can just move that Knight away from D4
and the bishop Falls all the way back
which might look a bit strange maybe we
can show it with just some arrows on the
board if the queen and the bishop can
line up on the A1 to h8 diagonal that
would be an absolute disaster for black
and just the way you're showing it right
now look at that Queen h8 would be a big
threat and Trisha will she find this
plan will she be able to make this
happen
that's really pretty geometry two long
range pieces uh starting at White's end
of the camp but uh they are no less
powerful because of that we've got a
couple of moves here as Shakura drives
this queen into A4 Trisha responds with
Queen B2 oh no it's a blunder Tanya
because Queen takes C4 wins the pawn oh
no and after Queen C4 Queen B7 check on
C1 check on out oh my friend that Bishop
on F6 the bishop that we thought could
win the game or at least hold it is the
bane of whites and black and pick up F2
as well and then pick up the bishop can
shakariar finds the shocking turnaround
move
of course he'll find that this is so up
his alley tactics attack and creating
these chances he has come in with the
queen he is calculating this line and of
course Trisha missed the point that
after taking that pawn you've got these
two checks picking up that Bishop
hanging piece loose pieces drop off and
that is one of the easiest tactics to
miss in chess Daniel
lpdo and you just know that Shakira sees
it he might be double triple checking
Bishop on F6 it's a loose piece as you
said the king is vulnerable as well and
this is just what happens this is what
top players do what top players do is
they miss winning moves
oh my God
this is this is unreal this is unreal
this is Trisha's chance he has advanced
upon she can now trade it off she can on
Pasa on C6 and trade off a couple of
pieces
boy oh boy is shocker gonna be kicking
himself for this I think after DC Bishop
C6 Knight takes C6 the position
clarifies and as long as Trisha can keep
her C4 Pawn protected she should be able
to hold a draw here she's down in two
minutes
D takes C6 on passant a very practical
move even Queen B3 a more inventive
tactical move also possible to keep the
balance but she shouldn't lose this if
she's careful
I mean she almost did with that one slip
and I'm shocked that chakria did not
spot that tactic that you did uh Daniel
that was a brilliant brilliant sequence
of move that would have wrapped up the
game and given black a huge advantage
and now it's again game on after C5
Trisha can't burn the clock too much she
has to take a decision and she has to do
it fast she Retreats with the night I'm
not too happy about that because the
tactic still exists Daniel
she has given Shakur a second chance
indeed again Queen takes C4 Queen C1
Queen F4 none of the squares are
protected that's another chance and he
misses it again
putting the queen one square uh to the
right just didn't have the strength to
move the queen one further Square Queen
B4 offers a queen trade Trisha says no
way Jose and now she is once again
threatening to move into E8 this Tanya
is very much a three result game
and I'm loving that last move by white
just putting the queen in the open file
and wanting to penetrate all the way to
Black's a background shark gives a check
but it's too late it's in the wrong it's
in the wrong diagonal that he Retreats
the queen what a big opportunity missed
by black here not once but twice
wow that is just incredible now the pawn
on C4 is well protected the bishop
finally moves out of F6 and shakuri are
also settled with the weakness of the D6
Pawn if he plays Bishop G7 you could run
into Bishop E7 it really restricts his
chances I think he might try A5 and
Bishop A6 accumulating pressure on C4
both sides down uh shock around now to
two minutes let's go quickly back to our
bird's eye view because we've got some
fascinating action unfolding on some of
the other boards we will bring you the
end of this game as well I'm looking at
Las Vegas Tanya I'm looking at Leonard
paravian that is in a very sharp end
game by no means is that game decided
either man I don't know where to go it's
like an all-you-can-eat buffet
and I'm still getting my head around the
top board that we just had onward shock
against Trisha I see a queen trade was
declined there and of course the casino
of uh lazavi game is also blowing up
with the queen on E7 almost trapped
and we haven't looked at that game yet
so let's travel to lazovic land and
Dennis lazovic is a name that should be
on every chess Fan's radar he's won
multiple title Tuesday uh Tuesdays
recently his Grandmaster title has
finally been confirmed Tanya
um he was and I am in name only and I
think he's just winning he sacrificed in
exchange but look at his Center and I
think the ingenious Queen H4 allows him
to indirectly defend the pawn on e4
because after Queen H4 rookie 4 Knight
G5 decides he does the same thing right
Queen F6 and Rook takes E4 fails to
Knight G5
very nice idea because you're not only
hitting the Rook but also the pawn on F7
and that would be an absolute disaster
I'm loving White's Center and yes white
has sacrificed an exchange but that is
for one Pawn so if we do the math it's
only uh it's four points for white with
a bishop and a pawn for a five-pointer
rook for black but still look at that
Center giving white so much compensation
and a nasty threat on the board white
can't jump in with the queen to eight
six and bring that Knight to G5
threatening a mate that cannot be
defended on eight seven
you can see the eval bar continually
creeping up no plus five it's not an
exaggeration and Dennis doesn't even
need to hurry he can play Slow moves
like Rook D2 or A3 further banishing
this Knight I don't know how gusanov is
gonna try to turn this around he is
incredibly tricky he's trying to
generate some action on the queen side
but Dennis has also managed his time
impeccably he's uh on three minutes he's
got plenty of time to figure this out I
think E5 uh is good here I think A3 is
possible your move Queen H6 lots of
options here for white the most
important thing is obviously not to
blunder one of these Center Pawns
he could Advance either of these two
pawns D6 E5 all these very very
attractive moves but instead Dennis
takes it easy which is also really cool
because he just puts the ball in Black's
court and as he's running as gosinov
runs down on the clock it's going to be
more difficult to answer questions when
eventually white does advance the Pawns
of course Dennis doesn't care about the
A2 Pawn the action is in the center and
the King side and E5 on the board
yep and this is firmly under control for
Dennis lastovic I think he's going to
win this game and I think that means we
need to go back to her bird's eye view
we've been there a lot but our top board
our our board one board four matchup
continues to heat up both players under
a minute there is a knight on E8 and
look at the board to the right of it
Alexander Letterman has lost a knight it
was a drawable end game but he
mishandled it and David paravian has
great winning chances if he can keep the
pawn on e4 alive but let's go right to
our top board Tanya what on Earth is
going on here
I I'm not sure what I do see is that
Trisha has managed to win upon after
blundering twice in this game which
shock did not take advantage of white
has an extra Pawn in the position look
at Black's King it is open that night
for me it can give a huge check on F6
while black does win the pawn back on C4
but at the cost of really weakening his
King
wow db7 check is literally almost only
Bishop E7 forced is there a knockout I
don't think so I think Trisha should
move her Knight away capture the bishop
and the opposite colored Bishops should
give her a draw there but 10 seconds on
the clock this is where Panic often sets
in for the lower rated player and Knight
G8 has been found hi Trisha
foreign
oh my God she's now losing
Knight h61 on the spot Knight H6 check
forced the king onto a square such such
that the queen can then move away with
check here the bishop captures with Jack
Tanya this is heartbreaking
oh my God what a big Miss 986 would have
just won the queen on the spot unreal
and we see Trisha on the screen she's
definitely checking that Daniel what a
game she played and we see shock he
knows he has survived this by the thread
what a game that was just I can't
believe what we just saw 986 and shock
would have lost gosh and look at that
final position it's just a stroke of bad
luck the Knight on E7 is literally
trapped so she goes from winning to
losing there is nowhere for the night to
go frustration on the face of Trisha
Kanye morala who could have scored the
biggest upset of the PCL so far but
round one continues and the other games
continue to heat up Valentina gunina has
a chance to score a huge upset against
Samuel Savion she was completely winning
just a couple of moves ago but Tanya she
has mishandled it as well and a devilish
strap that was set by Sam Sabian look
what he just did rewinding two moves ago
Queen E7 pretending to blunder Rook
takes D4 Valentina already up in
exchanged and this seems to end the game
but no it doesn't Queen F6 is a fork F2
and D4 are hanging and I think Savion
might even be in the driver's seat now
wow that is a nice sneaky tactic that by
Simon a really important point after
Trisha lost to shock uh the Wizards are
leading the match now is it all that bad
Daniel yes you do lose that Rook on on
D4 but it's not all over because look at
the peace activity that white has black
can pick up the rook and you can jump in
with your own Rook to E6 he does hit
that Queen she does it black has to move
the queen but yes Sam has survived this
one from a really bad position
and I've played sam7 enough times to
know when he's starting to turn the game
around now under a minute is Valentina
gunina her King is under Fire the threat
might be Bishop takes F2 check so if you
play Queen takes D6 and Bishop takes F2
is a is a deadly Desperado that drives
the king out of the shell Valentina has
to find the cold-blooded capture on D6
but not with the queen with the Rook not
fearing a check on C1 because the king
can move up to G2 but now 30 seconds
Tanya and Ken Valentina avoid the Panic
that sets in so often
just unbelievable stuff and not only
does she have to evaluate the checks and
see one if you pick up that bond with
the Rook she has to keep in mind that
the bishop can fall back to E5 hit that
Rook on D6 hit that pawn on H2 and she
needs to understand how that position is
not easy in 30 seconds she chooses to
bail out by offering a queen trade and
you know what Sam does what you said
Daniel he says the momentum has shifted
the attack is on yorking my king is safe
how are you going to defend F2 and this
has gone all wrong for the levitor
Wizards Valentina has to recapture with
the bishop allowing The Rook to
penetrate F2 now Sam is not only up a
pawn but with Bishop E5 he's gonna win
not one but two other pawns and he might
also pick up the bishop yes he does what
absolutely insane and he wins The Rook
as well I mean this is and say this is
one minute of unbelievable action Sam
sebian wins another game for the Wizards
and Dennis lazovic is the last remaining
game because uh David paravian has won
as well crazy it's three to zero could
have been at least two to one Dennis
lazovic seems to be finishing off gadir
gussenov are we gonna see 4-0
no Sam Champion one we're gonna see
three one yeah right now some did manage
to save a very difficult position but
Daniel you're absolutely right it very
well could have been 3-0 if Valia would
have just found that tactic uh giving up
uh that Rook on D4 which didn't work out
and what are we seeing here white has
got a bishop but black has a pawn and 13
seconds uh wow this is just dead lost
for black
and as they say on Twitch easy clap
Tanya 20 seconds for Dennis he pushes
the pawn gusana is going to resign now
any second this was a wire to wire
Victory by the Bella Russian Grandmaster
just such a strong positional player in
control of the game and he gives the
Fearsome levittov Wizards a 3-1 lead
what did we just see this is gonna take
me some time to just settle in we saw
what makes the protest league so special
Daniel that game with Trisha was a shock
was the game for me it did not go it did
not go Trisha's way but what a fight she
put up not only what a fight she was
completely dead winning against one of
the best players in the world and yes
it's a 3-1 Victory but that scoreboard
that result is not reflective of the
chest that we just saw
absolutely not Trisha should hold her
head up high and I think her performance
in this game bodes well for her chances
to score an upset later obviously very
important not to Tilden Sam Seville and
with that Swindle against valagunina uh
gives uh the passers a fighting chance
that very easily could have been a 4-0
blowout and of course the first team to
eight and a half wins the match so
ladies and gentlemen this is just the
beginning this was just round one the
Garden State passers have their work cut
out for them they will need a big
performance in round two to avoid
digging themselves deeper in the hole
and we will see if they will be able to
do that on the other side of this short
break
foreign
to our new video lecture series here
with the one and only the 14th World
chess champion vishwanathon and on if
you have to explain that you're world
champion and it's taking longer than two
words there's something wrong with the
adventure there's something wrong but I
believe in when we're talking the 60s
and 70s even the 80s and 90s
you could see that
the match format produced something
unique and I remember there was a funny
moment at the press conference where
I was trying to tone it down
not get very excited and also I had not
had time to collect myself in fact I
already wanted to calm down and think of
the next game because I knew this is a
wounded animal there I knew that I had
to play a game against a man who was
desperate for the match to be over so
that he could clinch his title he wanted
a draw at any price I mean you can make
a joke that he had spent a week out of
the swimming pool already so he must
have been exhausted and waiting to
finish so for all of us there was this
feeling of
um we got to grab this chance with both
hands because it's not going to come by
with it
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
welcome back to the pro chess League
Daniel nerdinski Tanya such they're
bringing you coverage of this
fascinating second day of action Tanya I
am out of breath and we're just getting
started because round two is upon us as
the Levitt off chest Wizards lead three
to one more fascinating matchups coming
right up
action from the word go and there is so
much good to take away for Garden State
bosses and James Canty III can't lose
hope just yet I mean Trisha's game
against shock what a match that was and
we're up for round two uh Daniel this is
going to be a close one Garden State
passes have to give it their all levitov
a big favorite they have taken the lead
but we've seen comebacks we've seen
turnarounds we saw one yesterday by your
team as well taking it down to the wire
and with what I saw in that first
matchup this one is going to be super
close
it is indeed we see Sam sebian playing
Dennis lazovic that's a game he really
needs to try to win with white same goes
for gadir a gusainov and Trisha Kanye
morala we talked about her performance
against shakuri Arma Madara of how close
she came uh to scoring the
potentially biggest upset of the entire
PCL she was one move away from winning
the whole thing unfortunately she missed
the move
she lost the game and that is just how
it goes Tanya absolutely now a guarder
gusanov against Valia gunina Valia has
lost the first game gusinov needs to
strike for the Garden State passes it's
a very important board for them Sam
savian against lazavic if The Underdogs
want to make a comeback another very
crucial board these two are playing with
the white pieces and Daniel they need to
go all out of course Trisha is an
underdog in that team and for her it is
her first time in the PCL playing
against all these Top Guns it's going to
be a tough day but if he if she can even
save half a point on any game against
any of these players that is a big
victory for the garden bosses
we have the team captain James Canty
wearing the captain hat today
commentating yesterday he says we ain't
losing hope it's three to one uh eight
and a half wins the match that's five
and a half more points that leviedov has
to score plenty of Chess left to be
played and I can confirm Tanya as the
games kick off that when you're sitting
in the hot seat and you can sense that
the win is at hand you just stop
thinking it's just so nerve-wracking
that two-second increment evaporates in
what seems like a millisecond but moving
on it's three to one it's round two and
the games have kicked off Shakura with
the white pieces against Alexander
Linderman well the Garden State passes
have to take it one round at a time now
we've got shock right he is one of the
best players in the world what a player
just super aggressive super attacking
but Daniel what we saw in game one I'm
not sure if shock is finding his rhythm
he missed he missed the two move tactic
twice on the board something we never
see from a player like chakra or mama
diaro so Lindeman I wonder if he's able
to create his chances again shock it's
not going to be easy but my only thing
is he's shocking fun today
yeah and I mean you called it that is a
tactic that we just expect it's a bygone
conclusion that top players see stuff
like that a hundred times out of a
hundred but we forget sometimes that
they're human uh they miss stuff and a
pretty disturbing sign uh for Shakur
Ahmad Yara who has to display Stellar
form today for the performance of the
top player is absolutely crucial to the
success of the team as Magnus Carlson
showed yesterday so Shakura taking a
slightly more conservative approach in
the opening playing a little bit more
positionally which is often what you do
if you can sense that some of the
tactics are slipping away from you we
had a slob Tanya that has morphed into
some sort of weird semi tarash I don't
even know what structure we're gonna get
it started a sort of a Sami slav and now
we've got a samitarash a black has made
a lot of pawn moves in the opening as we
saw which of course results in giving
white this lead in development what has
been shock has been able to get his King
to safety take out that bishop and I
think that is the point he saw what
happened in game one he wants to take it
slow not get into a messy position right
out of the opening because Lenderman is
also quite the tactician he will not
miss the chances that Trisha did and we
see some trades in the center which
might result in Black Landing up with an
isolated Queen spawn on D5 absolutely I
think Shakira should take back with the
Knight and I think he will cement a
slight Advantage out of the opening
exactly what he was looking for but game
two has also begun so we can go uh just
very quickly here to the bird's eye view
the games are staggered to allow us to
watch the start of each game and the
second game is between David paravian
who plays Trisha Kanye morale a big
challenge for her as she faces a
fearsome one E4 player with the black
pieces and she is beating him at the top
I love it we have a Rouser Sicilian as
sharp as it gets Tanya
Trisha really has so much to be happy
about from that game one she needs to
get that same fearlessness that same
combative style of play and that's what
the opening seems to imply with the
black pieces she has taken this position
which has a weird Pawn structure with
black you know very often we say don't
double your pawns but they also are a
big Shield to black skin very often we
actually see black just keeping that
King in the center because take a look
at how boxed up it really is over there
with the two Bishops in front of it with
the Pawns in front of it and we see a
night trade here and pick it up with a
bishop I'll get that E4 Pawn
whoa I I was really sure that Trisha was
going to take back with a pawn and these
Sicilian positions when you can open the
B file that gives you a major boost on
the queen side so I'm going to rewind
here for a second uh Tanya if we could
bring up an announce board I think that
BC was the key to developing a rapid
Queen side attack also D5 is in the
cards as well so let's take a neutral
move like Bishop D3 the attack comes
really really fast D5 and then the queen
comes out to B6 and most importantly
once The Rook comes to B8 if black can
induce uh the move B3 then the dark
squid Bishop comes in I really think
that was an important move to make
instead Trisha recaptures with the
bishop and not only does that keep the
queen side closed Tanya but it enables
white to put more pressure on the E6
pawn bishop C4 might actually Force
black to lose another Tempo dropping her
Bishop back and that's pretty bad news
out of the opening for Trisha
it is all about trying to fight for that
D5 Square so you do make that F pawn
move to provoke black to decide in the
center and look at it it's already
getting a little bit weak I think that
was a very good point that black had to
create counter play along the B file by
now Bishop C4 targeting that E6 Pawn the
only other way to defend it would be to
step up with your queen uh not retreat
with the bishop you never want to push
that pawn one square ahead because it
creates so many light squared weaknesses
especially that D5 Square you never want
to give that up in the Sicilian
yeah a move that you could get kicked
out of you know a Soviet chess camp for
if uh my coach saw a move like E5 the
lesson would be over but Trisha she is
alert Queen D7 is I think the only way
to preserve a feasible position and for
David paravian I think the main plan
right now is to find a way to get this
Knight into the center if you can get
the Knight to D4 or to F4 if you can
force E5 then the game basically ends
but it's not as simple as that time in
because 92 obviously blunders this very
important Pawn on e4 so maybe starting
with a slower move like Rook H E1 makes
sense I mean it also step up to D3 uh to
lend another Defender to the pawn so I
think Trisha is in a lot of danger she
has to start attacking on the very next
move and I think that is super important
we've been talking about trying to open
up the queen size so that Trisha can
Target that King on C1 B5 will come in
with the tempo we're gonna see this heat
up we also have more action that started
we've been talking about Sam Savion he
survived a scam air against Valentina
gunina in that first game but took
advantage of the momentum as soon as it
shifted and won a big point for the
Golden State passes let's bring up our
bird's eye view as we've got action on
that board again he takes on Dennis
lazovic with the white pieces and I see
a lot of Trades there
we have a lot of action over 10 minutes
uh from Sam Seville I mean the game
barely started and we already have an
end game four has also begun that's on
the bottom right of your screen we have
a tardikauer Karo Khan but I'm gonna go
right to the Sam sebian game here the
Queens are off the board I am still
counting the pawns time I feel like
that's all I'm doing today is counting
the pawns the pawns are equal and do not
be deceived by the incredibly
unappealing nature of whites on
structure to put it mildly I don't even
want to count the pawn Islands what
makes this so difficult to play for
black is the fact that Black's pieces
are just not coming out Bishop D7 is
going to be met with Knight C5 sending
the bishop back and God forbid if you
play E5 to try to open the diagonal then
you walk into Bishop D5 this looks like
a very unenviable situation out of uh
what started as a kind of unique Catalan
what brought by Savion as usual foreign
this is a trade-off you've got a hideous
Bond structure a bit in return you've
got peace activity especially that
Bishop on G2 Throwing Fire Down the
board all along the h1a8 diagonal really
targeting the B7 pawn and that Knight on
B3 that can jump to a key Square C5 but
meanwhile I also see trumps for
lazavic's position here Dennis can jump
with his own Knight and Target that C4
weakness that you have been mentioning
the Knight can come to A5 The Rook can
slide down uh to the other side of the
board from F7 all the way to C7 and put
pressure on C4 this is going to be a
strategic end game and look at Sam's
clock situation he's got more time than
he started with Daniel
unbelievable and the importance of that
cannot be emphasized enough he's already
up three minutes and do not be fooled by
the ebub or yes it's showing 0.00 but
guess what the top engine move is here
H7 H6 who can play like that just
basically doing nothing and waiting for
white to put his cards on the table if
we could bring up an analysis board I
think the idea of a waiting move like H6
is that white actually paradoxically
doesn't have too many ways to improve
his position because the moment Knight
C5 is played The Rook slides over to C7
X during the night and creating what you
pointed out the threat of Knight E5 but
the funny thing is that if you start
with the Rook C7 then white has the
possibility of taking on C6 and after
rooked ac6 there is a beautiful tactic
and this tactic reveals the point of H6
welcome to computer chess ladies and
gentlemen 95
and whichever way you take or if you
don't take you get mated On Da that is
ridiculous stuff and that is definitely
within Sam seville's preparation Tanya
wow I love this shot that you're
pointing out if you take the Knight The
Rook from F1 suddenly opens up taking
away all the Escape squares from lacking
what a checkmate
you needed that square
and that's why it's six this really
explains why the computer wanted 86 on
the board but of course Knight A5 which
was played is a very human approach and
a human move when you're just playing a
ten plus two format he puts pressure on
C4 but white simply Advance with the
pawn takes away more squares from black
and again it just feels like black is
breathing a little less it just feels a
little bit more passive for uh for
Dennis here in this position but there's
so much fire across the boards and
Daniel what do you say we call up for a
full board scene and take a look at
what's happening all around because it's
Madness
it is indeed and it's pretty clear that
Sam sebian is in the driver's seat and
likely to be in the driver's seat for a
while top right of your screen you can
see the main plan in action the Knight
has swung back to E2 uh where it heads
over to D4 it's a life or death
situation for Trisha who has to prevent
that idea at all costs and she is trying
uh as she drives her Bishop up to B5
attacking the queen we might see a trade
of that Bishop for white snipe at that
E6 Pawn uh is going to cause her trouble
for a long time uh Tanya we also have
craziness on board four between garier
gusainov and Valencia naguna what do you
say we take a trip to Karo con land
I love it I mean take a look at that
position what has black done with the
Pawns in front of the king now now all I
know about Chess is that you know you've
got this Pawn Shield once you've Castle
keep it safe especially in these rapid
and Blitz format you don't want to
attack against your king but this is not
in chess and gunina doesn't care about
any of that she has advanced the pawns
but I'm just wondering if this is way
too ambitious and is this going to end
up with huge light squared weaknesses
the queen can't jump into G4 and jump
into H5 at a certain moment it just
feels very shaky for uh for black right
now but watch out don't move that night
right now Daniel to just show the black
ideas in this position if you go Knight
to H5 it might still be fine but black
has a devious threat of Queen coming
into H2 with a huge check and once the
king moves up the bishop can join the
attack because notice that Rook on E8 it
has taken away all the squares for the
king to escape to the e-file
and that means after Queen takes G3 the
King has to slink back to G1 Bishop on
D3 is picked up a very devious concept
by Valentina gunina and just look at the
last move played by Gator gusana if he
met the move Queen D6 with Knight to F4
relying on the fact that GF runs into
Queen G4 check with obvious uh just
mating consequences just a brilliant uh
concept by the azeri Grand Master I'm
easy to miss Daniel easy to miss that
after Knight F4 actually The Rook on E8
was also targeted so really somehow a
lot of tactics here all across the board
it's it's so easy to make a mistake here
I didn't see that done yet I was
thinking about GF and calculating Queen
she was now winning no Rook 98 is
hanging your right and if husseinav uh
if gunina uh rather would have taken on
E1 yielding the e-file here is
absolutely deadly because the Rook could
make its way to E8 just further
crippling the prospect of Black's Queen
side development so that's not an option
it's especially in a rapid game instead
we have Queen G4 on the board the pawn
on G5 is now pinned and Valentina she
needs to try to keep her pawns as well
protected as possible maybe a move like
Knight f8 to H7 is what the doctor
ordered here it doesn't look pretty it's
not going to win you a brilliant
surprise but you need to prevent uh the
the prospect of some sort of Bishop
sacrifice on G5 and what's more Tanya
Knight H5 is now on the horizon because
that line we showed earlier no longer
works you can give the check on H2 but
after King F2 if the Knight lands on H5
it's going to protect G3 taking the
sting out of Bishop G3 check
and that is a key point with that Queen
on G4 which also adds to the defense of
that G3 square and after all the trades
white will actually just end up winning
that pawn on G3 so Knight H5 is a big
threat and wow Valia just made a
shocking move uh it's I mean so much is
hanging I'm trying to get my head around
it she moves the Knight she blocks the
pin look at the amount of pins that are
on the board Daniel what's going on the
F5 Pawn cannot pick up that Knight on G6
because suddenly the Bishop from D7 will
win the queen on G4 and once again don't
move that knight from F4 to G6 because
you've got the queen jumping in with a
check tactics tactics everywhere you
know what I know I know that eval bar
didn't like this move but it's one of
those moves which says all right white I
can tell you that you've got an
advantage but prove it to me and as a
human that's not easy
probability of a blunder here is like
100 this is crazy and as you said you
can almost consider the Knight on F4 to
be pinned because if you move it
anywhere except H5 and queen H2 Bishop
G3 is a deadly mechanism that is why I
think white should proceed with his main
plan and go Knight H5 just say hey you
put your knight on G6 I don't care that
Knight isn't actually doing anything and
the move Knight H4 Knight H5 will put
tremendous strain on the F6 Pawn I'm not
going to pretend like I know what's
going on here we are aided by the eval
bar that is giving at this point a
decisive Advantage for white and it's
possible Tanya the Valentina might have
forgotten that the move Knight H5 guards
the G3 square and if Queen H2 isn't
effective then black just kind of runs
out of ideas on the king side
wow and I I really like how the Knight
is equally an attacker but also a key
defender in White's position from that
H5 Square the one thing that gusunov has
to make sure that he doesn't do is trade
off that Knight on G6 currently and it's
really a big moment here which can
decide the outcome of the game Valentina
garina asking some big questions to
White hair because you know going in a
think tank and taking his time because
it's it's everything is hanging
currently so really critical moment here
in this game
a critical moment indeed and a great
moment for us because we have uh the
captain of the I want to say the Golden
State passers but no the Garden State
pastors James Canty he wears many hats
he wore the commentator hat yesterday
bday Master James Canty III how are you
feeling right now as you're watching
your team try to erase this two-point
deficit I'm feeling good I'm feeling
good in the team of course you started
just like this right yesterday you
remember this Dania Dania you was there
you was here yesterday right and you was
down to you know to first start like
that right when uh after the first round
it was like three to one right so it's
the same thing we in the same hot seat
here but of course now everything
everybody's warmed up I think they're
ready especially we had Trisha here
about to take down Shaq I was screaming
I was like let's go and I was literally
in the in my in my room like just like
oh my goodness about to knock everything
over off the table because she she
missed it right but it happens like that
of course this is very fun to see and um
right now we wouldn't know we got some
winning positions so this looks good so
let's see what happens
James what a game that was we were just
super impressed with Trisha's play in
that one I mean she's clearly uh the
lowest rated player in this field but to
shock it was just looked like she was
going to take that entire point away and
I can imagine the nerves I want to ask
you that in between rounds does the
captain have the possibility to talk to
the players
yeah you know that's a good question uh
I actually have not seen that in the
rule book that is not that you can't do
that right so of course but uh they
don't have that much time in between we
don't have that much time and
everybody's we have to stream over here
we're watching we want people to
understand look we're here for you
everybody's watching them there's a lot
of pressure on them too as well so we're
gonna do her thing there and we also
give them the pep talk beforehand so
we'll hear yeah he said golden what was
the best what was the yeah what was the
pep talk like before today's matchup
give us some insight on that
we cannot give away this we don't have
to okay I'm gonna give you my PayPal
Tanya okay I'm gonna give you my PayPal
you got to send that over right so um
but at the same time we just say okay
everybody play your best game it is what
it is like we can go out here we're
gonna play great chess right keep it
positive right and play and uh we'll be
brought you here because we know what
you can do and also um play your best
games that's really what it's about this
is pretty easy really just you know
motivational you can do this you know
Rocky type talk right because that's
what you need really in these type of
games and this type of format with PCL
and these strong players that you're
playing it's really really difficult you
can also like you know yesterday I mean
I was I was rooting for Danny I'm like
oh you go to this Magnus you got the
Kings Indian I'm happy you know because
me and him love King's Indian defenses
like we know that so seeing it happen
I'm like oh this rock solid and then
Magnus does some Magnus stuff and it's
ridiculous right so you know it was it
you never know in these type of games
you also that game yesterday with a
Wonder a Wonder should have won oh my
goodness that's the like Swindle of the
year it was really crazy right so I mean
anything can happen in these formats and
I know we got some good things coming
our way so let's go and you said Golden
State pastors too Daniel I was high
because I say that all the time I'm like
Golden State pastors I mean Garden
Garden State let's not let's not talk
about the Warriors yes I'm I'm
withdrawing my fandom of so so you know
at this point uh golden state is on my
black list but Garden State passers are
doing pretty well James this round let's
get your opinion on a couple of the
keyboards I can only imagine James how
nerve-wracking it is to sit there you
know what the winning move is you're
tearing your hair out and you're just
praying that they find it and it's just
nerve-wracking from both situations
whether you're the player or the captain
or the manager we've pulled up the top
board between Shakura mamidarov and your
boy Alexander Lenderman who seems to be
doing not to jinx him a great job of
stabilizing what was initially a
slightly worse position out of the
opening what do you think about this you
know I actually have been with Linderman
I've known him a very long time he
actually comes to Michigan quite often
he's been to Detroit a lot
um to help the kids here and actually
done simos so personally no lender man
so to have them on the team I mean it
was just amazing I'm like absolutely
Lindy let's get it right so Linderman is
um a very strong player he played in U.S
Championship many times too as well
extremely strong his in-game knowledge
is very very like next level I love that
he's in the end game right now in this
position right here I mean he's sort of
in-gamish obviously the Queens are still
on but definitely some type of end game
I think the White's King is a little bit
weaker and black can try to press
especially with the weakness on A3 we
King as well so I definitely see A3 is a
problem actually right now too if he
pushes A4 Bishop A4
um is coming as well there's a 93
automatically steal even if you play A4
there's lots of tricks in the position I
think black is more active and because
of that we have chances what's the time
looking like at time I mean it's about
even yeah Queen D3 stopped it right very
solid player I think we have very good
chances here of two results is what I'm
gonna say
I agree Knight to D4 is the last move
and shocker are trying to get some
pieces off the board the more pieces off
the board the more comfortable white
skin feels I think for Alex it's very
important to keep this Pawn on T5 as
well protected as possible but Tanya we
were discussing earlier Alexander he's
so good in time pressure he's a great
end game player I can confirm that and I
like his position right now yeah it's
looking good it looks like he's got
everything under control and James today
is such a big match for uh the Garden
State buses and I want to ask you now
you have picked for today's lineup uh
Alexander lender man you've got Trisha
you've got gusainov and Sam savian what
went into the thought process of picking
these players today against the levitov
Wizards yeah it really just a little bit
of availability but also at the same
time in any uh looking at the matchup
looking at the lineup who they have
right obviously and they're just going
in with that really just giving
everybody a shot because we have some
other players that are playing as well
too so we want to mix everybody in there
just get people out there see what we
can do in this room first match here and
go from there and who are the players
that you're looking at scoring big today
on your team
yeah definitely big Sam big Sam I Am
Green Eggs and all of ham Sam is
definitely the man right I guess saying
off too as well and I mean honestly all
of them we're looking for them we're
looking for our best chess um from
Trisha here today and she's doing he's
absolutely that she was actually winning
against Shaq that's I mean yes you lost
the game but be very proud of yourself
for taking it to Shack like that
especially uh you know playing with the
white pieces there so it's pretty uh
pretty awesome game I think from her um
and she can do more of this we know she
can't right so but Sam I Am is gonna go
crazy 26 87 right now going going uh
going off is also is great as well 26 uh
50 60 right now so he's doing well and
Linderman is also one that we know won't
drop points I mean Linderman is he may
not win every game but he's not gonna
lose I mean that's the thing about
London I like about that too as well you
need that guy to just oh
but James I I feel like yeah go ahead
Tanya was gonna say crazy stuff
happening please just what what's going
on here
well James we're gonna let you enjoy
this moment and we know you're feeling
nervous so we'll let you focus uh on
watching your team play but it does look
like bad news for Alexander Letterman
James uh we will let you manage your
team and give them thank you so much for
making I'm gonna call him right now
after this one yeah all right chat love
y'all yeah I'm about to get on the phone
all righty in a minute yep foreign
do your thing the captain of the Garden
State passers and a commentator he is a
force major but Tanya this was
frustrating Linderman had a chance for
an advantage he had to play Bishop B5
before Queen B2 instead he meant the
other move order and now he finds
himself down three pawns but the game
isn't over White's King is still in a
little bit of trouble
not only the white king watch out notice
that Knight on E2 which is on the fire
with the queen and the bishop ironed
right now black has a huge threat on the
board black wants to go Bishop takes
Knight and if you recapture that Bishop
with your queen the central Bishop on D5
will be hanging so yes uh White does
have a lot a big Advantage extra pawns
but just playing on oh seconds for both
these players anything can happen
and F5 there apparently was strong but
94 check the King has to dodge a couple
of bullets here Shakira gives up the
pawn on E3 but bad news for Alex as he
brings his Queen back it looks like
shock has stabilized his game position
and if I'm on the drf I'm trying to keep
at least 10 seconds on my clock I think
you can just keep pushing the king side
pawns instead he goes King H3 allowing a
check on F2 a repetition of moves and
now he initiates the process not over
yet Tanya Lenderman going hither and
thither and to the left and to the right
and threatening forks and checks and
captures and chakra has to stay on his
feet here Bishop B4 on the board
oh my God I can't keep up every move is
a thread or every move is a check and
watch out with the queen at night things
can get so dangerous for white skin look
at that Knight F2 is a big fork that is
being threatened and white comes back
with the king and a check again will we
see a repetition
he goes for a queen G1 here Queen G1 is
a big chance for Alex instead he goes
back to E3
shocker has to find some way to keep his
King safe and get this Pawn to G5 and H6
he's allowed Knight takes a five oh that
was that was a Perpetual check
that was a Perpetual check missed by
Lenderman wow and instead
of escape
this is insane 86 was winning there
eight six was winning that but he was
probably afraid of a check with the
queen on G2 so he defends that now the
Knight falls back again and the Knight
is coming to F2 with the check both
players down to seconds this just it's
playing for all three results and draw
is the least likely absolutely so easy
to miss a fork here H6 I think is still
winning Knight F2 check and can you do
but Chuck trying to play with an
abundance of caution I don't know why
he's not pushing his H Pawn he's down to
eight seconds now keeps moving the
bishop back and forth Letterman's gonna
go second to anyone no he's gonna go to
F1 made threat on H2 Queen H3 is made in
one Queen H2 is made in one oh my God
this is on the other side we need five
minutes
it's on the board oh what uh what did we
just see
this was insane there was a draw a
four-straw missed by Letterman we're
gonna show you that later because right
now we've got more crazy action on the
other boards Tanya this is insane we're
back to the bird's eye view we see David
paravian who has defeated Trisha Kanye
morala a very solid game but Sam Sevin
is locked in a crazy tactical battle
against Dennis lazovic let's go straight
to that game
help me help me out your knight takes a
six is the last move on the board
I mean my first question is what did
that night even capture on A6
oh that was a problem that he took on A6
and it comes in with a check and the
point is that the Knight on B5 hangs so
everything still makes sense you know
I'm still catching up my breath with
what we just saw that is shock your mom
made out of surviving his second scare
of the day and then he takes that point
home
kaisa seems to be on shock side today
shocked just not as crisp as we are
accustomed to in time pressure but he's
done just enough to keep his opponents
at Bay 96 Chuck was an excellent move by
Dennis lazovic he gives his Knight away
but forces Sam to get rid of his passer
and uh he is a Garden State passer he's
trying to get the better King position
in this Pawn end game Tanya this is an
actually pretty unclear end game white
spawn structure is worse but his King
position is better it is a draw
according to the eval bar but let's see
if Dennis lazovic can keep White's King
at Bay I think he should claim the
opposition with King D7 that would be my
instinct and I think white skin cannot
cross over all the way from the bottom
of the board and go too far because
black skin will also advance and start
targeting the double Central pawns so he
goes King to E6 and now he's going to
fall back he goes F5 oh also which is a
huge blender
I was gonna say it makes sense but why
is this a blunder I think you have to
take twice and once I can just get a
flag oh my God he almost flagged King T5
he's going to shoulder blacks King off
of the epon king F4 E4 H5 H4 and black
is going to be in zugspong this is a
huge huge moment for Sam sebian he has
to win this game to keep the passers in
this match and it appears that he's
going to do just that King D4 or H4 H4
might run into King G4 and might give
some chances but the valbar says this is
lost as well because Black's King is
stuck trying to get that pawn into the
game
he's walked into a check Tanya H3 King
G1 H2 and black is going to promote with
check that was a terrible move by seven
and he's allowed to draw what is
happening you don't on the Square way up
opponent Queens with a check and that's
happened and here we see seven shaking
his head what a big Miss by Sam oh my
God all he had to do was push his pawns
the pawns would have promoted
simultaneously but in the resulting
position white would have checkmated
Black's King there we see frustration on
Sam sebian's face he came oh so close to
swindling that pawn on him let me show
really quickly Tanya all he had to do E5
E6 now what he saw is that the pawns
promote simultaneously but in this
situation Black's King is in the worst
possible spot this is a very famous end
game we need to check if King H3 and
queen G4 G3 is made and this is a very
well known position it's queen against
Queen but Checkmate is Unstoppable 8 big
Miss ism7 compounded by gadir gusainov
who has won his game against Valentina
gunina to keep the Garden State passers
in this match but it could have been 2-2
it could have been two and a half one
and a half if Letterman drew his game
another frustrating round for James
Canty's team Tanya
this is the unbelievable stuff what
we have the opportunity to maybe at some
point just bring up that analysis board
one more time because I think I know
what white wanted he wanted to come down
with his King but we'll talk about that
a little more a little later take a look
at this Garden State passes here go down
once again but really the score could
have been even Sam with a winning end
game and just uh misses that at the very
last moment and now things are getting
really tough for James Canty the third
for his team to make a comeback
the margins are Getting Thinner and
thinner because the first seem to eight
and a half wins and we will go on a
break but before we do we wanted to
remind you of a very exciting event on
February 20th chess played quick returns
watch your favorite streamers battle our
AI Bots blame bounties and Vie for their
share of a prize fund of 2 000 twitch
subs don't miss this month's cpq chess
play quick it's on February 20th it's at
9 00 a.m Pacific noon New York time use
x Glam cpq in chat for more info well
we'll have more info on this PCL match
uh between the passers and the Wizards
but first we're going to give the
players a breather round three ladies
and gentlemen coming your way on the
other side of this break
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done 100 AD
free Bliss forevermore whether you're
following our events on site or on
stream type the command connect in the
chat and thank you for helping bring
these shows to life
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
in competitive chess
the weight of a win draw or loss is all
on one's shoulders
it's easy to feel alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my gosh
the protest league is back
once again in chess teammates matter he
is just upset he's got a hand in his
head he can't believe it what what what
are you doing welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives oh wait a minute maggots
could win this game a 20 for black how
does Magnus Carlson do this entering its
Fifth Season 16 teams will reboot the
PCL Legacy with a new format and new
schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL champion this tough out here India
is a Powerhouse
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
welcome back to the pro chess League a
ridiculously exciting day of action as
we are watching the first of two ecl
matches on this amazing Wednesday I am
Tanya suchdev and GM Daniel nerdinsky
chopping it up for you today and we are
entering round three of our first match
between the Wizards and the Garden State
passers who are staring down the barrel
of a three-point deficit Tanya it's five
and a half two and a half and the
customers need only three more points to
win the entire match as we look at the
individual scores with impressive
performances by mamidyarov and paravian
who both have a perfect two out of two
eight and a half is the golden spot and
we can see that the lavator of Chess
visits have already scored five and a
half points in their matchup Daniel it
could be over in this upcoming round if
levitov are able to score three game
points and of course the star players in
their show so far has been shock and
David Bravia and we see them with two
out of two they've had two wins but not
without hiccups now Shakura momedaro
especially has had a bumpy road both
games the results could have gone either
way meanwhile for the Golden State
bosses Sam Savion has been their star
player their MVP so far he needs to keep
the scoreboard alive for them to get a
chance in round four
he absolutely does they basically need
to be perfect and it's going to be hard
to be perfect given uh the lineups and
the match-ups uh in round three because
chakra mamidyarov he's got black against
Hussein off David barabian is black
against Sam sebian basically a must win
or sebian and Valentina Guna she has
lost both of her games thus far but
she's a Powerhouse of the white piece as
she was winning her first game against
Evian and she has another chance to
strike uh to Alexander landerman lazovic
as white against Kanye Morales so let's
not mince words it's you know Garden
State has to be perfect they need crazy
good performances on all of the boards a
4-0 victory would go a long way short a
miracle come back
it is a Goldberg or go home moment here
in today's matchup for the Garden State
passes Slenderman has to make sure of
walia's shaky performance but Lenderman
himself has not been able to make the
most of those critical moments and those
opportunities and we see the players are
ready to start this round three Daniel
you got gusanov with the white pieces
shock with the black pieces kosanov has
to try to make the most of this
opportunity and he starts with the
kingspawn opening are we going to see an
Italian or a Spanish or Spanish it is I
think we're going to see an open Spanish
soccer yard is one of the leading
specialists in the world uh in the open
relope that's where black takes on e4 in
response to Castle short so that is a
line Checker has studied backwards and
forwards he knows that theory up to move
20 or 25 let's see if he goes for his
vintage line and he does and you know
I'm not a Monday Morning Quarterback
this Tanya but going for an open against
chakra in basically a muslin game khadir
was saying of better have some serious
preparation up his sleeve
we're gonna find that and we see right
now it's still Mainline Theory as you
were mentioning shock is such a huge
exponent he's such an expert in these
lines so it's going to be interesting to
see what gusunov has in mind what does
he prepared Knight C5 hits the bishop C3
White's Rook often slides to the center
Rook comes to E1 right now the bishop is
threatening to fall back to C2 and no
more exchanges then so big question to
shock is this the moment that he trades
off the bishop for the night or he lets
it live
well the old move here is D4 that was
all the rage in the 90s and then Gary
Kasparov came up with a ridiculous
novelty Knight to G5 then the scene
shifted to Bishop B7 which as far as I
know is still the main line and Shakura
has played that move as you call as you
said white drops the bishop back to C2
and tries to establish control over
these weak dark squares in the center
with Knight to B3 but black has a lot of
dynamic play in the center and on the
queen side and once again Shakura just
has this developed and prepared well
into you know move 20 and 25. right now
if your mom and Yara more than happy
with a draw you're trying to play solid
not take too many risks you're up three
points and the margins will fit even
further if he can hold a draw with black
here
well shark looks relax and chill on his
chair he knows he's got the theory and
the line and the opening that he likes
to play the most now the bishop has
fallen back traits your idea of D4 Works
to Perfection now because white doesn't
have that knight from F3 jumping onto G5
we see that on the board one of the
tricky moves that white does have in
this position is actually to move the D2
Knight up to B3 and open up not just the
bishop not just the queen but also
Target the D4 pawn and we often see uh
some exchanges on the board with
weaknesses for both sides but for me I
like this position with white and the
reason for that is that Bishop on C2 is
often such a monster it needs to be
blocked and there we have it and I had a
recent rapid game of chakra uh that
followed this exact line black takes on
B3 and secures the opponent Bishop F5
there are a lot of force draws in this
line so let's see what gusana has up his
sleeve we also need to see what Sam
Sevin has up his sleeve as we go to the
bird's eye view board two has just begun
David paravian has the white pieces
against Sam sevyan who has to take
tremendous risk uh with with black he's
been amazing or the Garden State passers
so far let's see uh what he has in his
pocket and already a surprise Tanya on
move one I don't know if he surprised or
he's not at his computer either way one
C4 is not David per uh oh sorry Sam
seven is the white pieces I apologize
it's David paravian who is not at his
computer or he's just never seen this
move before one C4 a novelty
I would be surprised if that's the case
but I think they perhaps don't have have
him on the computer screen right now
because no matter how shocked and
surprised you are with one C4 you gotta
make those moves faster and he's almost
burnt a minute on the clock anyone home
and there we have it with one C5 I want
to ask you actually Daniel yesterday
there was this moment when uh our uh
Aryan tari was not on his board against
you and then his clock ran down by a
minute but it was the game was aborted
and restarted what were your feelings at
that moment
well I could anticipate that that was
happening because once you know uh you
take more than 15 seconds on move one
you just know that most likely they're
not at their computer so I really had no
problem with it you know I don't really
want to win a game uh with you know a
three minute time advantage on move one
so it is a little bit disconcerting but
it's part of online chess and I moved on
pretty quickly obviously I just wanted
to get the game going because the nerves
were running deep I was just thinking
about it and once the game starts you
feel a little bit calmer because you're
in your elements and speaking of being
in his element already up 90 seconds on
the clock he's gotten his Queen out to
B3 Tanya a very unconventional move uh
played on move five in order to prevent
black from opening up the center with D5
and really establishing full control
over that week D5 Square
and while no restart of games are today
so that minute might actually come to
haunt David at some point we often see
these openings where nothing gets traded
and everything to play for and the big
questions come later so I'm just a
little worried about that clock
situation he decides to Fan Chateau the
bishop on G7 meanwhile Queen on B3 like
you said is not exactly the most ideal
Square we often see it on C2 or in some
lines once the bishop comes out on E2
I'm not sure where it's headed and the
players are playing a very unique style
of development
this is a modern Chess at its fine as G3
I wasn't expecting that either I thought
he was going to go Bishop E2 but Sam
sebian I think really playing uh and
trying to control these light squares
with everything that he's got Bishop G2
later the Knight could move out of F3
and I like it I'm all for Unique opening
setups they give you a time advantage
and sem Savion must be feeling pretty
comfortable here out of the opening
board three is also underway Trisha
Kanye morala has white against Stannis
lazovic so let's travel back to our
bird's eye view and see how all three of
these games are unfolding we see Sam
Seville in there in full concentration
and end game already the intricious game
against lazovic tyna
wow and she starts with the white pieces
again Trisha has to try to save as many
points as he as she can in this uh in
this matchup of course you know that
first game that she had against shark
and even the second one she's been
fighting it out but so far she's yet to
start on the scoreboard and once again
even though the position looks like it's
fine uh for black and it's out of the
opening but don't get fooled by the
Queens being traded off it's often very
tricky for black in these positions
because White's Knight can land on to D6
via C4 and if white is able to get a
double Bishop pair advantage in these
end games that can often give a huge
Edge so Trisha though has managed to
trade off the Queens questions still
remain to be answered to neutralize this
position that Bishop on G2 is an
absolute monster in this in these
possessions
and Dennis lazovic is a monster in the
end game uh this is a very well known
line just because the Queens are off the
board doesn't mean uh that white setup
is toothless it's far from Toothless and
Dennis lazovic is going to squeeze this
uh Seven Ways to Sunday how is he going
to exploit the strength of his Bishop
well he can play Knight F to D4 opening
up the diagonal and he just needs to
make it there we go as difficult as
possible Tanya for black to deploy her
light squared Bishop maybe bishop D7 is
called for here for black but then
Dennis could bring his dark squared
Bishop out there's weak dark squares in
the center and on the queen side and
let's not forget about the B file Rook
B1 could come at the worst possible
moment and black can almost never afford
to push the pawn to B6 for obvious
reasons
um you want to keep that Bishop on G2 as
blunted as possible so the pawn movement
to B6 would only create more troubles
for black now it might appear that white
also has a weakness on C3 and that is
what black is trying to rely on for
counter play but it's just so far long
before you can get any piece to actually
Target the C3 Pawn meanwhile white Rook
coming to the open B file the bishop
already on G2 the Knight on C6 attack it
does look like uh White is the one who's
preferable in this end game and Trisha
can be aimed for a long grind to save
this one let's get all our four boards
up right now because action has started
on the very crucial Valia versus London
board as well and action has stopped on
the top left track remember of holding a
draw with room to spare they went
precisely Tanya for one of those
well-known drawing lines bad news for
the passers that was a game husana
basically had to win so shocker are
doing uh what was required of him
holding comfortably with the black
pieces and that transfers the demands
over to his teammates who now have to be
even more perfect let's check out
Alexander Letterman's attempt to defeat
valaguna with the black pieces gonna end
up playing one of the more solid setups
against Slender Man slav she's got
Bishops on D2 and E2 it's a modest setup
but it's a tremendously solid setup but
white has no weaknesses and white has a
very clear plan of a timely E4 Pawn push
Letterman says I'm beating you to the
punch
wow any strikes in the center first we
saw London strike with the c Pawn in an
earlier game now he does it with the
other Pawn with the e-pawn ends up with
the same isolated Queen's Pawn but these
kind of positions always give the player
with the isolated Queen spawn a lot of
chance for activity and to create play
and attack now what gunina what Walia
would want in this is to try and trade
off as many pieces so that that D5
weakness will will uh will tell at some
point you can centralize your Rook to D1
you can bring the other Rook to C1 you
can start start with trading off the
knights and once again
Slenderman will look at planting his own
Knight to E4 getting that Bishop the
light squared Bishop into the game and
getting The Rook to C8 at some point so
we're gonna see how this middle game
develops
I think you're bringing up a couple of
great points Tanya 50 years ago you
showed this position to a Trojan you
know or bronstein they would evaluate
this as better for white because white
has control of the square in front of
the pawn but that doesn't tell the whole
story and Black's tremendous piece
activity actually I think gives him the
easier game as the eval bar shows let's
bring up an analysis board how could
this game unfold how could Lenderman try
to squeeze the most out of his active
piece as well he can actually start with
a modest looking move like Bishop D7 but
the point is to bring the Rook over to
ca boom there's one problem there's a
pin if the queen slinks away to B2 well
then black could maybe strike at the
other side with a move like Knight fg4
the queen coming out to H4 eval bar
doesn't like this particular move
perhaps black can play a little bit more
patiently with rookie e but you can just
see all of Black's pieces potentially
aims at the king side and white just
doesn't have a clear plan right the
Knight on D4 is pretty it's impressive
but good pieces don't win games and it's
actually very hard to attack the D5 Pawn
so Alexander Letterman great choice to
play the opening he's most familiar with
and to generate an imbalance which if he
plays this well could result in a much
needed win for the Garden State passers
Bishop D7 on the board
Bishop D7 and I'm uh I'm wondering how
awalia wants to continue because does
she want to put that Rook on the central
file or jump in forward with the Knight
to F5 which is also an option we've been
talking about the importance of trading
pieces and we see that in our chat
Valentina is a boss she's had some
unfortunate turnarounds in her games
today but absolutely agree she is such a
competitive player fights at that till
the very end and this is a huge matchup
for both these teams Knight F5 is the
other option that I'm looking at which
also looks very tempting but first I
really want to get the Rooks into the
center get them get them on the D file
uh this is going to be a very complex
middle game with blacks Rook pinning the
queen down on C2 White's Rook attacking
the D5 Pawn the Knight jumping onto F5
great call Rook 81 is on the board I
think Alex yeah Rook C8 without any
delay that's another problem that white
faces just how easy it is to make
improving moves for black rookie 8 H6
you know Letterman could improve his
position 15 different ways Queen E7 even
B5 expanding on the queen side and all
of those moves contribute to the
pressure on White's position so good
enough she is going to have to be very
careful rookie it is on the board I
think Alexander is playing the clock as
well as the position we will keep an eye
as Valentina tries to navigate her way
through these complexities and put
pressure on Black's isolated Pawn back
we go to the bird's eye view a draw on
the top left between gusainov and
mamidyar of another half Point uh closer
come the Wizards to that much needed
eight and a half to win the match what
else catches your eye on you yeah well
both shock and casino they are fighting
for different teams but they're also
teammates both of them play for
Azerbaijan so they kind of know each
other's style and strengths and I kind
of understand on them not wanting to
fight this one but I feel the onus was
more on gusuno with the white pieces to
try and make the most uh off having that
opening Edge but now that that one's
over it comes down to the lower boards
as it usually does in team events we
also see Sam savian against David
paravian such a big matchup Sam has been
a huge scorer for the uh for the Garden
State passes and I say we try and jump
to that because a lot of pawns are
hanging and a lot of fun weakness is
actually in the position
yeah a lot going on we've got two
Bishops for both sides the knights have
been traded off the board now optically
I think black's position looks very
impressive right the bishop on G7 The
Rook under it combining to put pressure
on B2 there's a battery aimed at C4 but
first appearances rarely tell the full
story and you called it a lot of Pawn
weaknesses look at that pawn on D6 look
at that pawn on A6 look at The Rook on
D1 which is aiming at the pawn if you
give Sam sebien one more move I think if
he can get his Bishop to C3 and
neutralize the dark squared Bishop only
he can stand better also he is up four
minutes on the clock so that early time
Gambit by David paravian he is paying
the price for it in a big way right
about now
yeah he's down to three minutes and as
you're pointing out once this dark Squad
Bishop the most dangerous piece for
black gets traded off it's actually
black spawn weaknesses that are going to
tell and that is why David takes the
committed decision of trying to get rid
of that backward weakness and advances
in the center but to me it looks like it
might come at the cost of a pawn uh you
can take on D5 Bishop takes back the
bishop can't take the A6 Pawn but then
you have to calculate the lines with
blacks Bishop jumping onto B3 and we see
a huge cure with the queen and the Rook
yeah just ridiculous complications this
is where you need those extra minutes
there's another potential pin look at
the alignment of Black's king and queen
right white as a dark light squared
Bishop that Bishop could move back to C4
if Black's Bishop vacates this diagonal
so right now it's very clear what sam7
has to calculate he not only has to
decide between C takes D5 and Bishop C3
which I think is a viable alternative
but also figure out if you can snag if
you can afford to snag that pawn on A6
and if he has the resources to deal with
Bishop B3 I don't envy that task Tanya
and I can tell you firsthand
six minutes it sounds like a lot of time
looks like you can sit back and sip your
coffee and calculate leisurely no those
four or five minutes they disappear
instantly and all you've managed to do
is calculate two moves
absolutely I mean two seconds is nothing
it's just barely enough to make a move
in these formats so you really can't add
up on the clock much you've got to be
super focused and super fast and of
course speed and the clock is as much
important as the position on the board
and uh Daniel I think I think the line
that we're looking at is so critical to
understand the tactics that exist in the
position and let's just show it to our
viewers that if you take on D5 Bishop
recaptures on D5 Bishop takes on A6 and
we've been talking about this cure with
Bishop B3 and you've been very rightly
pointing out another potential pin that
exists and imagine why it falls back
with the queen and you can say I pick up
the Rook on D1 but that's when you lose
control of this key diagonal the bishop
comes back and hello Queen game over
game over indeed and so in this position
black has to make a more Zen move like
Rook C6 but white could actually simply
drop the bishop back Bishop C4 is still
in the cards and as cramped as White's
position is there are no clear targets
so I'm sam7 and I'm looking at Black's
clock and I'm saying listen I need to
win this game this is the best bet that
I have to unbalance the position I think
he should take and take on A6 there's
just nothing to lose at this point we
will see what Sam sevian decides his
clock continues to take down let's go
back to our bird's eye view because I
think there might be more bad news uh
for the Garden State passers as the
levit of wizards move closer and closer
to that necessary eight and a half
points look at Dennis lazovic's board
Tanya on the lower left I'm counting the
pawns which I've been doing uh quite a
lot today and it looks like White's got
more of them than black white also has a
very impressive looking Bishop I think
Dennis might be well on his way to score
and get another vintage end game victory
I completely agree well he's got an
extra Pawn a very strong bishop and a
potential control over the open file
with his Rook so this looks like it is
going to go levitov's way meanwhile on
the bottom right we see Alexander
against Valia a really big game and a
really dense one as very few pieces have
been just traded off just one set of
minor pieces and to me a strange looking
move has been made Walia moving the king
from G1 to F1 what's the point of that
I'm asking myself
wow and D4 on the board whoa yeah let's
go to that game because Dennis lazovic
he's gonna be pressing that end game for
a while so I think we'll still be able
to catch the action but the action here
is unfolding at Breakneck Pace Alexander
Letterman is demolishing Valencia
gunana's defenses this is exactly what
we talked about uh Tanya not only is the
isolated Queen Pawn not a weakness it is
now turned into a strength as Lenderman
opens up the e-file the queen is going
to infiltrate to H2 and to say that that
is devastating is to say absolutely
nothing and after Ed Queen H2 we can see
the point of the sacrifice if white
moves the bishop back to vacate and Luft
there is no Luft to be found because
that square is controlled by black
stroke I think this game is simply over
unless I'm missing something big here
for white
wow and and just to point out the reason
that the king moved to F1 was because
the queen and the bishop battery was
anyways planning to come in and this
looks like huge disaster this was the
moment Queen H3 is a big threat you
can't block it with pushing your Jeep
onto G3 because the H3 Pawn then hangs
and can easily be picked up so Valia had
no choice but to sidestep but this
doesn't stop the fire the queen still
landed after a brilliant Pawn sacrifice
that just opens the e-file for The Rook
so really bringing all the pieces into
the attack bad news for Valentin agonina
and the most crushing thing about this
is Letterman's clock I mean this is what
gives you that sense of hopelessness six
minutes and change for Letterman to just
contemplate his final couple of moves
Bishop G3 might bring the hammer down
Rook C6 to E6 comes to mind as well
Bishop G3 is on the board I think
Valentina should try Bishop E3 uh
preparing to cover the check with Bishop
G1 but then the other Bishop could
deliver a crushing sacrifice on H3 we're
gonna see a resignation here in a couple
of moves and a vital win for the Garden
State passers who very much stay in the
match even with a loss by Kanye morala
which is not a given that does not mean
this match is over particularly if Sam
sebian could score a victory as well
they would take a lead going into round
three and that would be the first time
today Daniel that would they would they
would be the one with the upper hands
the Golden State the Garden State passes
my fault I've gotten that into your mind
haven't I it's you know but they are
playing golden right now so I'm allowed
to have that skip that slip that Bishop
to E3 as you pointed out really the only
way to fight that mate on H1 and he goes
in Daniel you're calling out all the
tactics today Bishop H3 on the board uh
you can't really pick up that Bishop
because if you do then black first gives
a check on H1 forcing the bishop to fall
back and then that would be made after
Queen takes H3 so not allowing that
Valentina goes Bishop F3 but the
troubles are just mounting up black has
a crushing attack and I'm expecting this
to be over any moment well explained
Tanya I think Alexander Letterman needs
one more accurate move he's not totally
out of the woods it's still possible to
blunder and this is what people really
need to understand how quickly these
games can turn around one more thing
that will show then we'll go to the
seven game which actually might decide
the outcome of this match
if black had played the careless Rook
ce6 White's Bishop slings back to G1 and
guess what after Queen H1 G takes H3 and
white is right back in the game Queen
takes H3 is that Checkmate no it's not
can you give him check on F5 no you
cannot suddenly White's pieces aren't
perfect defensive post and so Linderman
has a couple more landmines to sidestep
he does that in style he does that with
great effect the Knight comes into the
attack and that Tanya makes all the
difference look at that mating
construction Knight H2 would have been
made in one Valentina still alive though
94. she is on her last legs Valiant
resistance no pun intended but I don't
think it's going to be enough
wow yeah 94 I mean these kind of
positions trying to defend them with the
white pieces you just want the torture
to be over and Alexander lend them and
just didn't no after blow Rook coming on
to F6 with these ideas it would just be
over King she could not have picked up
the bishop uh on G2 because of I don't
know if you can show that line with Rook
F6 Knight f69 H2 would have been me this
is just going so quick anything I'd H2
immediately yeah actually I apologize
work F6 uh Knight takes up so this would
be a check but it's a moot point
Letterman wins the game just in
absolutely crushing Victory 29 moves and
uh Alexander Lenderman gives the Garden
State passers a fighting chance we go
back to the bird's eye view and Dennis
lazovic he is about to bring the hammer
down on Kanye morala so that game seems
pretty hopeless it's all in the hands of
Sam sebian can he deliver a must-needed
victory against David paravian he's got
him on the ropes Queen for two Rooks and
two pawns white is winning in this
position and David with almost no time
remaining can Sam complete this effort
he has been the lone shining star for
the passers today
well he and in this run Alexander
Lenderman with a stunning win with the
black pieces what a tactical Masterpiece
that was and now it comes down to this
we see queen versus two Rooks the A3
Pawn is attack can white just ignore it
and start marching down the board with
his own C Pawn because you really don't
want to move that Queen Defending Your
A3 Pawn you move it to a weak spot to a
more passive position which will allow
black the counter play of doubling up on
the second rank once The Rook on E6 is
not pinned let's say you go Queen A5
trying to defend your Pawn The Rook can
jump onto E2 creating more threats and
that's exactly what you want to avoid
with the white pieces
absolutely and it's a tough conversion
ahead for Sam sebian whose clock is
dwindling and uh well what better way to
watch the end of round three then with
the team captain of the Garden State
passers FM James Canty joins us once
again James you must be just uh you know
biting your nails and watching with your
uh at the edge of your seat here can Sam
convert this James
let me tell you something we here bro
pass us the ball okay pass past the
passers the ball right now that's what
I'm saying because we're swinging we're
definitely swinging and we're coming
back right now as you see the score six
to four don't call it a comeback but of
course it is that's exactly what it is
right now and we do have two rounds to
go we're swinging there's gonna be
different matchups in the next two
rounds here so we're ready we are ready
to uh to finish this up so you know
we're feeling good though
feeling good
Queen D Queen D6 oh wait he can't
just like you're tied to that F2 part
right that's right
wow how do I get out of here yeah no
how do I win you might have messed it up
James he's allowed the king to stop the
C Pawn
so strong here check I can't run a king
way what this is insane stupid Pawn
chain over here for Black come on David
The Queen Is So overloaded trying to
defend everything it just looks like
white has to give up one of the pawns
what do you think James which Pawn would
you want to get rid of to try to advance
the other one what's going to be your
choice here
definitely definitely want to give up
this f-pawn but I want my king to be on
H6 is the goal but I just said I cannot
get this King the H6 without giving him
maybe not a run it's heading there it
might be going now right can you try it
takes King G5 and just run the king to
H6 bro and just it's whatever the Rooks
can be really disconnected and we can't
grab the H Pawn maybe there we go come
on Sam
I know I know my God I have two seconds
look Sam I am right Green Eggs and Ham
everything that rhyme with Sam okay
Sam I told you let's go come on Big Sam
okay there it is
he's trying to liquidate as many pawns
as possible this is a 50 50 game maybe
she takes that four James but then Rook
takes H4 check King takes G6 David
Gordon needs his Rooks king of five ah
it's so hard to calculate not 15 seconds
for Sam
can he pull it off
he's trying on the board wow he first
defends the G6 spawn but now you can
give a couple of checks and actually
defend the F6 spawn he goes for it he
goes Queen C3 and queen F6 might be on
the board let's give us another check
check
and another one there
and now he moves the king outside the
range of the Rook
that's an amazing technique Hell by wire
here comes the a pawn oh that's a fork
you can't take the pawn because of
another skewer
Queen B8 if you take the pawn
now push
push David is capturing pawns though and
here comes the a pawn it might be
unstoppable
maybe seven and A7 that sounds that
sounds about right that's it I like how
you said that
um stop
wow Sam Sam he's not over yet James can
he convert the queen versus a rook end
game with only 10 seconds left it's not
the easiest end game to convert
okay that's actually correct
right like
and David's down to one second on the
clock so it's a position that's harder
to defend
David has been defending like an
absolute hero but it might not be enough
sam7 is just a beast and first he needs
to win this Pawn on G6 how can he do
that by separating The Rook from the
pawn not the easiest task either James
he's trying to do that with a series of
pins by hooker by crook
can he finish it off
oh yeah this is uh apparently there
wasn't really tough yeah of course
that's this is devaresky Page
9072. yeah I mean like
exactly this is ridiculous I'm telling
you right now
there's also
feel about that right
stop if there's no progress after 50
moves
oh there's progress to be made right now
yeah that's what we need I know this is
let's go see him give me the prices
except for fun that's progress for sure
and now he's gonna Fork The Rook The
Rook is too far away from the king queen
D7
and queen d8 if you go to H4 you you
don't have you don't have a spot for the
king where you can keep it safe the only
move was to H5 not losing it in one move
Rook G5 Queen H7 was made there must be
a fork here and Sam has the time to find
it
was there Queen at seven made in one
there was
and that's it for The Rook he does the
job so let's go say oh my God I'm so
hyped right now Chad oh my goodness but
okay it is one and a half away so we do
have some work to do we got to pull out
our best hopefully the matchup is just
it just works right if the matchup is
good for us and everything looks good
then obviously we have a great shot here
so hopefully that works out for us as we
get this last once or these last two so
wow well James yeah I know you're going
to be watching on the edge of your seat
your team is resilient they pull off a
huge round and they've given themselves
a Fighting Chance James thank you for
finding time to join us we know you're
rooting for your team you got to give
them a pep talk so v-day Master James
you are the captain of the Garden State
passers and we will see if they can pull
off the comeback in the last round thank
you James let's go all right bro
wow wow it's a big big round coming up
Daniel here for the Golden State passes
they've made their first win today with
two and a half one and a half what a
nail-biting finish that was you could
feel it from James as well and there we
have a scoreboard with big wins by Sam
Savion and Alexander landerman
massive results by Savion and by
Letterman who score is just a tour de
force a crushing Victory with the black
pieces over Valentina gunana we remind
you that the team which reaches eight
and a half points first wins the match
so 11 of Chess wizards they cannot you
know win with half a point they actually
need to win a couple games they need at
least one and a half points in the last
round as we review the individual scores
that means yarov has to step up and
Valentina Guna now if she can score
Hearst her first half point or full
point of the match that might give the
Levitt off chest Wizards the push that
they need to avoid what would be a
ridiculous comeback by the passers Tanya
well Garden State bosses have to win the
next match but not just win it they need
to win it by a 3-1 margin because even
if they scored two and a half points
that would give levitar visits one and a
half moving on to eight and a half
wrapping up the match so Garden State
passes need to win and win it big
they do indeed and we will see if
they've got it in them to mount just a
vintage PCL comeback or will the levitov
chess Wizards stay on top you are
watching the pro chess League day two we
will be back with the final epic round
of our first match on the other side of
this short break
thank you
I remember people saying snow you got a
sandbag keep your rating low go play in
the World open and win six thousand
dollars you know just just don't don't
keep your rating up and I'd be like what
are you talking about I'm trying to
become a GM that's ridiculous so that
mentality was something I had to
escape this was not the black bear
School mentality but the park ecosystem
it for me was Prospect Park in Brooklyn
definitely Foster this idea because you
a little bit of awesome mentality that
you keep your rating low and you try to
win some money
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
the pensive expression on the face of
Grand Master Sam sevion the Undisputed
MVP of the Garden State passers Ken sem
Savion carry the passers to a stunning
combat victory over the Fearsome levitov
chess Wizards well the final round is
going to determine that Tanya they have
a very tall order in front of them they
are down seven to five and not only will
Sam have to deliver with black against
mamidarov but the other boards have to
be nearly perfect as well the passers
need at least three points to force a
tie break in three and a half or four to
win the match outright
tough task but at least Sam has got his
task cut up for him he knows he's got
the black pieces but when you have to
win a game you want to play against the
player like chakra mamidaro because you
know that there will be chaos there will
be chances on the board and Sam savian
really has to step it up in this one
against the levito wizard it is the
Garden State passes who need a little
bit of Wingardium Leviosa on their side
Daniel to levitate their game to the
point where they can get that 3-1 win
levitate well that was smooth right
there levitov levitate the puns are in
the air is there a comeback in the air
as well well Trisha Kanye morala she has
been playing excellent chess she has
come very very close in all of her three
games she was close to drawing against
uh against lazovic in the last round she
was winning in one move against Muhammad
yarov she has to put all of that behind
her and use that as inspiration she has
been right there uh right there neck and
neck against Grand Masters and let's see
if she has some magic in her against
Valentina gunana on board four I think
it's clear that she will do everything
that she can but of course in that game
against Valia Trisha is a is an underdog
that just puts all the pressure on
Lenderman gusanov and Sam Savion to make
sure that they get the 3-1 win because
again let's remind ourselves that a two
and a half Victory against the lavator
will still not cut it because the
Wizards will get that one and a half
point will make it to eight and a half
points and win the match so to force a
play go into tie breaks the the Garden
State bosses need a 3-1 victory
exactly and that's the important thing
to remember whether you're a levitov fan
or a passer's fan two and a half one and
a half it wins the individual round but
because uh the match score is cumulative
it loses the overall match here we go
Tanya this is where the magic happens
we've seen so many crazy comebacks in
the history of the PCL I was on a
California unicorns team that was
leading by three points uh against
Minnesota and lost 4-0 so I've seen it
all everything is possible seat belts
fastened and mandatory the games are off
chakra mom and yarov is going to try to
put this match to bed with a win over
sam7 if of course he uh makes his first
move
and then we see the players are almost
ready to go over there shock burning 30
seconds and getting up he's I think he
had he's is it something technical or
what's going on I saw he's got a phone
on him so maybe some messaging going on
there he gets up he leaves the screen so
stay not ready to start but he's burned
about a minute on the clock
and Tanya I'm going to be brutally
honest here uh even though I'm supposed
to be you know uh soft as a commentator
but I really feel like this happens a
lot a lot of players uh in these
tournaments title Tuesdays that tend to
get up from their table for long periods
of time you got to be at your computer
and you got to be ready for the game to
begin I mean you can have all of the
Beverages and the snacks you need at
your desk but you know I feel like this
happens a little bit too often and I'm
sure Sam Seville won't mind it if
Shakira's clock is reset But Here Comes
Shakura he sits back down and he makes a
move
absolutely he's done a little more than
a minute we see a Queen's Gambit decline
shock they're blitzing out trying to get
that time back on the clock but we're
just a two second increment that's not
going to be possible Kaiser can't be too
happy with chakra are just letting a
minute go down on the clock it also is a
bit of Mind Games you know for Sam he's
waiting there for the opponent to come
and and there we have it we've got a
very a very combative middle game here a
sort of a queen's cabinet accepted
structure arising
yeah this is a Queen scan but
accepted a cross between a slav uh and
this structure could change in a variety
of ways generally Black's idea is to
push C5 ASAP and uh correct the
structure on the queen side this is one
of the sharpest lines of the slav black
strikes with C5 white strikes with E5
there are simultaneous captures I think
Knight takes B5 is the main move here
Tanya this is a line which has existed
and has been popular I think for well
over 20 years Gary Kasparov uh
contributed to its development in the
1990s I know nothing about the theory
other than Knight takes B5 a takes B5
must be a move here he's played it
tons of captures in a crazy position
just with Sam sebion wants this is
exactly what he needed to get this is
the dream when you have to win on demand
for your team the pressure is on and
this is exactly the kind of Chess that
you want on the board now I was focusing
too much on the player but you're
absolutely right this is the main line
theory of the Miron and it is such a
tactical line it is such a combative
middle game and we can see the pawn
structure in front of Black's king queen
E2 not only targets that B5 Pawn but is
also x-raying that E6 Pawn so always
look for tactics down the E file uh
black first needs to decide do you want
to defend this Pawn by advancing it one
step ahead with B4 because giving it up
white will be super happy to get a
bishop there
absolutely white we'll be happy to get
that pin as well as connected passers
which a lot of people underestimate in
the middle game but A and B pawns they
run very fast A4 B4 A5 B4 you know it
white could lay down the wood on the
queen side so Sam sebien deciding
whether and if so how to defend the pawn
no he will not defend the pawn bishop E7
on the board Tabasco sauce being added
to the position biceps Evian I think he
wants to play Rook G8 and uh put his
foot down on the king side but what a
risky approach if I'm shock or you are I
am taking that pawn and running with it
I am Indian I love a good Tabasco spice
it up as much as you can and that is
what is happening in this position
Bishop B7 so the idea is of course to
Target the G2 Pawn we see black spawn
structure yes it looks hideous but the
good news is you've opened up a g file
for the counter play of course white has
to bite the bullet and just say you know
what I'm gonna pick it up show me the
money and now one thing that works for
for white is that the tactics with
taking on F3 the queen would have landed
on F3 and hit that freak on a so you
don't have time to do that which is why
first Sam Savion gets The Rook into the
game because this is a long-term
sacrifice it's really not about winning
something back on the spot but just
creating big problems and big questions
uh to White's King
exactly and I would cement the bishop
with A4 if I'm shocker out just to make
sure that the queen doesn't get
overextended once black let's say
castles Queen side and gets The Rook out
of its vulnerable position shock will
ponder uh his next move in this
important position giving us a good
chance to travel to the bird's eye view
because two of the other games have been
started and we've got interesting
openings in both of them top right we
have a king's Indian my neck of the
woods Kadir gusainov is a king's Indian
expert and it makes sense for him to
play one of the sharpest openings in
chess to virtually guarantee uh winning
chances and bottom left we've got
Alexander Letterman and Dennis lazovic
and kind of a Carlsbad slav type
structure so Tanya I'll give you the
choice of where we go next and you don't
have to choose the king's Indian game I
promise I won't be mad uh if we see a
king's Indian we see a king's Indian we
want a king's Indian and once again
gossinov's opening choice is so ideal
for trying to get them the chaos that
that the team is looking for on the
board and it's already pawns are rolling
down the board and I would love to jump
to that action with David Praveen with
the white pieces facing uh against a
very motivated gusanov who needs to
score for his theme
he does indeed good choice
um you're welcome Daniel we go hey I I
had a king's Indian yesterday against a
player whose name I don't quite remember
he's not very well known it's a
resilient opening it's one that has
withstood the test of time what do we
have here F5 is on the board this is one
of the typical King's Indian plans and
the downside of this move is that it
allows whitesnite a route to the E6
square and the one thing you normally do
not want to do in the king's Indian is
give away your light squared Bishop
because that Bishop is often the key to
breaking down White's King side
defensive setup later in the game so
will perabian go for Knight G5 is he
gonna maybe throw in he takes F5 first
to soften up blacks kingside decisions
to be made and he's got to make them
fast because he is once again
experiencing some problems on the clock
needs to keep the pressure up on the
clock and the position I'm loving this
opening approach asking a big question
do you take on F5 or do you keep it as
is and there's a third choice that David
has gone for he Retreats the Knight so
targeting the G4 Knight there which
falls back and Daniel I see you're not
very happy with that uh choice that
White made
I'm very surprised I thought an ig5 was
sort of a given uh David might want F3
which is a typical way to respond but
Queen D6 check actually picks up the
pawn on B2 but that might not even be
the biggest problem if we pull up an
analysis board here I think F3 walks
right into the kind of position Hussein
of once he can just play F4 and then the
king's Indian shows its full force with
G5 and H5 and G4 and these types of
positions are just easier to play for
black and again as I mentioned at the
start you've got to factor the clock
into every decision that you make in
these PCL games because you just don't
have a lot of time to figure out the
proper defense David though he takes a
different route as we go back to the
live board he trades on F5 and sticks a
bishop on G5 trying to just make it as
difficult as possible for black to
unravel his King side attack Tanya last
thing I'll say queen E8 here is very
tempting but you have to watch out for a
timely D take C6 I've blundered that so
many times that that D6 Pawn is a lot
weaker than it looks maybe husainf
should invest the tempo to close down
the queen side
I love how you've broken down all the
subtleties in this position and that's
of course because you yourself are such
a big King's Indian expert Daniel now
one of the ideas that white also has in
these positions super thematic is to
advance the F2 Pawn all the way to F4
and start asking some questions to Black
because what you really want is for
Black to push that pawn further weaken
the D4 square and then we understand the
point of the White Knight retreating
because it can reroute itself from C2 to
D4 which also brings me back to your
point to move C5 also stops that so I
like it but even if you control that
square I'm expecting f4 on the board we
see another decision being taken where
he decides to trade on D5
now that's a risky one because now a
knight appears on D5 and it's a menacing
night it's a night the black could try
to
excommunicate with the move Knight to C7
similar idea Bishop comes out to E6
husseinav can take the Knight on the
next move he can also surround it with
Knight C7 I think adira has gotten
himself a nice position good control of
the center he's managed to keep D6 under
under control and that Knight on E1 is
what disturbs me about White's position
there's just no coordination between
White's heavy pieces and David needs to
try to get those heavy pieces into the
game which he does with Knight C2 an
incredibly tense position this can go
either way let's see if Qatar gozainov
can can uh cool down his nerves and
deliver it with black and so important
what white now wants to do is fight for
that D5 Square which is really the main
focal point of the game so the Knight
that was in E1 is finding itself to
arrive on E3 and try to then jump onto
D5 after a few piece trades trades that
will happen so really tense middle game
position here but there's tension across
boards let's get our bird's eye view
because so much has happened especially
on the Sam Shakira board on the top
right as we see wow the king is still in
the center I see the rook and the bishop
firing fire down the boat on G2 what do
you make of this position
hi Tanya this is PCL action at its
finest the final round at exchange
sacrifice crazy attack and a five minute
time Advantage what else could we ask
for sam7 has sacrificed in exchanged and
he first sacrificed the pawn on B5 what
does he have in return well look at that
pressure that he's got on G2 oh look at
the pressure that he's got on White's
Queen chakra is just barely escaping
here Queen H5 is on the board the
analysis board is up oh my gosh Tanya it
appears that Knight G4 wins the game
because it attacks the pawn on F2 and
after Knight takes D3 this is the
hardest thing to spot you actually can
take on F2 anyway because suddenly the
pressure on G2 grows unbearable I'd have
to Rook cheek nope not Rook G3 Rook
takes G2 is simply Checkmate and look at
how beautiful how beautifully blackened
checkmate with Rook takes H2 Queen takes
F2 Bishop G2 and then the other Bishop
steps in to deliver the mate this is
just one of many mating options Tanya
Knight G4 is winning for black it's
official the evil bar confirms it seven
minutes seven minutes to find he needs
to find it he needs this is the moment
and he has slowed down so that makes me
feel like he is on the right path he's
definitely thinking about it also let's
point out that if you step back with the
queen to H4 trying to defend F2 it
doesn't work you can still take on F2
because after Knight F2 Queen F2 there's
Bishop C5 pinning that Queen winning the
game tactics across the board here will
Sam Savion find the killer Knight G4
it's amazing that Knight takes F2 is
essentially a pre-move after Knight G4
it works either because of the pressure
on G2 or because of the alignment of
White's king and queen thank you for
showing that line that really might be
the challenge for seven I think he's
gonna see Knight G4 Knight takes D3
Knight takes F2 but can he spot Knight
takes F2 in response to Queen H4 he
knows there's something he can sense
that you can just sense the wheels
turning in his brain he's got his hands
over his head forcing himself to
concentrate it's so important Tanya in
these situations not to rush you're
tempted to make a move but you gotta
double check triple check you got to
convince yourself that no it isn't too
good to be true you're beating shucker
mommy darav in 20 moves with black
will we see the Knight hop into G4 this
might be a game changer a match changer
if Sabian can deliver with black
such a huge moment and also the problem
here playing Black is that you have so
many tempting options that you have to
fight you know you can trade the Bishops
on D2 you can fall back with the bishop
and C5 put pressure on F2 and everything
seems like you've got a pleasant
position but when you've got a pleasant
position try and wrap it up in the
moment especially when you're playing
against somebody like chakra this is a
big moment and I'm liking that Sam is
taking his think here he is calculating
these lines Sam chat will Sam Savion
find Knight G4 he reaches out for his
Mouse he's about to make a move
this is just tension at its finest I
mean my heart is beating out of my chest
how how might some Savion feel and Tanya
it's so important to understand that
when you know the correctness G4 he's
got to sift through all of the false
positives all of the wrong moves and
he's done just that and he's left
himself with five minutes to convert
this position this is
I don't see a single way for white to
last more than two moves Tanya
in the chat I mean how did he play this
in this format just finding this move
your Bishop on B4 is hanging
unbelievable stuff and I'm loving it
Shakira mamidyarov in big big trouble I
don't really see a way for him to hold
on now
I mean it's not even like the Magnus a
Wonder game from yesterday where a
Wonder had to find a series of accurate
moves to finish off White's King Sam
literally needs one more accurate
follow-up and that follow-up is going to
be either Knight takes F2 or queen takes
F2 relatively speaking Bishop B3 that
might be the only way to Stave off
immediate defeat Tanya uh let's bring up
an analysis board one more time Bishop
B3 Knight takes E3 and queen takes H7
just trying to create as much chaos on
the board as possible but if I'm not
mistaken even a very straightforward
move like Rook G6 and oh my God I see a
crazy mate if I may share F take C3
Queen takes C3 King H1 Queen takes E1
just one of how many incredible mating
constructions are we treated to in this
that is amazing
that is a stunning line Daniel and of
course you can also just pick up the
Knight with the bishop but this just
shows the power play that is Black's
position some indeed a beast as Greg is
pointing out but he needs to finish it
by the way Queen H4 was the other line
that we were seeing on Knight F2 on the
board he has picked up the pawn because
white can't recapture the Knight the
bishop will fall back to C5 winning and
winning that Queen this is a busted for
white Bishop E3 you just pick it up and
after Queen F2 you go Bishop C5 you need
one more move here I think shaka's
actually done a great job he has found
the best practical chance but Sam has an
eternity to figure out the follow-up it
appears that Queen to E2 not the easiest
move to find ends the game immediately
because in the event of the queen trade
the pawn appears on E2 and after Bishop
takes E1 and Rook takes G2 white king is
once again checkmated but can Sam keep
himself composed can he find Queen E2
Tanya Bishop C5 also win the game but
that's a lot less convincing because
after you play D2 the Knight can appear
on F3 and block the light squared Bishop
so you can definitely still go wrong
here and how many times have we seen top
players pull out the seemingly
impossible Sam Seville once again his
hands over his head he knows the gravity
of this moment this is unbearable
tension oh my God Daniel he found Knight
G4 he's gonna find Queenie too he is in
the flow of this attack and as you're
pointing out that you trade on your own
tongues but he makes the McQueen E4 also
good also good which also seems
extremely strong because you're
threatening to go Bishop takes E1 you
pick up that Knight take away the key
defender of the G2 square and it all
falls apart I don't see a way for white
to counter these threats if you go
Knight F3 it's not good enough because
the G2 Pawn is pain the queen and the
bishop you can simply pick up the Knight
or you could even play Bishop C5 and
then Sack or Rook on G2 but it takes F3
is simple and strong Rook D2 the only
move shocker are playing the engine
moves to stay in the game just uh
incredible resistance or Rook G5 is once
again the best move a rook lift to F5
knocking the queen away and once the
queen is knocked Away by the way Bishop
C5 that might be even the bigger problem
for shock he's down to 40 seconds if he
pulls this off then you know then I'm
just gonna be in absolute shock for the
rest of this week but Sam just a couple
more moves away shocker yard keeps his
legs churning keeps giving himself
opportunities to pull off a miracle this
might decide the match if Sam wins
though Tanya obviously the comeback
isn't complete they need to deliver on
the other boards but this is exactly
what the passers needed this is what
makes it so tough to beat the best in
the world because they're so resilient
and so resourceful and that is what
shock is showing with his play in such a
difficult position but Sam is literally
just centimeters away from wrapping this
up but still little work to be done like
you're mentioning just a couple more
precise moves Rook F5 with a direct idea
you hit the Queen the queen doesn't have
a good Square defending that Knight on
E1 keeping everything under control so
after Rook F5 if you do pick up the
bishop on B4 black just ends up with a
lot of extra material I think you can
pick up the Rook but you can also pick
up the queen and then pick up the other
Rook as well yeah but Tanya here's the
tough thing after Rook F5 Knight F3
again I'm looking at the eval bar but
I'm not seeing a clear path to Victory
or black the engine reveals like a very
computer-ish move Rook to C5 that's so
hard to spot it's it's a weird geometric
move going to C1 instead sam7 has played
the second best move but he's released a
lot of his Advantage Bishop C5
liquidates to an end game in which yes
black is winning but now the win is a
lot harder to achieve I'm in disbelief
that Shakira has even managed to get
this into an Indian this is ridiculous
he's going to be up on down and Sam
should be able to convert but he's now
got a lot more work to do than just a
couple of moves ago is indeed fighting
well this is an absolutely insane game
wait he takes on D3 but this allows Rook
G2 to come in with a check to clean his
pin even better is to actually take the
queen first because if the king takes
then you can take on G2 and actually get
into a pawn end game because the b-pawns
are easy to stop with Black's King Sam
spots it and spots it what a beast and
shocked that he was shaking his head in
disbelief how quickly it's gone from bad
to worse with the white pieces and some
Savion just blowing up the board with
insane move after move pick it up pick
up the Rook pick up remember to pick up
the rook and that's it it's a winning
end game
basic Betty right here in Chicago
oh my God the Garden State passes Daniel
they are on their way for a comeback and
we see that Sam he knows he's done his
job now it's up to the teammates now
it's up to the three other boards can
they deliver as well the score is one
zero sam7 is one with black against the
top Board of the chess Wizards everyone
is on the edge of their seats we're
looking at the bird's eye view Kanye
marala on board four uh lower right of
your screen she is going after Valencia
gunana's King there on G8 I think she's
got an advantage but maybe not that
Knight on E5 is a beast over on the left
Linderman and lazovic that's the
concerning board Tanya that's the highly
concerning board for the passers because
I think lazovic has got a brutal blind
with the black pieces there against
Alexander Letterman's minor pieces in
King
yeah you look at that position you look
at those two knights in the center and
it looks like black is doing well also
let's not forget that the Wizards just
need one and a half points to actually
win the match currently Sam Savion with
a big win against Sam against chakra
momentarov has taken the lead meanwhile
on that bottom left board the knights
have been pushed back we saw a move B3
the Knight has jumped back to B6 but it
still looks like Dennis is the one who's
doing well and the other reason for that
is look at the pawn structure as well
white spawn on H3 is a massive weakness
it's a long and open file also if you
compare the Bishops the bishop on G2 is
just not as strong as the bishop on G6 a
lot of Harmony in Black's position so
Alexander lunderman can he pull this one
off he needs a bit of a miracle he
really does I mean he needs to stay
alive here he shouldn't go crazy I'm
gonna draw does not exclude the passers
from uh a comeback possibility a 3-1
score would push this into the tie
breaks which in and of itself would
already be a miracle Lenderman is worse
but he has to try to exploit Dennis
lazovic's Clock Dennis down to 90 90
seconds and the approach here for
Leonard Montanya I think is just to
bring his pieces into the center Queen
B2 rook ad1 and eventually when you're
ready you can start operating in the
center maybe Knight G3 and eventually
maybe you can break through with E4 but
that is way in the future right now he's
got to make sure his bases are covered I
really like the way he's handling the
defensive task so far but look at Dennis
hopping the Knight over to H4 that is a
nasty square and he could combine it
with Bishop E4 there might be made
threats soon enough on these weakened
light squares well and we've had a huge
result already
on winning against Wilson that is
oh my gosh she blundered his Queen
it was a wild it was a wild end there
Daniel lots of tactics all across the
board I had my eye out and David
paravian playing on seconds he managed
to win a massive point there for his
team and now they just need half a point
across the other two boards oh my gosh
Kadir gusana it was a drawn position all
the way until the end he went for too
much risk he tried to exploit private
time pressure he loses they now need
wins on all of the remaining boards and
let's go to Trisha kanyama's board
because Valencia could back this match
up and she will she is up upon in a rook
end game I cannot see her losing this
game Tanya well maybe maybe I I can I
mean Rook D7 is met with Rook F7 no this
should be the match right here and right
now A draw secures it for the levitov
chess Wizards what a heartbreak given
Sam sebian's performance
what a day for some Savion winning
against chakra Mama diaro but of course
there's still work to be done for
lavitovies that they need to draw one of
the two games and we see it might be
just this one gunina with the black
pieces and extra Pawn her own Rook
covers the seventh rank so nothing to be
afraid of with checks uh instead Trisha
brings in the king but I don't see her
being able to create these chances
Valentina is so strong in these Rook
pawn and games and I think this will
decide the outcome of this matchup
yeah and I mean you can see just the
exasperation on Trisha's faith it has
been a frustrating experience for her
today but for the lower rated players in
the PCL just Irreplaceable experience
facing grand Masters representing your
team and she has acquitted herself uh
really really nicely giving herself
chances in every game this one though
will not go her way she's still trying
though breaking down Black's Pawn mess
on the king side I think the only way
for things to go disastrously wrong for
Black by the way Valentina up two pawns
actually not one Pawn the King has to
worm its way into F5 but then the black
Rook can make its way to C2 and pick off
White's remaining second ranked pawns
this is not going to go widesway and
Dennis lazovic is also in control
against Letterman so this just might be
you know a two and a half one and a half
win this round for uh for the for the
chess Wizards
wow it looks like the passer's world is
falling apart right now if we just pull
out our remaining games as well the
bird's eye view you were talking about
landerman's position that is collapsing
as well take a look at that a king stuck
on H2 on the bottom left of the screen
all the pieces are piling up on the H
file and if we just pull that one up it
looks like it's going to be Dennis
lizavic's Point
yeah although in the last couple of
moves it looks like Letterman is
impossible he's gotten his King back to
G1 this is the amount of turnarounds
that we have seen in some of these games
is ridiculous and now Linderman is
actually in control he's in the driver's
seat if he takes on G4 he even has a
check on h8 potentially using the Knight
Fork on G6
it suddenly looks like Dennis lazovic is
the one in Mortal danger which would
make this result even more heartbreaking
wow that was a big turnaround because
the moment we went into this it looked
like lazovic was in control and now we
see it's again all over to London both
players well Slender Man's got a minute
and
Dennis has about seven seconds on a
clock and a really difficult position to
defend if Lenderman wins this then the
Golden State passes might win it with
two and a half but it still won't be
enough to win the match no because uh
well it's not official yet maybe there
will be an internet outage but balancing
Laguna literally has a rook and three
versus a rook and one it's an unusable
position and all she needs is a draw so
at this point the last of it game is
purely cosmetic but it's definitely the
more interesting game so the moment we
have a result on gunana's board we will
tell you about it but what a valiant
effort by the passers and what holds
blooded play by David paravian who's
been in high pressure this entire PCL
match and he's pulled out a couple of
those games with just seconds on his
clock against Letterman in round one and
now against who is going to be kicking
himself they were oh so close
hold on there's there's a huge Knight of
fought which has now been taken care of
with the queen stepping out of the pin
but still it looks like lazovic has
managed to come back into the game and
not that big a trouble as it was the
king in East on E7 is absolutely safe no
checks I say that and immediately
Lenderman blows open the center with E4
things are getting super tricky laws of
it down to eight seconds on the clock oh
but Rook H2 is now a huge threat the
white king who's King is less safe I
think the answer is Letterman's King
he's opened the e-file but who does that
benefit it probably benefits black he
has to try to get the Queens off the
board maybe get the Rook to G7 that
Knight can also swing to E4 The Rook on
D2 is hanging and he defends it with the
cold-blooded Knight F1 but Dennis
lazovic I mean the guy is just so good
in time scrambles I really can't
I was gonna say queen H2 check and then
I just realized that there's a knight on
F1 defending it just shows how easy it
is to blunder these positions but of
course the queen lands all the way to H1
and always watch out for the other Rook
jumping onto H2 things have turned
around once again and this looks like
it's completely over for white it's over
Alexander Letterman cannot pull it off
lazovic spent the last 30 moves with 10
seconds on his clock and he is going to
get the job done as is Valentina gunina
who wins her game the match is over and
it's gonna be a win in this round when
all is said and done if flazovic pulls
this off levitov chest Wizards will win
in this round with a score of well
they'll win it with a score I guess of
three to one actually and there we go
resignation
and that's it that is it lazovic takes
this point and that means it ends with
3-1 in favor of levitov Chess Wizards
what a convincing win uh by damn Daniel
but that said the match really had its
moments and the passerby really did but
put up put up a big fight in this one
listen they were outgunned from the very
beginning the levitov chest Wizards were
the favorites but for the favorites to
deliver smoothly is an impressive feat
in and of itself chakraf he wasn't in
the greatest form but he delivered when
it mattered he won the first two games
to set the tone and even though Sam
Sevin delivers a brilliancy with the
black pieces it is not enough because
his teammates unfortunately did not come
along for the ride Tanya it's a
frustrating loss for James Canty's team
but at the end of the day no uh shame in
losing to a team that has four strong
Grand Masters
wow what a match and things could have
been so different only if Trisha had
played that 986 on that first game for
me that still strikes as the moment of
the day that could have really turned
things around what a huge fight uh by
these players but of course Daniel the
action continues here at the protest
League
it most certainly does because we have
yet another match coming up for you you
thought them action was over you thought
that was it and you can go rest you
would be very very wrong because we have
a second match coming right up between
the Norway gnomes and the Spanish Maniac
shrimps which worked their way
qualifying through a scintillating
qualification phase they will try to
make their participation count ladies
and gentlemen the protest League we have
one match in the books we have a second
match coming up and you will go
absolutely nowhere neither will we will
bring you that second match in just a
couple of minutes stay tuned
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
chess
the weight of a win draw or loss is all
on one's shoulders
it's easy to feel alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my gosh
the pro chess league is back
once again in chess teammates matter he
is just upset he's got a hand in his
head he can't believe it
what what are you doing
welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives no wait matters can win
this game a 20 for Black come on how
does Magnus Carlton do this
entering its Fifth Season 16 teams will
reboot the PCL Legacy with a new format
and new schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL champion this tough out here India
is just a Powerhouse
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
welcome back to the pro chess League 2
matches today one of them already in the
books what a start this wonderful
Wednesday International Master Tanya
sachdev I'm Grandmaster Daniel naritzki
we are chopping up these two
scintillating matches for you best part
that one of these matches Is Yet To Come
Tanya get ready everybody
I'm so ready it was clear that lavatov
were The Magicians for today the levitar
Wizards wrapped it up and how what a
match but we've got another one coming
up and the action at the protest league
has just started Daniel this is the
regular season currently but we've got
to Mark our calendars for some big chess
action coming up over the next few weeks
non-stop action indeed this is the
five-week regular season throughout
February and March at the end of March
we have the arena Royale where all teams
participate in one big arena playoffs at
the end of March and in May 11th through
14th the PCL finals you want to mark
your calendar for those dates do what
you need to do but you will not want to
miss the four Team final in mid May
those are the key dates in the PCL now
let's take a quick look at the match
format we've got one more match earlier
today we had levitov chess Wizards
against the Garden State passers and as
you indicated Tanya it was a convincing
win for the favorites there were minor
hopes of a comeback for the passers man
did levitov bring the hammer down on
three boards in the last round
that was a crushing Victory with 10
points to lavitov against six but the
Garden State passers had some shine out
moments there by Sam Savion what a
player he was a big fight there but the
chess Wizards were just too strong today
and of course the match format does not
make it any easy it's an all play all
and so much action that's coming up and
I've got to say the clock situation
really matters here it's a 10 minute
with just a two second increment and
Daniel I cannot emphasize enough that
this increment of two seconds is barely
anything now you played yesterday and
you know how it is
oh absolutely it's important to have
that increment to avoid the craziest of
time scrambles but that time evaporates
so quickly the first team to eight and a
half points wins uh Point totals are
accumulated throughout four rounds in
which Everybody Plays everybody all four
boards play all four boards but
conceivably the match could end in only
three rounds because you could hit eight
and a half points in three rounds the
event of a blowout will we see a blowout
well let's take a look at the lineups
for these two very strong teams the
maniac shrimps have three grand Masters
and very strong women's Grandmaster on
board four same for the Norway gnome
some really really amazing names here
Tanya
wow this is the drum roll moment here
Daniel that we've got as we reveal the
lineups for these two teams the Spanish
shrimps really punched their tickets
into the protest League it was the only
team that qualified and earned its spot
so it's going to be interesting to see
what they hold and how they hold their
own against the Norway gnomes we've got
some star players here Eduardo iterizaga
he is such an attacking tactical uh
player but again we also see solemn
Saleh from the Emirates again the same
style of play this is a stacked matchup
with these two teams and I'm expecting
big fights till the very end and a lot
of fireworks on the board
fireworks indeed the maniac shrimps
going for the lineup That yielded them
the qualification spot if it ain't broke
don't fix it and in round one we will
get board one versus board for Laura
unook will have a tough task facing
Eduardo rizaga but she's got the white
pieces she is a very solid player not an
easy task at all oritare Saga some
really really amazing matchups deeper
enough Anya I am a huge fan I've played
him ever since he was an Untitled player
on chess.com buddy purnov as he is known
in some circles now a grand master and a
player that everybody fears he's almost
17 years old he is the 75th Grand Master
from India and of course there are so
many and you these kids this is every
second kid in India is coming out to be
a grand master and as you pointed out
pranav a super big Talent he's often
mentioned how big a fan he is of playing
on chess com and especially if the chess
bras as well he spends so much time
playing against Amman and Eric on chess
come some amazing games there so it's
going to be fun to watch him in action
today and pranav I'm biased because we
share uh an opening repertoire in common
so I actually look up a lot of his games
uh over the board to uh to help myself
do the very limited preparation that I'm
able to do he always finds a way to
unbalance the game in the opening so a
great addition for the Norway gnomes and
of course gawaine Jones and solemn Saleh
they don't really need an introduction
and neither does uh Ibarra who is
another chest outcome stalwart always
does well in title Tuesdays and Tanya
you just have to take these players as
feed a ratings with a grain of salt
because these aren't just random 2540
GMS these are players uh with a great
reputation or rapid Mastery all right
well the gong is sounded the games are
off and we start with Uno kagansi
turizaga oh a big game here and of
course unook on the paper is the
underdog in this one but can she hold
her own against itri zaga I've played
against Eduardo several times and I'm
gonna tell you he is such a dangerous
player we often talk about Clash of
styles uh in chess but for iterizaga and
the rest of the Spanish team each one of
them is a pure tactician so we're gonna
see a lot of excitement on the board it
starts with and I was talking about
excitement and look at this he goes for
C5 so it potentially could blow up
really soon so we've got no boring
Queens Indian stuff no Queen's Gambit
decline none of that Daniel bring on the
Fire
prophetic called by you Tanya turizaga
making his intentions amply clear uh as
he essays a modern benoni I face them
only once over the board I have a funny
story in regards to that game but I'm
going to save that story for a more
opportune moment because we gotta watch
the action as it unfolds and lauro Nook
investing some time here some people
might be wondering what is she thinking
about D5 is automatic no it is not white
does have a couple of Alternatives E3 is
a very solid continuation Knight C3 was
also possible but we're not saying hey
you want to play Modern benoni I'm
meeting you at the top D5 is on the
board and we're in again E5 is coming
amazing time Daniel battle
I would love to see it but we don't get
to see that one but he does go for a
pawn trade well at some point black does
want to start advancing the pawns on the
queen side currently iterizaga focusing
on development often we'll see a
structure where the bishop will land on
G7 black will go castles will move the
D7 Pawn to D6 to open up the bishop and
eventually dream and hope to advance
those Queen side Pawns
yeah this is unfolding at a Breakneck
Pace unook deciding what benoni set up
she wants to play you could put the pawn
on E3 or on e4 and as she Ponders her
next move let's go to the bird's eye
view because the second board between
pranav and Spanish Grandmaster Miguel
Santos Ruiz miguelito as he is known on
chess.com has begun and we have what I
think is a Petrov with a bishop on D3 so
I was talking about it pranav always has
a little bit of an edge to his opening
choices he never plays you know the
total main line but he's got a lot of
analysis within his Sidelines Tanya what
do you make of his uh Choice against the
Petrov
well he's I know pranav is a is an
extremely hard-working kid and for him
this platform of playing in the protest
League means so much so I know he's come
in with some preparation and knows what
he wants this idea of trying to just get
black out of Mainline Theory to get a
game out of the Petrov I like it he
first opens up the queen side pieces he
opens up the bishop and C1 takes control
of the center eventually as you're
pointing out the Rook will come to E1 we
might see the queen and the bishop
battery up on the b187 diagonal so a
very uh very normal way for development
with just a little mix up of the move
order of course Prana with the white
pieces is going to try and get the
initiative out of the opening I like
what he's doing I think he's slightly
better he's got a very nice Center and
that Bishop on B7 may look menacing but
the sting can be taken out of it if
white puts the Knight on D2 linking the
knights up and you know making the
bishop a good piece but nothing all that
special but the position very
symmetrical in terms of the pawn
structure so I think the onus is on
prernav to convert his Pleasant position
into something concrete Santos has many
ways to improve his position he's
playing fast he's playing confident and
he's pretty close just to equalizing
this game outright so enough will he
find a way to spice things up Tanya
looking pretty solid for Miguel
absolutely I mean it's the Petrov it
takes its while to really develop into
something and black will be solid no big
weaknesses white has a space Advantage
has taken the central line and now a
question by uh Miguel Santos where do
you want to drop back with the bishop
because Bishop to F4 also makes a lot of
sense as does Bishop to H4 and while
we're gonna see of course action is also
on the other boards but we see a big
decision on this one falls back and
already a peace trade offered with the
Knight not only moving to offer an
exchange but also eyeing that F4 Square
once imagined Daniel the Knight lands on
F4 with that Bishop on B7 just x-raying
that G2 pawn it can start to look scary
for white that Bishop took my insults
personally it says Hey commentator
doesn't think it's a good piece well
take that love the way Miguel is playing
here I think he's fully neutralized uh
prernav's opening play and uh as he
decides whether to snag the bishop pair
Let's Travel back to the bird's eye view
because the other two boards have been
started and we have a very interesting
opening on one of those boards bottom
left of your screen Jose Ibarra against
gawaine Jones an opening expert in the
king's Indian and in the dragon but in
this game he's opted for E4 E5 and Jose
Barra essay a gleck system with an early
King side fiancaro one of my favorite
openings in Blitz and Rapid I played it
yesterday uh in my fourth game against
Aryan tari and they've actually got a
pretty similar structure uh to to my
game so let's I'm just selfishly going
to force us onto that board the uh I'm
bartum of a game is also interesting
we'll bring you an analysis of that
pretty soon but action unfolding at
Breakneck pacing night on before Tanya
and I'm getting dizzy just looking at
the arrangement of minor pieces here
you know we've been doing this so much
today where we've been counting how many
pawns are on the board and this was one
of those positions for me because we see
white spawn structure on the queen side
has already been well separated and kind
of slightly destroyed there we see its
equal pawns which means I am kind of
liking Black's position here Knight C2
is a massive threat on the board the
Bishops blacks Bishops just eyeing down
on C2 as well as the bishop on D6 looks
really good what white has going for him
is the space advantage and also look at
the this connection between the two
Rooks that black has it's hard to find a
square for the queen to move to to
connect the Rooks to get them on the
open files also see also notice how the
bishop on A4 controls E8 and the bishop
and G5 controls the d8 square meanwhile
white has given up in return is the bad
Pawn structure it's a lot of give and
take care and this is going to be a fun
one great points Tanya a small
correction I hallucinated a little bit
uh I said this was a Glock system of
course the bishop is not fiance but it
is a very similar Pawn structure so it
was indeed a Four Knights with an early
H3 one of those Sidelines that's gotten
popular recently trying to get out of
theory very smart thing to do against
gawaine Jones another smart thing to do
is figure out a defense against Knight
C3 which would pick up a piece
I like Bishop D2 Ibarra drops his Bishop
back but it's not a passive move Tanya
it restricts the Knight and I think he's
loading himself up for C4 that pawn can
run up the board and the bishop on T6
amazingly could get trapped let's bring
up an announcement real fast just to see
how quickly these positions can turn
sour but some black plays H6 no problem
Knight F6 everything's fine C5 and uh
the bishop is completely dominated by
the rook and White's dark Spirit Bishop
so good Wayne Jones now he's the one
facing the threat of a piece loss he
might want to preemptively move his
Knight back to B6 but well then the
knight's gonna be dominated by the other
bishop and C4 C5 is still a force to be
reckoned with I like ibarra's position
here I think he's clearly better
a Gwen is such a creative player and
very resourceful I'm expecting him to
come up with some way of defunding
against this tactical idea that you're
mentioning that does create Chaos on the
board but there is chaos on other boards
already so let's bring up our four board
view because I already see on the top
right there's a check with the Knight
that has come on to 86 we see the
Bishops have been traded there are so
many threats with White's Knight jumping
in and we see that pranav his opening
with the Petrov that approach is paying
off as he's the one who's putting the
pressure on Santos yeah that early
Bishop D3 line does seem to be paying
dividends he's got essentially a
risk-free position with a completely
healthy Pawn structure and a queen on H6
but I still feel like Miguel he's got
all of his bases covered so we'll see if
turn off can make anything of the queen
on H6 another board then I want to draw
our attention to is Eduardo's game
against Laura unook if we could go there
uh for just a little while because Laura
is already down quite a bit on the clock
but she's got Eduardo's minor pieces in
a bit of a bind and pushes her Pawn up
to F4 expanding on the king side but
Knight to Jesus last night
oh yes I was just about to say I mean in
in the benoni when you move your F Pawn
you have to make sure that Black's
Knight is not entering the camp Anna
does attacking that Rook on H1 it just
looks like White's position has gone
really wrong out of the opening Daniel
I'm not liking uh Laura's uh opening
Choice here
Edward we Tori Saga well Kenzie
speculated that he was in a dentist's
office uh because of the cabinets and
just the that monitor that often
displays the dreaded x-ray uh after you
get it not to remind anybody sadly I've
got a dental visit in uh in 10 days but
I won't think about that
I would take anything over that but I
would maybe not take White's position
over a dental visit because
we're not going to do some work on
White's king with a check on D3 and the
Knight has a parking spot ready made on
B4 so Knight D3 Chuck thingy two night
before and Tanya the problem isn't as
much that White's gonna lose in the next
three moves but black just has a very
clear plan of expanding on the queen
side you could see F7 F5 and coupled
with Lara's very disturbing time
situation
I'm very pessimistic about our chances
here in this game
it might not be a couple of moves that
might get busted in but it looks like
you could very well lose this position
super quickly as you're pointing out we
saw the first night jump in trade off
that important Bishop vacate the D3
Square for the other night what a
creative way to respond to that move F4
that Laura had made hitting that Knight
on E5 you know not retreating with it
but creating this Square on D3 and now
jumping to this a stunning Outpost I
with white would be so worried about a
central break with that F7 Pawn moving
up to F5 when your opponent's king is in
the center you really want to try to
open up those lines and F5 here word
spell disaster for white now in these
kind of positions usually White's King
is already Castle to safety and white is
pushing the central pawns but with that
King stuck on E2 this looks like it's
going to be big trouble I don't really
see how white is countering lacks move
of F5 yeah I mean if you reposition the
king and it moved like a knight over to
G1 all the situation would shift
dramatically I would still prefer black
but I don't know if Laura just has the
time to move for maybe she should try
king after maybe she should try to beat
Black to the punch and play out five
either way she's down below three
minutes now handling this position with
no time on the clock is impossible and
this just looking very very tough Knight
C4 on the board but Bishop D7 all right
Bishop B7 simple because you don't need
to just play on one side of the board
there is B5 ideas as well now in the
benoni when you're playing with the
white pieces you want to try and keep as
many minor pieces as possible because
your big Advantage is the space
Advantage due to the central pawns and
it is because itoizaga has managed to
trade off that Knight for the bishop
that we see so much play come on and
there we saw Laura trying to stop B5 but
in that process she gives the B5 Square
to the bishop to arrive that bobbing his
head he's happy this is a dream benoni
position if white trades on B5 black
captures with the pawn hits that Knight
on C4 and the pawn on A5 will fall as
one of the Defenders will be attacked
yeah you can just sense how comfortable
he feels with seven minutes on the clock
to navigate his way through these
complexities he's gotten exactly the
type of position that he specializes in
and he is coasting his way to what
appears to be a very smooth Victory
let's go back to the bird's eye view as
Laura trying her best to figure out a
way to keep her Center intact she is now
down to a minute 47 this is going to be
a very tough task on the other board
lower left I think we've got a lot of
liquidation here Tanya between Ibarra
and Gawain Jones that game seems to be
heading at a furious Pace toward a
peaceful result unless I'm missing
something that just seems pretty equal
to me and very up wow look at that wow I
agreed
all right Daniel the Prophet naroditsky
how did you even just do that and the
game ends as you called it out
I promise I I didn't know that a draw
was a draw for was issued but you know I
you know I gotta have my monitor time to
time the first result is a draw and that
transfers the tension to the other
boards where do we go next time help me
out I'm experiencing some decision
anxiety
well I know Solomon he's such a
dangerous player to play against he's
playing with the black pieces against
Karina and I see the positions while you
were talking about an end game Queens
are on the board in this one and as I
say the Queens are traded off Daniel we
see Queen D2 on the board and expecting
white to pick that up with the Knight
you don't want to fall back with the
bishop and this as well looks like
solemn can be happy with the opening
outcome no trouble for black but can he
try for more in these positions yeah he
most certainly can I think there are two
reasons why black is the one in the
driver's seat the first as you uh very
astutely noted is the fact that there's
pressure on D4 and with the the capture
White had to bring one of her pieces
back toward the second rank not what she
wants to do and the second reason as
solemn indicates with his last move is
that black is a pawn majority on the
queen side and total control over key
squares and files on the queen side in
particular the C file Rook to C3 could
come with great effect B5 followed by A6
could expand and control even more
squares so it's one of those positions
where the engine always just gives a
slight Edge but practically speaking I
am not envying Karina's situation here
she really needs to be perfect for the
next couple of moves
well this is going to be a slow grind
but as you mentioned those pawns are a
bit too ambitious and might become a
weakness and also black can create a
passer on the queen side the two Bishops
that black has is actually are the other
ones that have more Targets in White's
position so uh Karina is going to have a
tough task but meanwhile not the only
player with a tough task because pranav
is trying to put pressure as well let's
bring up our bird's eye view also Daniel
I noticed that a lot of our chat is
loving the shrimps logo one of the most
fun things about the pro chess League
have been the team names and just their
logos which have been designed uh look
at that shrimp at home I mean what's
your pick in this one that is really
Sleek I I'm just looking at it's the
shrimp next to itsurizaga's name I don't
know what I like more his position or
the logo but it definitely is Sleek
that's just what makes the PCL so unique
there's just so many components to it
that you can enjoy let's go to the
tourizaga game because it is about to
end and I'd like to catch the results of
that game unook is down to her last
seconds fighting valiantly I have to say
her last move was an excellent one
sacrificing The Exchange and barring
entry from The Black Queen but I think
Eduardo is just a couple of accurate
moves away from uh hammering down the
full point here
wow and look at that King on F3 I mean
that King has no way home there and it
all started with the opening choice that
uh that Laura made allowing Black
Knights to jump in and I love how
iterizagas decided to not pick up that
material because at night on D3 is worth
so much more he goes in with the queen
to F6 but it's getting a bit tricky now
because Black's Queen is attacked but
also the Knight on D3 is attacked that
said you can always pick up the Rook on
E1 because it comes in with a check
Laura onok working some magic with no
time on the clock 94 was another very
precise move and suddenly if you
carelessly take on F5 that night on D3
is hanging Eduardo terizaga has to spot
the fact that Knight takes C1 check is
bad and has to sacrifice in exchange on
e4 so rather than securing an exchange
the correct move is to sack on e4 and
with five minutes I think he's gonna
find that but Tanya what an instructive
line how many people would immediately
grab the Rook on E1 if we could bring up
an analysis board why is this bad
because White's Knights dominate the
game here after Queen takes F5 Knight
takes D6 white recovers the exchange
with interest and a check on H5 doesn't
help Black's pieces are suddenly the
ones that feel discombobulated so why do
we tourizaga has complicated his task
and he's played Knight takes he won and
we go back to the live board Laura
suddenly back in the game
oh but she's watered a piece that was in
the middle that's the problem with the
clock because she's playing on seconds
in such a difficult position and now it
just looks like it's all over after
finding those series of super strong
moves just one mistake and it all
collapses chess can be so heartbreaking
ah she took on E8 and that was Hasty she
had to find a computer move to stay in
the game now Bishop C6 is going to end
uh her resistance but Laura can hold her
head up high because she was in time
pressure it was a difficult situation
she came close but Eduardo rizaga
ultimately lays down the wood and wins
an important first game for the uh
shrimps
super important and what a game with the
black pieces starting with the benoni
and then just these tactical skirmishes
that we saw uh calling themselves a
Spanish shrimp but right now Daniel
they're playing like sharks they take
the lead in their match and we still got
action on the other board uh Prana
versus Santos is such an important board
for the Gnomes and we see quite an
imbalanced position our bar says pranav
is on the driving seat here oh scientist
has lost the threat of the game and this
is what makes pranav so dangerous he is
Relentless in his ability to put
pressure but he is down three minutes on
the clock so can he keep his nerves in
check he Santos is trying to keep
White's pieces in check and he is
failing the queen comes into D6 what's
going on here I think the idea is well
A4 is protected by White's Bishop the
unsung hero of White's position
blockading the C pawn and guarding A4
man Santos is quite isn't quite the bind
is there a threat though well it's
important to know that white isn't
threatening to pick up the B6 spawn
because the Rook on E7 is hanging so
white can simply slide with the Rook all
the way to B7 and try and go for these
Queen side pawns once you do win the B6
spawn the entire Queen side collapses
white will simply match down the board
and the eval bar hits it is there attack
someone pointing it out oh my God
Rook takes F7 and White's gonna eat that
pawn for breakfast tactics like that for
breakfast
and Daniel did you see that expression
pranav there just absolutely shocked at
what has happened he realizes it he
slows down takes a sip of water because
he knows that it does exist he needs to
he finds it it's on the ball he is just
a wizard I mean he just he saw her to
play against because he's full of Tricks
he spots tactics relentlessly and he's
just like one or two moves away from
winning this game I think Bishop takes
G6 might win it's important to know
Queen C1 is totally innocuous because
the King has a very beautiful Luft
Square on H2 pranab is basically just
choosing between you know five or six
different ways to win the game and he's
just gonna pick up all of the pawns with
Czech here or the pawn on G6 with the
fork it's all over what a game well you
can step up water game you can step up
with the King to 8-6 but that doesn't
help because white can then pick it up
with the bishop and threaten the mate on
87 as well and there we have it Bishop
G6 Queen 87 is a massive massive threat
here and if Anna wins this they will
equal the score and it's happened
it's done it a great game by pranav the
opening didn't quite result in what he
expected Santos equalized but then a
loud white pieces to infiltrate down the
open IFA great game by the Indian
Grandmaster the score is tied but it's
untied again because solemn has won that
end game against Karina ombre tsumova it
was tough all the way through and Karina
just not able to keep Black's pieces at
baitanya she resigns in the final
position there just down in exchange and
losing the pawn on D5
oh wow that's a tough one for Karina and
a big point for Salim and that means the
Norway gnomes take their round one
against the Spanish shrimps but by the
smallest of margins a two and a half uh
to one and a half win there with big
victories by Prana what a game solemn
with a grind in that end game and Gwen
holding to that draw meanwhile eturizaga
blasted open the position in a benoni
and scored the only win for the Spanish
shrimps and it was a much needed win as
you say as he said keeps the Spanish
Maniac shrimps within Striking Distance
nothing has been decided but the big X
Factor is V pranav and Santos Ruiz on
the maniac shrimp side he did struggle
in that qualification event in some
critical moments so again the Spanish
Grandmaster gather himself together and
Strike Back in the next rounds nothing
again has been decided do not go
anywhere real we are only one round
through this scintillating second ecl
match of the day we will see who can get
the upper hand after this short break
we'll be right back with round two
[Music]
oh he's I was here I was I was lost oh
okay well hey hey let's go oh no I think
I should have just done that
We Beat It
oh
the unreal no first try eight in a row
nine in a row baby let's go
let's go let's go
I gotta oh cool I got a little
achievement thing I honestly really
enjoyed that that was really cool become
a chess.com Community streamer at
go.chess.com start streaming
[Music]
foreign
certificate is behind him Grandmaster
Jose Carlos Ibarra an indispensable
piece of the Spanish Maniac shrimps very
strong player a streamer and he will
need to deliver as we review the entire
roster of the maniac shrimps Tanya some
amazing names there alonpie show Jose
Fernando Cuenca who is known for his
distinctive commentary but also for his
great Blitz play man is that a great
lineup
I love it and of course iterizaga who
had the big win for the Spanish shrimps
in round one they've also got some star
women players in their lineup with
Sabrina Gutierrez and Karina Sabrina is
also part of their national team for the
Olympics for the chess olympiads so
definitely one to watch out for and
Daniel this is the only team that
actually earned their spot they
qualified to play in the protest league
so they've got a point to prove here
they do indeed and Argentina has been
experiencing something of a chess a
Renaissance their bottom word that's an
awesome name first of all Canada
and I see the bottom boards you know I I
usually make a fool of myself but don't
sleep on you know those 22 2300s because
they come in hungry to deliver upsets
and they are often The X Factor in these
matches well speaking of X factors we
have one round in the books Norway
gnomes lead two and a half one and a
half on the strength of her knobs very
important Victory as well as itsurizagas
crushing win but Anya once again nothing
decided yet
and look at our matchup that's coming up
here the board one and we've got a
iterizaga who of course had a huge win
he will be taking on pranav so these two
players had such a fire start today
Daniel and I think that is going to be
the match that will decide how it goes
in this round pranav who played Super
impressively this last game he starts
with the black pieces and of course
there's also Ibarra against Solomon not
a huge matchup meanwhile it is going
taking on Karina so an important board
where Karina is the underdog but she
found some such intense moves in that
previous games was so precise she just
needs to take care of the clock play the
same chess but just don't take that much
time
and for Less experienced players and the
rapid time control it takes some
adjusting to the 10 minute time control
I'm a big fan of it but it straddles
that middle ground between Blitz and
rapid and you know sometimes it takes
some calibrating not to play too quickly
not to play too slowly each player has
their different approach as Eduardo
rosaga might need to approach his coffee
maker there oh my goodness man wake up
Susie
wow that we see you through Saga he
seems very sleepy you've been mentioning
that it looks like he's playing from a
dental office there well he has been
very precise there with his last game
win this one's not going to be easy
shranov uh super good at tactics and
really good with his opening preparation
we see an English opening C4 E5 a sort
of a reserve reversed Sicilian setup and
look at this Daniel pranav doing pranav
things with going for a line that's not
super topical but he wants to get that
Central Break in with D5 yeah it's kind
of a reverse elephant and it is
definitely not the main line but it has
gotten more popular in recent years and
it's the very ambitious setup as front
of grabs control of the center uh and
now this resembles an advanced French
setup where White
what's interesting five Pawn it's like a
billion openings aren't we
exactly it started well it could have
been any Sicilian then from an elephant
to a French and we've got a trade and
pranab slows down to think about what he
wants to recapture with with the pawn or
the queen and that's a surprising uh
surprising moment for me because it just
looks like the queen capture might be
automatic he also can deliver an
intermediate check on before so I think
this is also factoring into his thinking
now I would not rule out GF by the way
in order to support E4 but that's a moot
point he has taken more conventionally
with the queen and you're gonna be very
careful of your panopter because if you
lose D5 your entire Center collapses so
I would go Bishop before here and
immediately get this Knight off the
board the only priority for black right
now is to keep this on protected do not
play Bishop E6 because of Queen B3
hitting two pawns at the same time so
runoff Sans are already full seven moves
in will his unconventional opening
choice backfire well he's got to take
his time and make sure he gets out of
the opening unscathed Bishop before on
the board
and as bronov gets his pieces out the
rizalga does the same a couple of the
other games have started let's take a
look at the bird's eye view we've got
board two there between Miguel Santos
Ruiz and Laura onok in a what seems to
be an exchange Caro
yeah you're on point there it was an
exchange Karo Khan and it looks like
both players know what they're doing
take a look at the clock situation
though there is well 10 minutes for
Santos uh also for Laura she's taking
about a minute on her clock but
everything's fine there black finishing
development white finishing development
we're gonna see castling on the board
really soon and we also have actions
starting on the solemn versus Carlos
both there on the bottom left and it is
a
whoa and an unconventional perk at that
this is kind of an old school move order
where black plays D6 and E5 immediately
now newer players might look at this and
be very surprised because white has the
opportunity to do something very
tempting take on E5 if we may bring up
an analysis board they are now playing a
full-scale old-school filador but it's
important to point out Tanya that this
is not as good as it looks because with
the Queens off the board black skin can
actually find shelter on C7 Knight F3 is
pretty innocuous and this is considered
essentially an equal position so this
would be a toothless approach from White
and solemn is definitely not in the mood
to give up an easy draw with white back
we go to the live board we do not see
the Philadelphia at the Grand Master
Level uh many times anymore but it's an
underrated opening Tanya particularly
this setup where the bishop comes out to
E7 not easy to prove a big Advantage
with white but Bishop F4 is the move
recommended uh in I think most books in
recent year years
and very often we can see castles on
opposite sides of the board I think
we're heading there Daniel as he moves
the queen up the board so that Queen
side Castle let's go and this is what
it's going to be about with the flank
attack on either side but look at this
Carlos says I'm not going to give you a
chance he strikes in the center
immediately this is heating up fast
indeed be still my Beating Heart D5 is
not a move that you want to face if you
are unprepared and clearly Ibarra is
just showing some home cooking here that
looks like a very logical move time to
opening up the center and if a queen
appears on D5 what's annoying about that
is that white suddenly cannot Castle
Queen inside because A2 will be captured
by the queen so E5 comes to mind but
white could easily get over extended
there C5 could come with great effects
so solemn he is usually the one uh on
you know the other side of this he's got
great opening preparation but this time
the roles are reversed a great start for
Ibarra already up two minutes
I would be terrified as white having to
answer this question of how to respond
because you can't take on D5 you can't
take it but it's not ideal to trade
everything on D5 centralizing black
screen getting in the way of your own
long Castle uh of course also pushing
that pawn I'm not loving that because
black has got this Tempo jump with the
knight jump into H5 hitting that bishop
and then the C5 move comes in driving
your knight away so it looks like big
questions here you can't really go long
Castle already because there's pressure
on the E4 Pawn black can simply pick it
up with a knight uh if white was to go
along castle and finally Solem takes the
decision of trading on D5 and this is
what we've been talking about you call
this out the queen lands now you can't
go long Castle the A2 Pawn is hanging
which means you have to spend one more
Tempo getting your king to safety
meanwhile black is ready to jump in with
the Rook to eat this is getting crazy
Knight B5 attacks oh my God
oh my goodness what a move
oh
Daniel this is insane stuff and we've
got to show the tactic here
please oh my God I love the analysis but
at this moment Queen if I would run into
a check on B4 it's a double check the
only movement and rookie one Checkmate
oh my God just this is amazing stuff I
can't believe he played Rook to E8 what
a move the preparation is unreal rookie
eight is a damn girl type of move and
you need it it's not just fanciness
Tanya for the sake of being fancy
because had you instead traded Queens on
D2 the pawn on C7 is under Fire from two
different sources black would have just
lost the pawn for no compensation now
let's not overstate the case or shall we
overstate the case the bar continues his
Shenanigans Bishop before a bishop
sacrifice what is he doing what is going
on here this is Wizardry this is wild
Daniel what is this preparation he first
sacrifices the queen Queen and now a
bishop is hanging and we've got to take
a look at what happens if white actually
bites the bullet and picks up that
Bishop on B4 after Queen B4 the bishop
on E2 is still pin the pawn on G2 is
hanging is the idea simply you take on
B4 so and does black one
I think it's just Knight C6 which is a
deceptively simple move and what is the
point here well the point is that if the
queen moves away then black is able to
capture on B5 now it's a solemn's relief
I think he is able to just finally end
the shenanigans with Bishop E3 forcing
Queen before and the end game is going
to be equal which does not detract from
the impressiveness of ibarra's
preparation but more importantly Tanya
if solemn stubbornly tries to cling to
the Knight with Queen to B3 after Queen
takes G2 white is experiencing massive
problems on the queen side knowing
solemn I have a feeling that he might go
for this line the engine does give an
advantage here to black but Solomon
might want to go for a position like
this look at the Eva bar dropping
precipitously apparently this is losing
on the spot to Bishop F5 I mean I could
totally see a line like this appear on
the board if I'm solemn I'm saying
listen you gotta choose your battles
let's go conservative and let's go Queen
C3 and Bishop E3 let's see what what
decision he makes Knight C6 is on the
board
this is incredible preparation
just amazing and it's got to be
preparation right he's got like nine
minutes 46 seconds on the clock so
definitely something that he's looked at
home and as our chat was pointing out
the Opera mate we saw we've seen that in
the classical games the idea of
sacrificing the queen with the bishop
coming to the check uh chat knows their
stuff amazing amazing prep then Knight
C6 the queen has to fall back but you do
end up giving that Knight on B5 or even
more dangerously the pawn on G2 most
importantly even if solemn finds his way
he's burned six minutes on the clock
while doing that
he has indeed and with the Norway gnomes
holding that one point lead you can
afford a little bit more risk but again
Queen to B3 solemn is an incredibly
ambitious player that what that's what
makes him so fun to watch but as his
clock dwindles I think it becomes more
and more prudent to just go Queen C3 and
Bishop E3 and make a nice peaceful draw
Jose Carlos Ibarra I mean the guy is a
wizard he's so dangerous that is why
fide ratings don't tell the whole story
right 25.50 okay strong Grand Master but
this guy comes armed with Incredible
lines and solemn does choose a more
peaceful approach Queen to D2 is on the
board but what is he planning Tanya
against Queen takes B5 I don't like that
move at all because in that position
Bishop E3 walks into Queen takes B2 I
think black might be better after Queen
takes B5
that's a really big question and also
the C3 Square was so important uh to
just keep an eye on G7 as well and I
think we've got some moves on the board
so Salem they're playing quickly he
makes the move C3 Bishop developing
really putting pressure on that E2 pin
what white is relying on is the F Pawn
jumping to defend that with F3 you will
hit that Bishop you will stop that pin
but as long as White's King is in the
center Solem still under huge pressure
and huge fire Bishop G4 get that Bishop
out with Tempo F3 bring your other Rook
into the game bring it to d8 attack that
Queen it's getting more and more
dangerous for white
and it's going to be scary even if White
Castles that's what you're getting at
once The Rook gets a D.A black has
dominance in the center as well as
potentially on the queen side if the
queen swings perhaps to the other side
of the board but finally Ibarra is out
of his preparation that is the one
silver lining for solemn he's finally
gotten his opponent to think with his
own brain just a round of applause for
the Spanish Grandmasters preparation
this is the PCL in a nutshell and as
Jose Carlos Ibarra Ponders where to
develop his Bishop I'm anticipating
Bishop G4 but that affords us a good
opportunity to go back to the Prototype
view because we've got three other
fascinating games and not to be outdone
look at some of those openings we've got
Dwayne Jones and Amber sumov on the
bottom board in a very complicated
Catalan sloth type structure seems to be
a pleasant position there for Gawain and
itsurizaga continues to pile on the
pressure on renov's D5 Pawn
I think that's such a big game for these
two teams uh with itari zaga taking on
Prana both players with an excellent
showing in round one and I say Daniel we
dive into that one and take a look at
how the opening has gone for the players
because I see that black with the pawn
advance in the center has really managed
to get so much space I'm really liking
uh pranav's position here and wow take a
look at the clock as well both players
are about five minutes
I like the positional pluses that he has
you mentioned the space he's got light
Square control on the inside the problem
is without the additional pieces I don't
think he might he's going to be able to
make anything of it on the other side of
the board so rizaga has a very clear
plan look how quickly he's playing Rook
after C1 he's got his Rooks stacked on
the C file I feel like black is just
under a lot of strain on the queen side
Queen A4 Knight F4 all of those moves
have to be reckoned with and pranav his
clock is dwindling as well now Tanya as
it's horizaga thinks about his move I'll
quickly share the story from my over the
board game against him uh years ago in
2014 it was a peaceful game I was black
in an English actually and at one point
I made a move got up to go to the
bathroom when I returned uh Eduardo had
made a response and my clock was running
I wrote down his move and instantly made
my response the moment I made it I
realized that the move I had recorded
was not in fact the move that he had
played I thought he had played King G1
to G2 but in reality he had played that
move earlier and I had a moment of
abject Terror as I realized that I
actually did not know what move he made
and I'm might as well have made a huge
blunder as it turned out I got immensely
lucky that he had pushed a Pawn on the
left side of the board and it did not
impact the position or create any
threats but that is the moment I will
never forget the realization that hey
I have just given him a completely free
move Eduardo he's a tricky Guy the game
ultimately ended in a dry ultimately
ended in a draw
it's so tricky and sneaky with him you
just you just never know when
something's created on the board and
Daniel we've all been there when you
leave the board you come back and there
are these little pawn moves these little
King shifts and yeah what did my
opponent play
so I completely understand and relate to
the pain but of course in this position
it looks like pranav doesn't have that
much pain because take a look we've been
talking about the two Bishops the only
thing he needs to watch out for is
White's doubled Rook on the C line the
only open file and it looks like White's
got the control of it even though black
has got the bishop pair but the
positions blocked enough for the knights
to jump around the Knight can land on F4
put pressure on D5 that pawn chain can
become a Target and the more I see it
the more I feel I've been
underestimating White's drums here
yeah but at the same time Eduardo you
know it's it's a good problem to have
but not when you're low on time you've
got so many options to improve your
queen side position he's now suddenly
down a minute on the clock but I like
what he's doing winding his way into C5
chiseling and knifing his way into
Black's position trying to induce more
weaknesses do not play B6 restricting
the Knight because then you potentially
drop C7 and then A7 to follow E2 is also
hanging so a lot going on under the
surface and as the tension builds up
Tanya we've got tension building up on
another board that I want to check out
as we go to our bird's eye view the
right side top right we've got pandas
has sacrificed two nights and she's
recovered one of them is this a sound
sacrifice I think it is not
uh can we just quickly bring up the
analysis board because these two night
moves the last few moves are absolute
Shockers and stunners what Laura has
done to try to open up White's position
if we just back up and see how this
actually happened so the king moved up
to H2 and let's just keep the play on
and get up to board because the last two
moves with the Knight coming on first
she opens up the center and now another
Pawn sacrifice so one Pawn sacrifice
then another one then picks it up with
the Knight gives that up and doesn't
take this back it's unbelievable and she
goes in with a knight to F4 instead of
just going Rook into D4 just picking
recapturing the Knight a shocker Laura
hallucinated after Rook takes D4 her
position might not be great and perhaps
she was apprehensive about entering a
pawn down end game but after B6 the
Knight is chased away black has
excellent chances to hold the game
instead Laura throws in Knight F4 it's a
beautiful idea but unfortunately she
just runs out of fuel there's no gas
left in the tank Miguel just sidesteps
the check sidesteps the threat and
there's literally there isn't even a
single check white is up a full piece
you know under pressure in time pressure
you hallucinate stuff and it's a good
Valiant attempt by Laura but she is
going to lose this game Miguel as six
minutes and an extra piece
yeah too many sacrifices that just
nothing left none of the night neither
of the knights were left no pieces left
to assist that Queen in the attack this
looks like it's game over let's bring up
our other boards because action is on on
this one it does look like the Spanish
shrimps will take this game uh against
the Norway gnomes Laura with just an
extra piece some work to be done but
should be easy enough and there we see
while that one's easy the other boards
not so much the action the fire is on on
the solemn board what an opening that
was it looks like it's calmed down a
little and we've got well quite a
simplified position with just the Knight
and the bishop remaining on the bottom
left there but I still like black space
activity here with the Rooks in the
center the queen in a more aggressive
spot
yeah agree agree completely control of
the D3 Square you know the fact that
black is aiming at White's Queen side
pawns and a small time advantage to boot
so ibar is going to continue pressing
another board uh Tanya that catches my
eye is the bottom right between Dwayne
Jones and Amber tsumovar were white
continues to massage the weak squares in
the center shall we take a brief look at
uh Karina's attempt to hold her position
together
absolutely because this is such a huge
game here for the Spanish shrimp as well
with the black pieces and quite a wild
position I have to say at first sight I
like everything that white has done here
Gwen looking strong just compare white
pieces to Black's pieces that night on
E5 there are always Targets on this F7
E6 Pawn formation with a cunning attack
the queen can shift from B3 to F3
targeting that pawn on F7 targeting that
pawn on C6 and the last move that Karina
made sliding her Rook defending the
queen she wants to create play on The
Queen Side by picking up that A4 Pawn I
just don't feel that black has enough
time here in this position I am really
liking Gwen's uh opening approach and
what he has achieved so far the Wayne is
such an interesting player to watch you
called it is creative uh he always comes
with a little Edge in the opening and
this is exactly the type of position in
which he excels an initiative a
positional advantage and The Rook now
coming in to see one putting even more
pressure on this backward C6 spawn I
think Karina with a minute 30 has to try
to liquidate and reach some clarity on
the board so that she can play Fast B
takes A4 comes to mind after Queen takes
A4 though taking on B2 might be
ill-advised if we bring up an analysis
board take on A4 take on A4 take on B2 I
think white can capture on A5 hitting
the rook and it's so easy to lose
control of this game Tanya it can
literally happen in one move let's say
you move the Rook away already the queen
infiltrates to C7 and this is clearly
going downhill for for Karina I don't
see her surviving with just a minute now
left on the clock
she's gonna try and trade off as many
pawns and pieces as she can as you're
mentioning take that pawn on A4 Karina
open up that B file and then offer a
queen trade once white jumps in with the
queen you can move your queen either one
step forward or two steps forward and
then adjust making sure that you can try
and get the Queens off the board to ease
off the pressure a little bit with less
than a minute on the clock she's got to
do that if she keeps the pieces on the
board I'm afraid black will end up
getting checkmated in this one
draw agreed by the way in solemn's game
against Ibarra we were on the same page
you borrow a little bit better in the
final position but in the grand scheme
of things uh a I think a wise decision
he's got the black pieces against the
higher rated opponent fantastic opening
preparation and uh definitely a solid
result but now the onus is on his
teammates let's go back to the bird's
eye view it looks like a Wayne has
things under control he actually didn't
even recapture on A4 he went for your
idea we've got craziness on two boards
I'm looking at Laura unook's game and
suddenly she has developed Furious
counter play against White's King that
game's far from over and of course he
tourism is going crazy as well which of
those do we go to Daniel you've got to
go to Laura's board because she's done a
piece but what on Earth is that Knight
doing on A6 I have no idea how did it
even get that I had the exact same
thought why did it go there is my big
question what is it doing there it was
perfectly centralized Miguel Santos Ruiz
messed up a completely winning position
that almost cost the Spanish shrimps uh
the maniac shrimps qualification uh in
the final qualifying round and he might
be doing it again he's blundered or has
he I think he might have oh my gosh
Queen F1 Queen takes A6
oh
what a time we've got to show that we've
got what a tactic and you're taking
advantage of the back rank weakness and
if you go crazy you pick up that Queen
you pick up that Rook on E1 with the
check and the only move that white has
is to come back with the queen and now
you win it and take a look do a do a
pawn count here this one's easy It's All
Blacks game uh as you mentioned bang
bang and black wins I was a history
major I think you're overestimating my
buddies but it is five on three and
Miguel has to now be careful not to lose
this game but anything can happen Laura
down to 20 seconds what a tricky move is
Queen to D1 I think Laura has to go back
to D4 do not do not take this Knight
because you allow a potentially
devastating check on D.A that might
still be a draw but no need to be
adventurous I think Laura a repetition
repetition now
an inconceivable safe if Miguel does not
find a way to continue the game and I
don't see a way for him to continue the
game what a player Laura come back
that's what we're looking at I'm sorry
just amazing stuff he goes he goes
coming up on with Laura find Queen do
not she's got a plate She's Gotta play
Daniel I two seconds she misses it but
it's still under control still a lot of
threats do not take that Rook on G4
there's a mate on each one
oh great call I didn't see that what a
trick you move the Rook you get mated he
didn't do that Miguel thinking down to
two minutes F3 the best move Laura takes
it but she's let this slip oh she's let
the night out oh no
and she missed Queen takes A6 which
would which would have yielded at least
a draw on the spot
five seconds this is what time pressure
does to you Miguel
he is counting his lucky stars forces
the queen trade and this ends the game
this is all over such a heartbreak there
for Laura what a team what a fighter we
can see it on her face she knows she
missed it she had a big opportunity you
can see the disbelief there and really a
big save there by Santos
oh my gosh but we've got craziness on
two of the other boards gawaine Jones
has won his game but let's go to
itawateri tourizaga's board we've got a
crazy time scramble two Queens on the
board
what was Queen's doing on the board I I
mean I just don't understand
oh my lands
what an ending what a final position
I mean I need like five seconds to take
this in unbelievable so why just has a
queen and Black's got no checks in the
position and that's why Prana resigned I
have no idea how we got there but what
around oh and Eduardo almost got mated
but he just found a way the point of
promoting a second Queen was actually to
cover the G4 Square which uh basically
eliminates all possible checks for black
a huge win and he was off to a good
start it was an unsuccessful opening
experiment for pranav he loses a big
game Tanya this is shaping up to be an
insane match we are all tied as the
Norway gnomes seem to strike back with a
two and a half one and a half win
despite Bernard's loss wow so Spanish
shrimp steak
that's fine it's been a crazy match and
Daniel two and a half to the shrimps
which means they level the score and
what insane games we had there now
itarizaga and Santos scoring those big
wins but Santos surviving by a threat by
a brat there against Laura and then we
had a draw on the Ibarra Salem board
after an opening which I feel you only
get to see in chess books and not in
real what was that oh my God rookie
eight Bishop B4 fireworks on all sides
of the board and kudos to Solemn for
keeping his composure and making the
wise decision to just say hey I got out
prepared but I'm not just giving up a
full point he makes the draw the match
is tied after two rounds we remind you
that the first team to eight and a half
wins uh the match so we are guaranteed
we are guaranteed uh a fourth round
Tanya which is music to my ears I have a
feeling that this might go either to a
tiebreaker or to uh the last game oh my
lands I cannot wait for this ladies and
gentlemen Tanya this is crazy
it's just crazy stuff we've got a four
each round score currently just amazing
chess here going on uh and uh you know
what Daniel I would love to see your
playoff in this one I would as well well
we will have two rounds for you before
we go on break we want to remind you
that the officialchess.com Discord
server has been revamped a fresh new
look lots of new features and more join
us at go.chess.com Discord and make sure
to connect your chest.com account to
earn unique player use x Glam Discord
and chat for more information make sure
to stay plugged in by joining the
official chess.com Discord server well
we hope you will stay plugged into our
coverage of the pro chess league and the
second match of the day uh between the
maniac shrimps and the Norway gnomes we
will be back with what promises to be a
scintillating second half of the match
in just a couple of minutes
[Music]
foreign
to our new video lecture series here
with the one and only the 14th World
chess champion Bish monathon and on if
you have to explain that you're world
champion and it's taking longer than two
words there's something wrong with the
adventure there's something wrong but I
believe in when we're talking the 60s
and 70s even the 80s and 90s
you could see that the match format
produced something
unique and I remember there was a funny
moment at the press conference where I
was trying to tone it down
uh not get very excited and also I had
not had time to collect myself in fact I
already wanted to calm down and think of
the next game because I knew this is a
wounded animal there I knew that I had
to play a game against a man who was
desperate for the match to be over so
that he could clinch his title he wanted
a draw at any price I mean you can make
a joke that he had spent a week out of
the swimming pool already so he must
have been exhausted and waiting to
finish so for all of us there was this
feeling of
um we got to grab this chance with both
hands because it's not going to come by
way
[Music]
foreign
welcome back
ladies and gentlemen too the pro chess
League we're in the midst of a
scintillating second match of the day I
am Tanya sachdev GM Daniel nerdinski we
are chopping it up for you on this crazy
Wednesday we've got one match in the
books we've got a second match that is
all tied up at Four Points a piece so
the smarter chess predictions I have to
begrudgingly admit I've been getting
more and more accurate with every year
and a look at that 44 to 45 it could not
possibly be more evenly matched and
Tanya the course of the match is bearing
out this prediction to a T
it's a level match so far Daniel I'm
loving the chess it's for each and
absolutely smarter chest there on point
with a 44 to a 45
and I'm predicting it right now we're
gonna have a playoff in this one I'd
love to see it go down to the wire
I would as well perhaps the players
won't but hey as commentators we gotta
hope for the closest possible match
let's review the overall player scores
through two rounds who is doing the
heavy lifting for The Maniacs rims it is
their top boarded water resurizaga who's
got two points out of two with two
excellent wins including one of her
pronov Santos Ruiz redeeming himself
with a crazy win over unook and on the
other side solemn holding the draw in
round two winning round one gawaine
Jones Tanya he is the one that I'll be
looking to because he's in good form I
feel like he can run the table in the
last two rounds that will go a long way
for the Norway notes
such a big round coming up and of course
it is the first team to eight and a half
points that takes the match and let's
take a look at the action that's coming
up Daniel we've got iterizaga against
Queen Jones now both these players are
so dangerous their style is so similar
they're attacking their aggressive and
neither back down that one is going to
be fire on the board and of course
there's Santos against solemn another
big matchup by the way I have to say I'm
loving that shirt on Gwen
no it looks fantastic he's got that
colorful rainbow shirt going uh we're
we're seeing him he's sitting pensively
waiting for the game to start Tanya
there's another interesting storyline
both of them are English players Gawain
was an E4 player up until a couple of
years ago he has started playing the
English of course the turizaga plays the
English exclusively so I'm very
interested to see what gawaine will
bring to the table there we see Gawain
it's like a comfy churn nice little uh
playing space
he awaits the start of the game what
will we see in the opening from the
opening wizard himself the author of
several well-received books on dangerous
opening weapons and dangerous shirts as
well he ain't joking around
and dial I know that Gwen also loves his
King Kings Indians so that we have it
his style of play and yours very similar
but he starts with the white pieces in
this one and we see a king spawn opening
we got iterizaga what is his first move
going to be will he go for E5 he says no
I'm getting the Sicilian and we have an
elephant
and he wrote a coffee house Chess
Records or a two volume series on a
dangerous Blitz repertoire guess what he
practices what he preaches the elephant
has been making a Resurgence recently it
is a full-fledged and dangerous opening
weapon this is a topical line and this
game is already I can guarantee you're
going to be full of excitement now black
is that a Crossroads here C4 was one
move D5 is the other now e takes D6
Queen takes D6 hassles and then Bishop
E6
is uh one of the key lines and then the
Knight often comes out to eighth three
and then B5 this is going to be amazing
Buckle yourselves in ladies and
gentlemen
wow and I love how that night comes to
A3 and you can also strike in the center
with a deep on going up to D4 with ideas
of Knight B5 well right now eturizaga is
saying I want to trade off the Bishops
but that means he's losing time for
development and look at this Gwen not
backing down A5 A6 big threats on the
board The Rook can come to E1 attacking
that Queen on E6 with the tempo uh oh
and this is the recommendation of
svidler uh and qasim John of and Ganguly
in their recent chessable alopin course
I've played this in Blitz this is a very
dangerous line for black white generally
plays A6 and then D4 he starts with D4
and black has to get those King side
pieces out as quickly as possible
turizaga has early problems to solve and
we've got a couple more games to look at
let's travel to the bird's eye view but
danger zone or Eduardo itsurizaga love
what Gawain Jones has brought to the
table in the opening well Tanya we've
got a slightly more peaceful opening on
the top right what looks like a nimso
Indian and board 3 has also started
where to from here
wow I think we've got so much so many
moves that have happened in the solemn
Santos board and I I mean we know Salim
he is an uncompromising player uh let's
jump into that and understand the nitty
gritties of this structure because
there's everything to play for we see
Santos Trying to minimize the pressure
by treating off as many pieces as
possible Queenie two hitting that Knight
on A6 black can't slide with the queen
to B7 but the important thing to
remember is that the Knight on A6
doesn't have a future so he actually
reroutes it a retreating move only made
to come forward on the next move great
point and because the position is
relatively tame there isn't a lot of
contact between the Army's black and
afford these types of positional
niceties three or four move Maneuvers
where is the Knight heading could be
heading to D7 could be heading to C6 I
think both moves are acceptable but look
at White's Bishop solemn with that
innocuous looking move it's not
innocuous at all that Bishop is aiming
at the Knight aiming to ruin Black's
Pawn structure Miguel Santos says not so
fast hold your horses hold your Bishops
in this case Knight bd7 linking up the
knights in a very solid position for the
Spanish Grandmaster I like what he's
doing here
wow and white blitzing are his moves
while Santos blitzing out his move so we
see a hanging Pawn structure in the
middle game now the D4 C4 Pawn pawns are
in chess we call them the hanging pawns
because they kind of don't have any side
by friends just these two hanging around
chilling together trying to control as
many Central squares as possible but
very often they are also weaknesses and
white has to watch out for attacks along
the C file the problem with the hanging
pawns is that whichever Pawn advances
further it leaves a weakness adjacent to
that square for example if white was to
push D5 the C5 Square would be a
weakness if white white was to on the
other hand at some point go C5 then D5
would be a big hole in the position so a
very combative structure and I think
Santos should be pleased with this
opening outcome and I say that Daniel
because the side that has hanging pawns
wants more and more minor pieces to
create an attack against the king but
here we see a lot of Trades have already
already happen for for black great
explanation of the intricacies of the
hanging upon structure to piggyback off
of your point one way that black can try
to force the issue is the very typical
move B5 I call this carving out you're
carving out a parking spot on D5 for
your knight B5 C5 Knight T5 is often bad
news for white not only because the
Knight is very good but because the
Knight basically sits on the bishop and
one of White's main tactical ideas is to
push D5 at the right moment yes you give
up the C5 square but can't make an
omelette without breaking some eggs so
from a practical perspective I actually
would prefer black queen E4 Miguel
offering a queen trade Solomon says I'm
not even thinking about it in no way get
off me and I think he's going to
continue pushing the queen around
not sure about Miguel's decision to get
the queen to the other side
time
you want to try and keep as many pieces
on the board as possible when you're
playing with these two Pawns in the
center because the more pieces that get
traded the more of a weakness it does
become black meanwhile uh trying to
create some pressure but I don't really
see the queen at night combining to make
an attack on the king's side it is going
to be about trying to get that B5 break
in and the more I look at it the more
I'm wondering can black actually make
this move this plant this idea that you
were talking about go B5 try and win
that D5 Square for the night now might
be the perfect time it might be the last
opportunity that a black has because
white can play the prophylactic A4 and
take B5 out of the equation A4 also has
the benefit of opening up a square for
the bishop solemn does just that I like
the way that he's handling this position
definitely still equal right the evil
bar 0.0 but don't be fooled by that
plenty of life in this position chances
for both sides is Miguel piles up on
that C4 Square on that C4 Pawn a fast
fascinating positional struggle
unfolding in this very important game
and solemn will probably take his time
figuring out a way to buttress that C4
upon affording us an opportunity to move
back to the bird's eye view we've got
action on all of the boards Tanya
wow and the one that catches my
attention is again the top right the top
left board with Dwayne Jones against
italyzaga take a look at that white
spawn has landed all the way into
anime's camp with that pawn on E6 so
many pieces stacked on the queen side uh
and I'm kind of just loving what I'm
seeing right now uh Queens Queen trades
have been offered and I think
I I'm kind of I'm not sure does black
want to trade here because the A6 spawn
can be a weakness I would want to keep
Queens on the board and continue uh
playing with them and he decides the
same with Queen E7 he does indeed let's
go to that board maybe for a little
while I want to check out uh prernav's
game against albertumo because Arnav has
taken a lot of risk in the opening and
he is in trouble but we'll get to that
game in just a moment has the Wayne
Jones succeeded with his allopin
experiment I don't know Tanya on the one
hand this A7 Pawn is obviously a big
Target as you were indicating but with
the queen sitting on E7 it's protecting
it white can play Knight B5 but white
cannot add a second attacker to the A7
Pawn meanwhile black snides are very
well positioned Knight on D5 the other
night has a pretty bright future as well
as does The Rook which gonna commit to
d8 so a lot of tension in the center I
think it is prudent for white to throw
in a move like H3 or G3 because there's
a big chance that the position opens up
and I either side I get back ring
checkmated here in the blink of an eye
wow and also let's point out the Knight
on D4 actually did land from B5 so the
move Knight B5 will definitely just be a
repetition and something that iterizaga
will not be so worried about I like your
idea of playing little moves like H3
just slowly improving the position where
I do feel that black also has moves like
getting the Rook into the center making
his own pieces better the one thing that
white doesn't want to rush in is with
the move the B2 Pawn to B4 hitting that
Knight because that would just give away
the C4 Square for free and we see right
on the C3 big weakness that you're
highlighting a rook C4 jumping in
attacking that Queen and to make a point
here again B4 would be a bad idea it
might not even work tactically but more
than that it just leaves a huge weakness
on the board so it looks like white
might have to retreat back with the
queen agree completely Queen D1 is very
likely and the game continues to heat up
the time continues to dwindle this is a
very important board between two players
who are clearly in good good form but
speaking of good form for nav seems to
be in very good form after his
convincing first game Victory but his
fortunes have changed for the worse he
faces Karina ambrozumova uh a very very
dangerous board four and he is in a
great deal of danger after an opening
experiment gone wrong let's assess the
extent of the damage oh my gosh Tanya
this position the more I look at it the
more I just want to avert my eyes and
wash my hands and take a shower
Daniel you're not even overstating it
because I can feel the emotions that
you're talking about in the position not
only does white have great space
Advantage look at those holes in Black's
Camp the night jumping onto C6 and that
Rook on A7 defending that Bishop on B7
it is the least ideal Square for the
black crook now imagine a scenario where
white advances the E Pawn to E4 and
lands his own Bishop from C1 to E3
targeting that Rook on A7 which is just
stuck defending uh the bishop on B7 and
I think we've got a move on the board he
has immediately played Bishop E3 I love
it Knight jumps the Knight is coming on
to F5 the Knight is landing on C6 big
trouble here for pranav Karina uh what
what a play by her with the white pieces
and it just looks like over ambitious
play there and it's backfiring
yeah pranov with an early A6 B5 kind of
a souped-up Queens Indian but he didn't
bring his pieces out in time Karina
established this monster on D5 which is
just lording over the position in the
light squares now I think perhaps only
move is Knight G4 this might have been
overlooked by Karina I think she was a
little bit over eager with her last move
more accurate would have been to start
with Knight C6 and then play Bishop E3
with Tempo attacking The Rook but no
need to panic drop the bishop back to D2
if you're Karina and you preserve all of
the advantages no damage done you can
chase the Knight away but I think it is
critical for white to stick a knight on
C6 as quickly as possible one thing to
note though Tanya a very very poor move
here if we could bring up an analysis
board would be Knight C6 I think a lot
of players would get excited by this and
say well we win an exchange Bishop takes
E6 Bishop takes A7 but no black takes on
E3 and hits whites Queen and if you
enter the complications after Knight
takes the eight Knight takes D1 white
suddenly loses a piece because both
Knights are hanging white could undo a
lot of the damage with f takes E3 and
incidentally even here white holds
essentially a decisive advantage that
just shows you how bad Black's position
is even with this favorable
transformation or an Ops position would
be bad
but Karina needs to keep her composure
here
she needs to be calm but she also needs
to make sure she doesn't use too much of
her clock that has been a problem for
her in her past game she's gotten good
positions but low on the clock and that
then decides uh in critical moments now
in chess the hardest things to do is
well not just in chess but in life as
well Daniel to to accept your mistake
and fall back here so to so to
understand that you know what I've gone
the wrong way I just retreat with my
Bishop I keep all the pluses in the
position and everything is fine and
that's just a very difficult mindset so
I am actually
expecting her to go ahead with that
night jump to C6 as you're pointing out
that's definitely what she's looking at
it'll be very impressive if she falls
back with the bishop and says that I
evaluate this position as better for me
I keep the trumps yes I went wrong I
need to First either push my Pawn to E4
hit that Knight or jump in with the
Knight to C6 a big moment here on this
board for Karina we're not hesitating
here taking just a little bit too long
my former coach Grandmaster Gregory
kaidanov he called the skill that you
describe saying sorry and it's it's
difficult psychologically right you make
a move you load up the discovery and
then you have to switch your mindset as
you put it drop the bishop back and kind
of reset mentally Arena now down to four
and a half minutes and with every
ticking second fernov is definitely
getting more hopeful about his chances
to save the game we have seen crazy
comebacks all throughout uh the four
matches that we saw yesterday and today
good move by Karina I think Bishop F4 is
largely similar to Bishop D2 and Knight
C6 coming to a theater near you and
Karina keeping her control over the
board
I love that coming to your theater near
you and that's a movie that definitely
Karina wants to watch here Bishop
Bishop F4 nicely done there so moves the
bishop away doesn't want to trade that
off keeps the bishop there now the pawn
from E2 can advance to E4 as well along
with the idea of Knight C6 and also
notice the queen on D1 will suddenly
open up targeting that Knight on G4 and
big questions now to Prana but it is
action on the board everywhere we see a
move there by the way he jumps in with
his own Knight to C5 Arnav is not gonna
go gentle into that good night he is so
so tricky I've played hundreds of Blitz
Games with him and I think much like the
new crop of Indian Grandmasters all of
them are just incredibly resilient I
mean nihal Arjun it's just part of what
makes the Young Generation so exciting
to watch runoff he hasn't gotten as much
coverage he's still in the 2500s but
he's he also has that unwillingness to
go down without a dog fight let's see
where he puts his Knight I think he'll
go 95 and try to keep his Knight
centralized and just keep his Queen side
at arm's length but still Karina is
decisively better she should win this
game if she can keep her composure and
make a couple accurate moves Tanya
Daniel there's dogfight on all boards
and I want to pick up a bird's eye view
as pranav takes a call he does go back
to the center as you call it we will
come back to that but take a look at
what is happening that board on the top
right saw him against Santos looks
absolutely wild whitesnite has arrived
on D6 and we've been talking about how
with the hanging pawns you want to build
an attack and it looks like the position
has gotten super dangerous for black it
has indeed Solomon is completely out
playing his opponent he has outclassed
him in the positional maneuvering battle
it almost appears as though Santos has
made no moves and Solem has made all
sorts of improvements to his position
his Queen is perfectly placed his Knight
has access to D6 blacks Queen right he
brought it to H5 I expressed my doubts
about that idea and I feel like those
doubts have been borne out that Queen is
stuck in place that is doing nothing it
is miserable and D5 ends the game here
D5 ends the game Queen B4 is also good
D5 might have been immediately winning
but solemn I mean he should be able to
finish this game black is totally
paralyzed here
and I think that's the point and that
solemn isn't rushing with D5 simply
because his position is so good and he
can hold on and continue to bring Santos
low on the clock because every ball
that's passed on to Santos every move
that black has to make is a difficult
one he has to burn the clock it doesn't
improve the position so saw him here
keeping the threats a threat is stronger
than its execution and also bringing his
opponent low on the clock that is
strategic play in this format it is
indeed and just saw him demonstrating
better command of the hanging Pawn
structure the position was equal it is
no longer equal D5 he takes D5 and Rook
E7 is the reason I got so excited about
that breakthrough but again it's always
easy when you've got the engine the
evolver telling you what to do solemn he
wants to play with an abundance of
caution here I still think it's gonna
happen High time
it's coming it's happening you want it
it will be on the board solemn does not
does not hang back from moves like D5 he
is it is on his mind but of course it is
about timing he wants to make sure his
pieces are best placed for this break
while he continues to jump around with
the queen so be a little indecisive on
that but it will happen D5 sooner or
later is the only way white breaks in
with the possession yeah but listen
Miguel's not gonna wait around forever
this is like that uh meme video that
circulated a while back it's a 10 minute
video where a high jumper is kind of
jumping on the trampoline he's getting
ready to make a jump that you think is
totally impossible and of course the
joke is that the jump is never made it
just wastes 10 minutes of your life as
he prepares solemn needs to avoid that
narrative and I feel like he's
hesitating just a little bit too much
but still D5 looks incredibly strong
but you know with moving that Bishop
away from the long diagonal one of the
main points of getting that D5 in is to
fire down that A1 to h8 uh diagonal but
with this last move it seems to imply
that perhaps solemn is not so sure about
the D5 break so really here big
questions as well it looks like a super
Pleasant position here for white but
where is the Breakthrough and can solemn
find it in just about two minutes
exactly can he keep his clock uh at a
normal time because in time pressure
this is not easy to handle or white very
easy to blunder a minor piece here or
allow counter play let's go back to the
bird's eye view we'll come back to this
game when it enters the final phase of
the time scramble but the game that we
haven't covered as much is uh ibarra's
game against Laura Uno in which uh Laura
has played a fantastic opening I think
she stands better and she has a golden
opportunity uh to score an upset on the
Norway end which would uh counteract
Karina umbertsumova's win if of course
she can convert her Advantage so let's
go briefly to that game and assess the
extent of Laura's Advantage Tanya this
is looking real juicy
wow I'm loving it I mean that night on
D4 just look at this construction along
the A7 to G1 diagonal Dania we've got a
piece on every single Square we got a
Pawn on A7 on a bishop then a queen then
a night then a night then a bond and a
king if there was a design of what it
would be this game that would get it
that's amazing actually this is every
day
wow
did we actually just do that
we just did so H5 on the board and wow
white is not stopping because why can't
afford to do that black species are so
nicely placed white goes down the board
with that H Pawn 816 come on up with the
King yeah I think it's just too
dangerous with with King 86.
F7 Falls Bishop F7 you just can't allow
that
Ibarra I mean he's always finding ways
to create chances this is what strong
Grand Masters do and Black's King might
need to visit a bar if it takes on H6 it
will not be safe there but neither will
it be safe on f8 the difficult thing
Tanya about playing King f8 is that
you're leaving this Pawn alive on H6
whenever there's a Pawn on H6 there's
always going to be the threat of
essikaru deemed at the lobster mate when
the queen appears on F6 it threatens a
devastating series of checks on G7 and
h8 but can Ibarra find a way to get his
Queen there Queen H4 would be
ill-advised because if Rook takes D5
with a fork on F3 uh on Deck so
white is still worse but he's created
practical tactical chances this is still
a three result game
a hundred percent it doesn't even matter
what the eval Bar says with the King
position on effort and upon an 86
Anything Can Happen white can jump in
with the queen to B7 already threatening
mates on G7 but what works for black is
that your Rook can always step up to the
seventh rank we see that happen Queen G7
watch out for that Laura and she says
I'll fall back with the queen I really
wanted Laura to keep the Queens on the
board I'm just not a fan of offering a
Trader still a good position and wow
Ibarra says no way and comes all the way
back to H1 that's one big Retreat that
is a ridiculously gutsy call by bar
taking that Queen and following up with
Knight T5 would have given him I
wouldn't say a guaranteed draw but
definitely very good chances but he
smells blood he senses that Laura might
be losing control of this game and she
says you know what I'm going to make you
pay I love the move Queen G5 preparing
F4 and white you get checkmated here in
the blink of an eye what a fascinating
position we have here I will say that
there are some bad news use for the
shrimps it appears that Amber sumova has
completely lost control of the game
against Bernard there in a Time scramble
so let's quickly go back to the bird's
eye view as Ibarra continues to try to
make inroads and save this position
what am I seeing on the bottom right a
crazy position
I think Arena has lost the thread
and this is such an important round with
both these teams on Four Points a piece
just a massive round for both the Nori
gnomes and the shrimps what is even
happening there we see both Rooks have
jumped on to the sixth rank not just
that the board next to it we just saw
with ibarro versus Laura that is
absolutely hot action there there's so
much happening I'm gonna let you take a
pic where do you want to jump to Daniel
well it appears that solemn still has
things under control gawaine Jones's
game has been balanced for a long time
let's go to Karina's game against
Bernard because I think we are going to
see the denum they're pretty soon fernov
has taken full control of the game
White's Pawn on D5 is nowhere to be
found the queen side pressure that
seemed decisive just a couple of moves
ago uh is now in the past and it is now
blacks pressure in the center that I
think is going to decide the game Bishop
D4 coming in hot black is also up upon
man Tanya I mean you see this position
and you see the position just 10 moves
ago you will not believe that it came
from the same game Queen A4 apparently
was it was a Swindle but that was a
crazy computer move
and it's so hard to find and again it's
the clock that plays such a big role
with Karina down to just nine seconds a
very difficult position to go look at
pranav species they've just captured the
center they've captured the entire board
the Knight on E3 cannot jump back to
that Central D5 Square the F2 Pawn is
forever hanging it looks uh like pranav
is going to take this point for the
Norway gnomes oh my gosh and it appears
that the least likely scenario is
transpiring Ibarra has succeeded in
swindling Laura unook the shrimps are
gonna win on that board but conversely
bernav is also going to take the victory
so wow this is just unbelievable that
leaves us with two more boards you can
see Ibarra is up a full Queen
we've got to go into that I think that
should be finishing any second and I see
that Laura is still thinking where has
her Queen disappeared
well I think he borrow won the Queen by
infiltrating down the a file Laura might
resign In This Very position we might
catch the end of that game she might let
her time expire but Laura just shaking
her head making a couple last moves D2
Ibarra he went down the a file Tanya he
created threats against Black's King and
Laura was forced to give up her Queen
again and again and again it's the clock
situation that decides the outcome on so
many of these boards okay
Pawn as well you can pick up the bishop
on d8 you can just do a million things
completely busted and Laura will resign
this one and she does it no time no
position to play for wow yeah that is
going to do it a big win for Ibarra
pranav oh my gosh that game has gotten
complicated again he's let a lot of his
Advantage slip let's go back to Karina's
game against Bruno I'm gonna flip it on
solemn has indeed won his game as we
expected Tanya he never let that
Advantage slip huge win for the Norway
gnomes they currently lead this to uh I
think they've got two points now with a
Solomon Victor no it's even 101. this is
a huge game and Karina
is back in it or is she no the knights
coming to E4
wow this is I mean that is more than
back in the game you gotta watch out for
that F7 Pawn so you can't jump just yet
but it's always in the air and this D2
Pawn this Pawn on the second rank that
black has is so much more worth than an
exchange uh I think for Prana this is a
big moment he's got all the compensation
with the black pieces I think he's the
one who's pushing here he's got one last
hurdle to cross which is that he can't
move his Knight because F7 Falls with
check the email bar does not tell the
whole story here plus six much six he's
gotta find a way forward and the engine
sees it maybe you should play H4 and
soften up White's King position but I
don't see a direct way to make inroads a
clock situation as almost equalized is
pranav the one who's panicking Karina
defending tonight you've defended the F7
in with your knight to E4 but it does
remain pin Knight C3 could be a could be
a big threat in the air and is it
possible can you go Knight C3 right now
oh my gosh Knight C3 that's amazing
tactical Vision by you the Knight was
gonna go to E3 that one on the spot but
I think pronov's move is gonna do the
trick as well he secures the Knight with
a pawn now the queen is free to roam
about the cabin and Karina's still
trying to hold on for dear life
I don't believe it will be very
successful here and we've got another
result as you're mentioning a draw so
the score is absolutely level down what
is this match oh my God creepy seven
Queen B7 and I think White's got some
sort of Perpetual but I don't see it
where is it King 86 I don't see another
check no then Queen F2 there's a what's
the drawing move here I don't see it
Karina oh she felt no she didn't find it
I didn't find it
I mean that was hard Daniel I don't we
still don't know what was the correct
move and that is it Queenie one you're
threatening a mate on H1 the d-pawn is
about to Queen no checks on a black skin
except on F4 and that is it the king
comes the queen will fall back and guard
against checks and pranav takes this one
what a game oh man I was a slave to the
eval bar there for just a second I
apologize for that but Queen H1 did not
cut it we will show you the move I don't
know what the move is so let's go back
to that fateful final moment a
heartbreaking loss for Karina Umber
tsumova and it was indeed oh my gosh
what an idea Queen B2 is the right move
and here's the amazing thing Tanya I
takes D1 Checkmate on h8
what a geometric idea this is insane and
apparently holds the draw
your intuition with Queen we do was on
point and the whole idea is with this
mate on AJ it's so easy to miss and we
see Karina there uh definitely
heartbreaking heartbreaking moment there
for the Spanish shrimps just so much at
line and with that the Norway gnomes
take a one point lead in this match what
a treat it's been so far
it has been a treat indeed both matches
have gone down to the wire this match
guaranteed to go down to the wire as the
Norway gnomes grab the one point lead
once again on the strength of two huge
wins by solemn that was a smooth game
for nav suffered a very difficult
opening he was lost for a while but the
resilience of the Indian Prodigy proves
powerful again and he wins his game it's
gonna come down to the final round eight
and a half points is the necessary score
Norway gnomes will need at least two
points in the final round Tanya seat
belts they're fastened they're mandatory
what more could we ask than things going
down to the wire and perhaps the final
round of the day
I'm loving it I'm loving it at Daniel
and I'm still hoping for a comeback
because I would love to see a playoff
between these two extremely level teams
we've seen Norway gnomes come up with
the first punch and then Spanish shrimps
equalize the match in the second round
and in the third round Norway gnomes
takes it again will the Spanish shrimp
uh strike back one more time their task
is cut for them they need to win this
two and a half one and a half well there
is only one way to find out the players
they need a breather they need to steal
themselves for a huge final round and so
do we ladies and gentlemen we hope
you're enjoying our coverage of the pro
chess League this is the second match of
the day and we will have the fourth and
Final Round coming your way in just a
couple of minutes
foreign
struggling to improve your game
chessable is the home for chess
improvers with hundreds of courses by
incredible authors like world's champion
Magnus Carlson Christoph selecki and
Josh Toth everyone's favorite social
media troll known as Anish Geary and so
many more chessable can help you raise
your game to the next level you're
getting started on the fundamentals you
should check out everyone's first chess
workbook
maybe you want to stop letting all those
points slip away in the end game 100 end
games you must know is the course for
you
did not notice your king was in check
and still can't figure out why the
pieces won't move
actually uh chessable can't help you
with that maybe try refreshing your tab
check out chessable today and get 30
days of pro for free go to chessable.com
begin
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
on camera is one of the most fearsome
competitors in the Pro chess League
English Grandmaster gawaine Jones a key
player for the Norway gnomes loading
himself up with some caffeine there much
needed caffeine before this
all-important Final Round the Norway
gnomes are a very well assembled team do
not sleep on them they don't have
anybody over 2700 feet a but Tanya it's
important to indicate that it's not just
about what super GMS you have it's about
how well distributed your team is who do
you have on board three and four and the
Norway gnomes have some incredibly
exciting young players capable of great
things
absolutely and it doesn't it's not even
indicated the the standard rating is not
indicative of the rapid the speed chess
uh strengths and I think that's what
Norway gnomes is excelling at they've
got these dangerous players who play
very attacking style which really is the
most difficult to combat and to reply
against in these speed chess formats
solemn Saleh we've got David Howell down
there we're not seeing him play today
but we will have him I'm sure at some
point coin Jones uh Prana of the 17 year
old Grandmaster from India and look at
their women lineup as well Nino batser
Chevrolet is the top Georgian female
player she's part of their national team
and Laura even though her results today
has not gone her way she hasn't scored a
point yet which she has been better and
often winning in pretty much each of the
games that they've had today Daniel she
has indeed and but CS really actually
held Carlson to a draw a couple of years
ago in round one of the guitar open so
great lineup all round for the Gnomes
and they will need that lineup to fire
on all cylinders let's review the
current score and the final round
pairing as they lead by a point they
need at least two points in order to
reach the required eight and a half
points so with a two and a half one and
a half victory in this round the maniac
shrimps will tie the match and force the
tie break they can win outright with
three to one but they will need three
Saga and Ruiz and Ibarra and
albertsumova all hands on deck effort is
required or the comeback round by the
shrimp
wow what an action Factor on this will
be the task is cut up for the Spanish
shrimps I would love to get chat's
opinion chat what do you think is gonna
happen will Spanish shrimps take this
away in this round fall which means that
they have to at least got three points
will we see a playoff with Spanish
shrimps a winning with two and a half or
will this be a Norway gnomes all the way
wow well Tanya the Charlotte Cobras were
in a very similar situation I think this
was the exact score going to the final
round yesterday and I can tell you that
when you have a score like this the
nerves are hard to put into words
orizaga there he just wants the game to
begin because you know that ultimately
the responsibility of making the
comeback might fall on your shoulders
you know that your teammates might make
a draw it might be one and a half one
and a half and things might go down to
your board that feeling is incredibly
unsettling but for the players it's
important to focus on their games they
got to control their board because
that's the only think they can control
is going to try to control the course of
this game by playing what he is most
familiar with one C4 has been his weapon
for many years and asymmetrical English
ooh D5
ice and as always spicy stuff and we've
got asymmetrical English on the board
with the center blowing up you were
mentioning the tension and the nerves
going into the last round and what
doesn't help is knowing that the world
is watching you the cameras are on you
and it is really all about bringing out
your best character and your best
qualities as a chess player in these
moments when it really counts will the
Spanish shrimps be able to do this and
this round in front of us this game in
front of us again solemn is so critical
in deciding how this day pans out for
the Spanish team it is indeed and
obviously
the Spanish Maniac shrimps they don't
need to go crazy on all of the boards
they've got a little bit of room for air
they've got a margin and they shouldn't
force the issue if the position is equal
uh then you should make a draw and and
trust your teammates but with that said
you try as much as possible to unbalance
the game that is what Eduardo is doing
D4 used to be pretty automatic until a
couple of years back Shakura mamidarov
was instrumental in developing uh the
setup that we see uh it's urizaga essing
in this game he goes for the finqueto
and delays the move d4 because he wants
the dark squared Bishop to fire on all
cylinders the other Bishop Tanya could
come out to D3 I've heard these Bishops
refer to as the Horowitz Bishops but
that's a pretty Niche term whatever your
however you refer to them clearly these
Bishops will be menacingly aimed at
Black's King
I like that approach you're really
holding back on that Central break and
taking it slow with taking out your
Bishops and slowly this will build onto
a king side attack as you're pointing
out and currently uh solemn also not
backing down he has brought his King to
the safety he completes develop and oh
my God look at that if there ever was a
way to make your intentions Clear
itarizaga goes for it H4 on the board he
wants to March down with this Pawn all
the way to 86. yeah there is nothing
that screams I need to win this game
more than playing H4 before move 10
which has gotten increasingly popular
Alpha zero Style by Teresa as he secures
a G5 Square for his Knight but an
exceedingly risky approach as he gives
up a lot of the center and D4 could
potentially come with great effect this
is one to keep an eye on but we also
need to keep an eye on the other games
in particular we have board 2 that is
underway between Santos Ruiz with white
against gawaine Jones and Wayne has
refrained from his usual Sicilian opting
for the more solid King spawn game and
here he seems to have fully solved his
opening problems not the biggest fan
Tonya of how Miguel has handled this I
think he's given Gawain
a really really nice Italian setup with
the f file and access to F4 and just a
good deal here for black
I completely agree with you and let's
not forget exactly this F4 Square the
Knight jumping into H5 really eyeing
that meanwhile white doesn't have access
to those Central squares of F5 D5
because of the trades of the bishop so
even though black has doubled the Pawns
in the center it's exactly what you're
dreaming for because you open up the f
file and also take away key squares from
White's Knights jumping in now Santos
has to be on the defense he has to make
sure the Knight doesn't jump into F4
which is why the move G3 has been played
and I'm expecting going to continue
building the pressure along the f file a
white snake meanwhile is headed on to G4
black stops it by retreating with his
own knife I'm also looking at the clock
though and here's the thing Miguel has
all of his time which tells me that
despite appearances despite the menacing
appearance of Black's doubled heavy
pieces on the f-file Miguel believes in
his ability to orchestrate pressure on
the queen side and maybe also in in the
center I've seen a lot of yannick's
stuff Duda games uh in this type of
structure and these Knights actually do
a great job of holding down the f file
Knight on F3 is very hard to dislodge
still I think from a practical rapid
play perspective Black's position is
easier to play we will see if that bears
out as this game enters what will be a
long and complex maneuvering middle game
well meanwhile we've got action on the
other boards as well in this super
critical final round of this matchup and
let's take a look at pranav's position
there in the bottom left once again very
aggressive play it looks like it
probably arrived out of a front which
means Black's Bishop is stuck on C8 you
don't look very happy you don't sound
very happy with the French on the board
uh Daniel well listen I take it
personally when I see a French because
my score in OTB chess and the French is
I think half a point out of five
um and that includes some embarrassing
losses that I hope will be buried
beneath all of the other games or
playing against the French playing the
French with black oh
so I've given it you know the old
College stripe but I've lost a lot of my
faith in it and I think this position
represents a part of the reason why if
you turn on the engine it often gives a
deceptive evaluation close to equality
but I always feel like White's play in
this Knight C3 line is just easier F5
comes with greater effect than Black's
quote unquote equivalent pressure on the
queen side it's not equivalent D4 drives
the Knight back but the Knight is
actually happy to make its way toward
the king side maybe I'm overstating the
case here Tanya and obviously Jose
Carlos he's not a stranger to the French
he understands the ideas and in this
time control it's really all about
familiarity
hmm I completely agree you've got to
know the plans you've got to know the
ideas and Maneuvers so that you can make
the moves faster and counter your
opponent's moves as quickly as possible
so it is really all about how familiar
the players are with the position I see
black has moved all his pawns to the
light squares currently with B5 C4 D5 E6
and the pawn on F5 but I am expecting
black to continue advancing those Queen
side pawns it looks like it's going to
be a play on the flanks white is going
to try to break on the king side while
black will build a quite an Empire there
with B4 A5 A4 coming in and it looks I
don't I'm not really sure I kind of like
White's position but it's hard to point
out why exactly I think it's because
this E6 Pawn can be a Target at some
moment Daniel the Knight can jump to G5
I am envisioning a G4 break at some
moment so just oh wow and then the play
is just on the other side I clearly have
no idea what I'm saying B3 tree that's a
shocker wow and pranav might be setting
up a crazy night sacrifice if Jose
responds with B4 which I think he very
likely will perhaps there will be a sack
on D5
incinerating Black's Pawn Center that
would be a incredibly risky approach but
enough I mean I would not put it asked
him I won't try to evaluate that after
b-force he can also drop his Knight back
and maybe he is trying to slow the
progression of Black's Queen side pawns
Rook B8 uh is uh ibarra's move instead
Tanya I totally second what you said I
think pranav should roll up his sleeves
and get down a business on the king side
King H1 Rook G1 and go G4 before black
has had a chance to untangle uh this
mass of pieces in the center that could
potentially come with decisive effect
I'm calling it I'm predicting King H1
here
oof that will be fun to see I would love
to see G4 down the board just opening up
the G file also important to point out
actually the idea of B3 was that now the
B5 Pawn was hanging indeed which earlier
could not have been picked up uh because
the Rook would Slide Attack the might
and win the B2 Pawn so a move that did
have an idea and Carlos of course uh
steps away with his Rook defense the
pawn this position has all the potential
to blow up but meanwhile action on all
the other boards as well while we've got
the time let's get an update on some of
that let's bring up our bird's eye view
because I see a lot has happened in the
italyzaga solemn board and take a look
at the top left wow black spawnstone
down the center and it just looks like
white hasn't made that much Headway
while black has just made a million
moves already and look at that Bishop on
B7
yeah you're exactly right Tanya and one
sign that things haven't really gone
Eduardo's way is the fact that he's had
to Castle kingside and that's something
you normally want to avoid you want to
Checkmate black on the king so you want
to keep your Rook on the H file the fact
that he's castled there is essentially
an admission that his opening strategy
has not been successful now with that
said black may very well overextend
himself in the center and uh the fact
that black is a space Advantage doesn't
tell the whole story C5 is weak D4 could
be weak and rizaga could redeploy his
light squared Bishop to G2 so the
position remains incredibly complex but
one concerning board for the shrimps uh
I think is board four where Laura Uno
seems to have a major bind in the center
against Karina Amber tomb of us King's
Indian shall we take a quick look at
that board Tanya and then maybe go to
our top board
let's do it Daniel also it's really
important to understand how how big a
deal this round is because the final
round in this match the round four is
really where the players play against
each other's board and against each
other's strength we've got board one
against board one board two against
board two both three versus Board four
and here we see we've got Laura against
Karina as well so it's a very evenly
matched round uh so we can expect big
fights on each of these boards and you
were mentioning it looks like a tricky
position but I have to say that it's
really a game for all results I love
that Knight on D5 but at some point it
can be pushed out I can imagine that C7
Pawn going up the board to C6 of course
it's a long way off you first have to
defend that E5 Pawn as you're pointing
out go E4 attack the other night move
your knight go C6 Force this Knight to
retreat as well I'm disappointed with
myself I didn't put enough faith into uh
King's Indian setup I fell victim to the
menacing appearance of the night but
your explanation has made me realize
that actually black
maybe I wouldn't go so far as to say
that black is better but black
definitely has a very clear way to try
to push white off the ledge here
starting with E4 then moving the Knight
into the opened up E5 square and
following up with C6 if black can
achieve all of those moves then the
bishop pair and black space Advantage is
going to make its presence felt so a big
moment here for Laura and Oak and one
way that she could try to stem the tide
here is with the move H4 not really
trying to attack but rather trying to
create a stronghold on G5 for her Knight
if we could bring up an analysis board
this could go wrong very quickly for
Black
if black insists on e4 and then
eliminates the Knight then the Knight on
D5 could move on to greener pastures and
a check on F6 could mean seriously bad
news for Karina so in the event of H4 I
think she should respond with H6 maybe
weakening the G6 Pawn is going to Bear
long-term dividends for Laura but I
agree Tanya I think that these are some
hard problems to solve and the time
situation is going to equalize here as
Laura deals with uh these complex
questions that Karina has happened to
their last move
yes and Laura needs to understand also
just how dangerous E4 can be and once
she does that I think she will find your
idea of H4 which is so preemptive
prophylactic of the of the move that
black has up her sleeve with attacking
that Knight you just create a G5 square
but this game is of course it's a long
way in it's a game for all three results
a visually optically it looks super
pleasing for white with that Knight on
D5 with Black's Center and all these
ideas of actually making white pieces
Retreat make it difficult and look at
that Laura falls back with the queen
this is Karina's opportunity to get that
move E4 in
play it and play it quickly try to turn
the tide on the clock and on the board
Karina has had trouble keeping up on the
clock and these are the moments where
you have to cut those extra 30 seconds
and trust your instincts but Karina
she's taking her time I think this gives
us an opportunity to turn back to the
top board where action is at unfolding
at a furious space holy cow f4 on the
board
I cannot believe what we're looking on
that top left board F4 you're pointing
out I think we just have to jump into
that yes we do really quickly because if
we just if we can back up one move and
just show how this Pawn got here because
white in fact white in fact captured
that Central Pawn D4 and most of us male
models would just recapture back
instantly but solemn none of that he
wants to go for white skin he plays F4
this is fire down the board this is
blowing up for white and I think
iterizaga is in big trouble he is in
huge trouble I totally agree he might
lose this game in three moves if he's
not careful and you might say well
what's the big problem and I think G4 is
actually the only way to stay in the
game otherwise the file would have
opened up and the position would have
just immediately evaporated for why
turned into dust Eduardo trying to keep
the king side closed but now this Pawn
is a Sitting Duck and I think solemn
should flick in the move Queen D7
obviously coordinating his Rooks but
more importantly hitting the pawn which
is very hard to defend you might have to
contort yourself with Bishop H3 or even
Knight H2 just to keep yourself from
getting checkmated let's not forget that
the center is also a flame the board is
on fire this is how solemn wins game
games I think if you plays Queen D7 he
is knocking on the door of what may be a
decisive victory for the Norway gnomes
it's on the board
it's on the board you called it Queen D7
so just really bringing all the toys
into the party queen D7 conducting the
Rooks hitting that pawn on G4 you win
another Tempo you can always pick up the
default Pawn that Bishop on B7 Daniel
once that starts playing along this
diagonal it's going to be absolutely a
train wreck for white right now of
course the biggest question is you need
to defend that G4 Pawn you mentioned the
move Bishop H3 really the only way uh to
solve that problem and this gives black
the time you can't pick up 94 well he
picks it up with a pawn also remember
there's a huge threat of Knight jumping
on to B4 hitting not just the queen but
the Knight on F3 as well
great points there by UC takes D4 such a
good practical move keeping that two
minute time Advantage this is what he
did against Miguel Ruiz yes he
sacrificed a little bit of precision he
made some inaccuracies but he kept
himself with enough time to figure
things out when they got real 95
itsurizaga trying to turn the tide and
generate some activity apparently uh
that move makes matters even worse
Knight takes E5 comes to mind even Queen
D5 uh is on the radar I think for solemn
because Bishop G2 could be met with a
sack temporary sack on G2 you could win
the queen back or even F3 so black is
actually spoiled for Choice here I think
we're gonna see Solomon continue to play
quickly and Trust his instincts
he needs to do that because he really
needs to put the pressure on the clock
and make sure these difficult questions
in these critical moments are answered
with as less time as possible for
iterizaga 95 you're mentioning getting
that Queen centralized on the board
white is dreaming and hoping for a queen
trade I would be super worried of a Move
Like Queenie for trying to trade off on
that diagonal none of that he says I
want to First Trade the knights I want
to hit the Rook if you fall back give me
that D5 Square for the queen imagine my
queen lands on D5 and there's no
stopping a mate on H1
well solemn was right the commentator
was wrong the immediate Queen D5 would
have been a mistake would have allowed
white to intercept the long diagonal
with Queen E4 Rook C5 and Tori zaga is
on his last legs you might be in a
dentist's office but solemn is the one
who's demonstrating surgical Precision
he is performing a rude Canal right here
on White Center and White's King side D3
looks Mighty juicy and he's going to
occupy that cavity on e4 pretty soon The
Filling has fallen out okay I'm gonna
stop here
how a white really Nick requires the
wisdom tooth but there is no wisdom to
be found either Daniel it just that's
worse and worse fine let's stop now well
we might need to braces ourselves for
the end of this game
but uh we're on a roll we're we're
totally on Roll Tanya solemn is also on
a roll and this is where that time comes
in handy right he's investing
strategically a minute even a minute and
a half he knows that if he finds two or
three more accurate moves one of which I
think is in fact E3 he might end this
game here and now and as he Ponders uh
this fateful decision we've got action
and Transformations on some of the other
boards for nav uh is trying to strike uh
with an important Norway Victory we're
looking at the bird's eye view and end
game in Santos Ruiz gawaine Jones oh and
the Spanish Grandmaster is up upon he's
got gray winning chances here Sonia he
has managed to massage his way to a on a
Brooklyn game
wow and right now we see upon his attack
but it doesn't matter because it can be
defended with that Friendly Pawn on the
B2 Square so it does move forward
everything under control in this one
there's action on the other board let's
just say that chord it is white playing
for two results either the shrimps win
or that ends in a draw meanwhile take a
look at pranav's board that is insane as
well what on Earth is going on it is
pandemonium on the board and solemn by
the way he continues to make accurate
moves I think he's gonna win his game
but let's go to pronov's game because
time continues to dwindle for both
players this might be the decisive game
of the match if solemn delivers with a
win against uh itsuri Saga that makes
the margins even thinner
Miguel Ruiz will have to deliver ombart
Sumo is better she will have to deliver
and then pranav will need uh Ibarra that
is will need at least a draw to force
tie breaks that's a lot of ifs Tanya but
this is likely to happen and this is not
looking very encouraging for uh Ibarra
who is A Swindle artist he has escaped
from so many bad positions but pranav is
just salivating at the prospect of
pushing this Pawn Jose says not so fast
my friend
wow and that is one characteristic that
you really need in these formats is the
ability to be resourceful into Swindle
games and to really show resilience here
we see Rook beards stopping B5 but I'm
loving White's Rooks pinning that a pawn
to A5 he first clarifies the situation
on the king side the pressure on the
queen side is on with this Apon pin I
think pranav look at him on the screen
he looks so chill and relaxed and
confident about his position yeah he is
a zen master he's just so Daniel yeah he
just realized that white can actually
just completely shift the plate of the
king side yes Rook do you want Queen G
to line them up and give a maid on G8
and that is space Advantage you can
fling from one side of the board to the
other as quickly as possible while for
the defending side it's never easy her
eyes travel to the right side in in
synchrony I kept looking at the bifa oh
can you go B5 wait a second there's a
side of the board called the king side
and there's something called a king
that's stuck on that side Knight to D4
pernav instead continuing to work in the
center and on the queen side a trade of
knights the position beginning to
simplify a little bit but black could
still get checkmated here in two moves
literally all you need is Rook G1 Queen
G2 and these two squares cannot be
protected so far literally has one move
to set up some sort of defensive line
here
he needs to do it because you know what
pranav's done really sneakily he's taken
Black's Defender with a knight that
could have jumped to E7 to defend those
g-squares he's taken that away he's
traded it off and now we see Queen
jumping in but this gives white the time
to actually goruch G1 I don't think
white needs to bother about the B4 Pawn
I could be completely wrong here Rook G1
Queen G2 is such a dream you're
absolutely right and this bishop on D4
is the unsung hero because after Queen
takes before Queen G2 Queen B2 would
have forced to Queen trade if not for
The Bishop's control over that square
incidentally why should even play Bishop
F2 there but prernoff's placement of
this bishop on D4 what a wise decision
he actually has good 41 and he goes for
it
this might be winning this might spell
Doom for the shrimps
what an idea he just and all the play
was on the queen side and how quickly he
traded the knights and it all makes
sense life makes sense backwards chess
makes sense backwards now we understand
that nitrate he's taken away a key
Defender from Black's position that
could have jumped to E7 and guarded
those two squares the G6 and the G8
Square just amazing play very practical
choices here by pranav
the one encouraging sign Ibarra did pull
out a piece down position to qualify the
shrimps for the PCL in his game against
rasulov can he generate a little bit
more Spanish magic we will see if we can
go back to the bird's eye view Eduardo
rizaga's game continues to go he is
soldiering on he is somehow still in the
game moreover he's got this into a Time
scramble Karina Albert Zuma meanwhile
squeezing an advantage but likely to not
be able to convert
Saga game we gotta do it both players
are playing at about 10 seconds on the
clock in a crazy wild position what is
that white Bishop on C1 even doing has
it ever developed has it ever seen the
light of day but it looks like white
offering that Queen trade forcing that
Queen trade and the worst is behind him
but I will say Tanya I don't love that
decision because this gives solemn
essentially risk-free winning chances
unless he plays King F6 and blunders
into E5 four seconds
I feel like this is so hard to play for
white black is infiltrating
through G5 maybe what is just in time to
make it to G3 Eduardo is an escape
artist King G3 in the nick of time oh my
God this is crazy he might be able to
save this
I jinxed him
how did that happen it just oh
this is insane Eduardo's gonna win the
Spanish shrimps have a chance depending
on the result of the other boards and
now purnov needs to win his game
this is what was the king F6 E5 a
blunder in one and what a turnaround
solemn who was dominating this game
start to finish and now it is going to
take this point unbelievable stuff what
oh my gosh Tanya good news replaced by
bad news it appears that Miguel Santos
Ruiz who has been a pawn up in that Rook
end game he might have messed up his
winning chances now we gotta go to that
game because pernav does seem to be
converting that attack into the full
point let's see how Miguel Santos is
doing the Wayne Jones down to four
seconds he's got to make a move here
he's still down a pawn here we go
but it's a blunder
why
good question
is it because of Texas you lose eight
six oh my god king T4 ends it the reason
it ends it is because Black's position
falls apart instantly and the pawn and
game is lost and Miguel has just enough
time to find it King D4 might propelly
missed it because that is so tempting
and that's what I wanted as well and the
eval bar no it's back but it picks up
again Gawain went the wrong way Santos
missed kt4 again this is incredibly
sloppy for centers he had to take more
time King D4 was a very final move but
he still has chances Gawain needs to
find a way to use the pawn and I'll lose
on time pinky 43 King D4 E3
oh wow and if you take the Rook the E2
Pawn is Unstoppable you can give some
checks but it will come to nothing oh my
oh my gosh and Karina has failed to
convert that slight advantage that game
has entered into draw Laura unook with a
huge hold
this means that Santa's has to find a
way to squeeze a win out of this he's
trying
check back E3 is coming I think on the
board you've got to come back with your
rook and defend that pawn he picks up
the H5 Pawn he will lose the E3 Pawn but
it won't be enough and I think this is
going to end in a draw now Gawain is
playing like a wizard here Rook H4 is an
amazing move King B5 runs into Rook B4
if you go back to D3 still Rook before
and Miguel's winning chances they're
evaporating but he's still trying can he
find some way to keep his chances alive
King D4 wait a second it's not over yet
oh but now the king comes towards the
but he's going to just simply bring his
own King but you pick up the A5 Pawn
it's really far before these two Pawns
maybe they should be winning for white
even the evil bar has no idea what's
going on he's just gonna run
and why has to sacrifice his Rook for
black spawn will the two pawns be enough
or not black queens white gives up The
Rook this is super close run off runoff
has won his game this means Santa Claus
looks faster when rookie three but right
oh he's gonna pursue oh my God he's
gonna pursue White's Rook all across the
first Rank and I don't think white can
escape that mechanism Rook H3 make a
move he's down one second one second
because you're B3 that is ambitious
making D1 well this is getting tricky
and one second for Gwen
well he's gotta give up his Rook now
because otherwise you just repeat and
come back King D2
it's almost
four what on Earth is happening here
what was King C4 Rook C1 check Rook C1
Checker B7
oh my gosh Gawain is choking this away
he could have just repeated moves and
made a draw he literally just
self-destructed a million
oh my God and now white is completely
winning the pawns are unstoppable how
has black salvaged all the way down with
the King and that is it Santos knows it
and Gwen there shaking his head oh what
uh what oh I just um I don't know what
to say anymore this might be the
craziest end to a match that I have ever
seen and everybody in the chat knows
that I have been around the Chess World
for a while gawaine Jones
just did the self-destruction of the
century literally all he had to do he
had done all of the hard work first of
all you can go Rook H3 if I'm not
mistaken and this ends the game media no
matter where white goes you pursue The
Rook because white can't take that's
number one Tanya number two
literally Miguel is repeating moves and
it's an instant draw
we're not a long time my heart is out of
control because this would not have only
saved Gwen's game but it wouldn't mean
Norway gnomes wins the match but with
this win with this big win by Santos it
means the score is level and guess what
Chad we've got a play off on our hands
this is absolutely epic and this is why
team events are the best kind of events
because not only do we see the greatest
performances we see the greatest
self-destructions gawaine Jones you
could see him there he is trying to make
sense he is trying to puzzle out what
just happened but he has got to put all
of that behind him because his services
are required in this overtime this is
the first tie and definitely not the
last of the pro chess League the score
is eight to eight and the format is
going to be very simple we will explain
more after the break but basically
they're replaying the same pairings but
now it's Blitz time three plus two and
the winner of the match wins everything
we will expand on that but first it's
time to review for our coffee fasten our
seat belts and we will be back with PCL
over time on the other side of this
break
what is this this is duck chess you guys
this is a new variant it's called duck
chess chess
chest quack quack
how to play duck chest the duck is a
brick pieces cannot move through the
square occupied by the duck click on a
square to place the dog
when you're not yourself
Yeah so basically you do this and this
cannot move I'm gonna go Knight F6 and
I'm gonna put the duck in the most
inconvenient place for my opponent to
move no Bishop no Queen so no London's
can permanently stop the London capture
the pawns King to win oh wow oh there's
no stalemate but still wait there is
still meat but the still made the player
wins ooh if only that was real chess I
think I'm getting the hang of this game
no I think I think I actually am getting
the hang of it
I think this works oh that's a horrible
blunder oh my God I just blundered I
have to move something else first then
dark and Knight will take my king this
is the best way to lose the dog chest
[Music]
there are some real bullet skills right
there boys this is the first time
winning
oh no no no no no no slip no no no no no
no
come on
a duck chess champion give me those
points baby
[Music]
all right
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
you cannot script this better in
Hollywood in the greatest movie studios
they could not invent a crazier ending
to this second PCL match ladies and
gentlemen it's been a pleasure bringing
you this match alongside I am Tanya
Tanya nobody I would rather cover this
with the Norway gnomes and the Spanish
Maniac shrimps are tied eight a piece
after four rounds and they are tied in
the most improbable of ways to Wayne
Jones squanders a Surefire draw to
secure the Victory and now they have to
start
not just going Solomon Daniel remember
he was winning as well and what a
momentum shift this has been with the
shrimps taking that win going into a
playoff going into a tie break and then
let's take a look at our format that
we've got a different time control
Daniel just three minutes with a two
second increment yeah it's very simple
the pairings remain the same as round
four but the time control folks is
different it's now three plus two and if
one of the teams wins the match two and
a half one and a half or higher the
match ends if we are tied two to two
then they replay with a three plus two
time control and swap colors if that is
also tied then the time control changes
to one plus two bullet and they play in
that time control until there is a
decisive result I would say that a tie
is quite unlikely with a blitz time
control but I wouldn't put anything past
these players so once again folks the
pairings remain exactly the same so it's
urizaga he plays solemn Joe John's Place
Ruiz Etc it's just that the colors
switch so go Wayne Jones was black he
will be white solemn was black he will
be White and the other two players for
knob and Laura Uno will have the black
thesis so it's Blitz time Tanya and they
have to adjust mentally that is a huge
adjustment ten plus two three plus two
so so different
it's also letting go of what just
happened on the board Quinn and saw him
especially for these two players because
they really had the match victory in
their hands and as we know that the
pairings remain as they were in round
four which really levels the playing
field as each of the board is being
against the corresponding board big big
rounds here solemn versus italyzaga
Prana with the white pieces taking on
Ibara we've got the we've got Karina
against Laura and with the white pieces
Santos baking on Queen Jones this is
going to be an insane Blitz game it is
the first playoff of the pro chess
League I am pumped Daniel I called this
two rounds ago and I'm so happy that
it's here you called this at the start
of the batch I mean it's insane you said
they would find a way to tie the match
by hook or by crook you know by this or
by that they found a way to tie a to in
you're absolutely right the big story
line here will Jones and solemn silence
be able to push aside forget Barry under
a pile of rubble the tragedy that befell
them in the last round don't spin the
wheels don't tell yourself things could
have been different I could have been
enjoying a dinner no you've got to focus
on the task at hand roll up your sleeves
because you got a chance at Redemption
so there is still a silver lining for
those players this is going to be
unbelievable Tanya this is I can't
believe we're here
we're here we made it and of course it
is the I think the board four is going
to play such a critical such a critical
uh role in this very important playoff
and as you mentioned that only if it is
a tie only if this ends with two two we
get another Blitz game but for now we
know Blitz uh very rarely do we get a
tie this match could be decided in this
one and I really want to get chats
taught who are you guys rooting for who
do you think is going to take this away
it has been such a roller coaster of a
match it has indeed we'd like to thank
the thousands of you so involved in the
chat supporting your favorite team folks
we will try to bring you all of the
action it's hard to cover four Blitz
Games at the same time so we'll do our
very best we will try to catch the end
of the games but you know we can't cover
everything but we will do our very very
best here we go here we go going Jones
has the white pieces and it a king's
Indiana attack so he starts pretty
peacefully
wow and we've got action on all the four
boards as we can see the players are of
course blitzing out their moves we've
got the kingspawn opening on the bottom
left while D4 on the top board and wow
look at this Gwen versus Santos opening
that we have where do you want to jump
to Daniel because there's action and
it's quick action it's action on all of
the boards and we've got a nimso Indian
in pranav versus etorizaga uh let's go
well there's already an end game and
gawaine Jones's game let's go to
ibarra's game against pranoff because I
feel like that might be the X Factor now
I've just delivered an amazing attacking
game let's not forget that he played
perhaps the best game of the whole match
and he's playing for a win with the
black pieces he's already managed to
unbalance the game he's got an open B
file and I think he's got a very good
Blitz type position but Ibarra starting
to accumulate some of the pressure on
the king side
well I'm happy to jump into that because
we see it's really heating up you were
talking about the pressure along the
king side and we see the F Pawn
advancing and now pranav has to always
watch out for F5 or E5 break especially
with that King on 87 notice White's
Bishop on D3 let's see if we can't jump
into the analysis board and get the
players on the screen as well
yeah we've got crazy stuff there Bishop
to A7 on the board bottom left of your
screen bar attacking that Rook on ba
that's why you can't pre-move in a three
plus two time control this isn't bullet
and you don't want to over compensate
and start blitzing out moves three
minutes it's a long time and run off
there shifting his Knight back toward D7
and meanwhile top left we've got
craziness any tourizaga's board Knight
takes E4 and Knight sacrificed by its
rizaga White's King is wide open there
so it's a rizaga just feeling it right
now after that Swindle win in the last
round
he is angry Saga is an angry man right
now he goes on to open the E file you're
calling it a sacrifice I'm calling it an
attack Daniel if white does accept it
which it looks like white must the black
Rook can slide onto the E file taking
advantage of White's complete lack in
development here
indeed and the two relatively peaceful
games going Jones I think holds a small
Advantage top right against Santos Ruiz
he's bringing his Knight to G5 he's
doing exactly what he's supposed to do
he's squeezing out a small Advantage
right an anti-tilt opening meanwhile I
think pranav has just gone very wrong
with his last move I think he's made a
huge mistake so if we could go to the
pranav game I think oh and
I apologize bernav does have the white
pieces uh Ibarra that is no bernoff has
the black pieces so yes he does make a
big mistake there with Knight C5 purnov
has black and I think Bishop takes C5
and E5 sections off the bishop Tanya and
gives black tripled hawns on the queen
side
there is one hideous Pawn structure it's
not just the triple pawns the pawn on A5
is forever weak as well and as you're
pointing out white and we see that
happen E5 blocking off that Bishop on G7
because like has made the committed
decision of trading off his own Bishop
so he really makes sure that black has
got no activity down that diagonal it
looks like pranav could be paying the
price for this one he most certainly is
and Ibarra you don't have to tell him
twice this is a basic Betty idea and
this is a terrible terrible position for
uh vipranov who's trying to unbounce the
game but instead he's just giving up
another Pawn he is in free fall right
now not only does he have terrible
Bishop on G7 but White's got easy and
clear attacking prospects with the
Knight coming to you for Tanya this is
very very disturbing this could be a
painful loss for uh the Norway gnomes
Ibarra playing a perfect positional game
so far
wow so much action in this one so this
we can call it for now that it looks
like pranav isn't driving seat here with
the white pieces uh and Bishop falls
back to f8 it looks like huge trouble
here for Ibarra let's go back to our
bird's eye view and take a look at some
of the other action that's on because
take a look at the top right screen now
Gwen has marched down with his Pawn to
D6 he's sacrificing the pawn but what
he's done is open up his light Squad
Bishop targeting B7 this is wild this is
wild to clarify purnov has blocked
veeper enough has black he has the black
pieces against Ibarra so Ibarra is the
one winning uh we'll switch that label
as soon as we can a lot of things to
manage here folks uh but solemn Saleh
also has a pass Pawn so look at that
pawn on D6 on the right Tanya and a Pawn
on D5 that might appear on D6 if solemn
drops his Bishop to F4 I think he's got
Eduardo on the ropes yet again this time
with the white pieces Bishop F4 and D6
really good Wayne Jones is better I
think the gnomes are just crushing it
right now
wow and let's not forget Norms were the
one who were dominating that last round
as well but shrimps they are known to
come back they have made massive
resilient efforts in this match and will
they be able to do this take a look at
the top left
solemnizaga board what is that white
Bishop doing on F6 dark Squad weaknesses
it looks like black should be getting
checkmated any moment but Queen T4 and
queen H4 I mean that was cutting it very
close by selling he almost lost that
Bishop on F6 The Queen Is Anchored to
that Bishop as it stands the D5 Pawn is
hanging but if you capture it you get
pinned with Rook F1 2d1 Eduardo's
position is almost unplayable the only
chance is to get the Knight involved and
he does he's made a great move Knight B3
to C5 and he is back in the game once
again Tanya the Knight is coming to E4
he's managing to turn it around and it's
coming to E4 it's coming to D3 it is
basically entering White's position and
meanwhile white can't jump in with the
queen 286 because the bishop on F6 hangs
it might be time for white to actually
retreat with that Bishop to D4 trying to
really build a king side attack there
but it is action all over take a look at
the bottom left Ibarra Crusher
wow
can we push that up Bishop F5 ends the
game even Queen takes G2 he's got a
minute and a half
God Mode God mode by Jose Carlos sibara
unless he messes this up royally this is
in the back not a single counter chance
and he plays this Russian Schoolboy
Style with Queen takes G2
pranav with the black pieces just
running out of gas he is an excellent
Blitz player but this is all Ibarra Rook
is coming to G1 and Tanya this is
exactly what pranav did to Ibarra in the
previous round he made it him on the G
file the fortunes reverse
I remember that this is crazy stuff and
now eight six is hanging and pranav down
to just two seconds on the clock but the
clock doesn't matter because it is a
dead lost position he can't pick up the
exit Pawn with the check he can pick up
the bishop he can go Bishop E6 check go
Queen h8 pick up that Rook on on G7 just
a million ways to win this position a
point for the Spanish shrimps that is a
huge point you can see pranav leaning
back and F5 crushes it as does Queen F6
that's it let's go back to our bird's
eye view because this puts
usual discover check wins a queen and
wins the game
he wins the game Spanish shrimps lead by
a point that means solemn Saleh has to
deliver on his board as this guy Wayne
Jones but Wayne has lost a lot of his
Advantage I think Santa Cerise is
generating a tremendous amount of
counter play in this rock on here it's
another Rook end game what are the
likelihoods what are the odds of that
and wow and Gwen down to seconds but I'm
sure he's having nightmares from the
last round and look at this I fourth
board it will count and there we've got
both players playing on second what is
happening that you pick up the bishop
with your Rook
Laura is going to win unook is going to
win that bottom board she is up a
thousand pieces that's it that is going
to be a point for the Gnomes it's gonna
be 1-1 after ombartumova resigns and she
will resign she's down a rook she loses
on time the score is 1-1 we are down to
the bottom two boards and Dwayne Jones
has choked it again he's gonna lose
I can't believe it son whoa
and Santa's reaction he just completed
he probably pre-moved I don't know what
happened there but he just wanted to
rook and then he resigned he wasn't
he wasn't played Rook after he now
slipped
this is there's a demon that's behind
this and it's all down to the bottom
game which is Frozen we don't know
exactly how it happened let's see what
the result of the tourism is in shock he
can't believe what just happened
oh my God
failed to win his game
no this didn't just happen I need to
replay this 18 more times let me let me
say this again Tanya Gawain was winning
he literally is a rook down with 17
seconds for santus Ruiz
and he spent 0.5 of them to make a mouse
slip
yeah that was just so unfortunate that
was a mild slip putting that Rook on F2
he wanted it to go all the way to E2 and
with that it just looks like kaisa today
was not on their side whatever and this
just cost them the match because they
lost 10 and a half to nine and a half
I'm totally speechless I will need to
pinch myself multiple times
Gwen can't believe it Gwen can't believe
what just happened this might be one of
the craziest sequences Tanya the one of
the craziest half hours in the history
of online chess and that is not an
exaggerate I don't think anybody would
possibly think that that that's an
exaggeration Miguel Sanchez Ruiz
is not going to live that down for a
very long time Gawain Jones is still in
absolute disbelief Santos has left the
room he needs a breath of fresh air
oh my freaking lands
I can't I can't believe it and it just
reminds me of Gwen's last game it feels
like uh the law of averages here Gwen
messing that up losing that round four
and then winning this by luck just
insane stuff but you know what they say
uh Daniel you make your own luck on the
board and what happened and Tanya to add
insult to injury Eduardo terizaga
checked the Wayne Jones's sport he saw
that his teammate Santo Cerise with
swindling minnows Rockingham and he
accepted a draw in his better position
he accepted a draw in trusting the win
to Ruiz
this compounds this compounds the the
just the feeling of utter disbelief uh
let's bring up the bird's eye view
because I I don't have let me see if I
can find terizaga's game here
um and there was just no way that
iterizaga would have agreed to a draw
had he just waited for one move what an
unfortunate Mouse slip that was and we
see that on the top left uh Daniel what
you're pointing out the position that
the game ended in where uh iterizaga
took a draw as he saw that Santos was an
entire Rock up he's never imagining that
there would be a mouse slip plundering
that Rook away let's pull up that board
just for a second
he actually was losing out of the
opening swindling Asylum 20 seconds up
on the clock and with Knight C5 could
have continued to expand his Advantage
this is a very hard position for white
to play the dark squares are covered but
he checked the other boards quickly it
was a totally rational decision by
Eduardo he saw that uh amber tsumova had
a decent position uh she loses he saw
that Ibarra was winning he does but the
mouse slip
by Santos Ruiz is going to go down in
history as one of the craziest
turnarounds in online chess history
I've just never seen anything like this
I mean what a match we've had Daniel
starting from round one the Norway
gnomes taking a lead and then shrimps
coming back with a back punch then again
Norway gnomes taking a lead and then
shrimp equalizing the match leveling the
score going into a playoff and that
final finish that we saw with a mouse
slip blundering that Rook this is Blitz
it is completely unpredictable it's not
over till it's over and if ever that was
true it is this moment what a win by
Norway gnomes and you've got to feel a
little bit for the shrimps for going
down in this one uh just unbelievable
stuff there unbelievable indeed pure
pain or uh the the shrimps who did such
a good job to qualify and then an
unbelievable comeback by Santos Ruiz but
at the end of the day Kaiser just was
not on their side and ladies and
gentlemen who would we interview except
go Wayne Jones the man of power what
hasn't happened to him at this match
will have to win for you for our
post-match interview so Chad if you've
managed to recover from the sequence of
events we just saw you can spam the chat
with your best questions for the English
Grandmaster we will ask him all about
his crazy experience in the last 30
minutes folks stay tuned the match is
over but the entertainment is not we'll
have Grandmaster going Jones for the
interview and the wrap up on the other
side of this short break
what is this this is duck chess you guys
this is a new variant it's called duck
chess chess but with a duck quack quack
how to play duck chest the duck is a
brick pieces cannot move through the
square occupied by the duck click on a
square to place the dog
oh he put the deck to prevent moves of
opponent not yourself
Yeah so basically you do this and this
cannot move I'm gonna go Knight F6 and
I'm gonna put the duck in the most
inconvenient place for my opponent to
move no Bishop no Queen so no londons
can permanently stop the London capture
the one's Kingdom too oh wow oh there's
no stalemates but still wait there is
still me but the still mated player wins
ooh if only that was real chess I think
I'm getting the hang of this game I
think I think I actually am getting the
hang of it
I think this works oh that's a horrible
blunder oh my God I just blundered I
have to move something else first then
dark and Knight will take my king this
is the best way to lose the dog chest
[Music]
there are some real bullet skills right
there boys this is the first time
winning duck chess
no no no no no I won
uh duck chess champion give me those
points baby
foreign
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the pro chess League we
just observed one of the craziest
finishes uh to a match that I have ever
seen and the perfect guest joins us in
the studio Grand Master goane Jones the
man of the moment Gawain I gotta ask you
first and foremost is is this the
craziest thing that has ever happened to
you in your chess career is that does
this make the top three
it's a Blitz game but the record one
before it it was all a complete blur
there
but that was probably a split second
away from resigning okay so if he'd not
moved I think I would have resigned so
it's a
definitely a lot of luck on my side
today
wow as you mentioned Gwen that last
moment of the blitz playoff it was just
a nail-biting finish but I want to get
your thoughts on that fourth round that
you were talking about the match could
have been wrapped up there for Norway
gnomes what was it like for you taking
this to the playoffs with the nerves
what happened there why did you not just
repeat
uh a good question certainly I saw him
to my wife and she said were you trying
to win didn't you not know the school
my uh brain just stopped working I
didn't realize that could repeat and
then I was worried that I was losing
this
at the race and uh
I think I played too slowly earlier in
the game and I had just playing on two
seconds for so long that uh at some
point there was some
meltdown and
I've got a lot more excitement
go in we uh obviously want to let you
rest we've got a couple of chat
questions feature chat questions first
of all from go nkn who asks how do you
stay calm with a finish like this I mean
you uh survived a pawn down end game or
ever can you give us a little bit more
insight on just like what how difficult
it is to handle those high intensity
positions with no time on the clock
yeah I think at some point I thought
objectively was lost and therefore I
should just play well practically and
just play some quick moves and
the problem was the transition back to
suddenly when I thought I might be
holding the draw uh added pressure
became too much for me so I think that's
quite a difficult scenario
uh and then I have felt some deja vu in
the next game as well where suddenly I
was losing another rook and born in game
but
be punished but
now slips are part of online chess at
least
it's all part of the skin set and these
things happen and if
you know it's it's not the most ideal
way to win a match and I I understand
that feeling Gwen but then you take what
you get and it is just the start of the
protest League every week it gets
tougher you will be playing against uh
the chess Bros as well and I want to ask
you actually not me but it's pumpkin the
cat who's brought up a great question
here you're playing for the Norway
gnomes how excited are you to play
against Magnus and Aryan who this time
are actually playing for the chess bras
what's that gonna be like
yeah that'd be a great match the added
motivation for the for the gnome theater
to be the expats playing over for the
chess Bros
but uh no when it's a team event it
doesn't really matter how you win it's
just great to get through I think if it
was a individual event I'd be feeling
much guilty
goane final question for you before we
let you uh take a well-deserved rest and
you know sit back and process all of
this a question from
um a question from brainstorm 18 who
asks who do you have for the candidates
and I guess I could extend this and ask
you if you have a prediction for the
world championship match
uh
so are the candidates first I don't
actually know who's playing in the
candidates yet I don't either so yeah
let's go
yeah it'll be great to watch
um
I'll go for nepo because he's got the
experience of already playing a match
and
yeah so yeah that's probably actually
like it'll be a very close match looking
forward to watching
gotcha well thank you Gawain we will let
you rest I think I still need to pinch
myself a few times and I'm sure you too
as well Grandmaster Wayne Jones the hero
of the match congratulations on the
window Wayne and get some rest great
thanks good night
that's all she wrote Tanya ten and a
half nine and a half the final score so
calm you know they won by a point
nothing major happened they outplayed
them oh no no you had to watch this
match in its entirety and this is why we
hyped the PCL up so much right this
right here in a nutshell is why team
events produce some of the craziest
entertainment that you will find
anywhere in the Chess World
wow that match was just something else
it was it was from another planet I mean
what it went down to what we saw
Fighting Chess not just not just about
going into playoffs there Daniel but
also what we saw in the rapid portion
the ten plus two how the teams came back
just how resilient and difficult it was
uh to put the shrimps down they really
fought hard they had it in the bag and
it all came down to Gwen we heard it
from him when it comes to team events
you know every single point matters and
you take the wins as they come whether
they're in the most ideal way or not he
had his chances in ground four and then
finally Kaiser had him had guys I was
smiling upon Him by gifting him that
point Rook F2 that one is going to hurt
and cause probably a lot of sleepless
nights for the Spanish shrimps but you
need three strikes before you're
eliminated so the shrimps have another
chance they will be angry they will be
hungry and they will seek a Redemption
Eduardo
ran the table with four out of four
quietly an amazing performance much like
Magnus yesterday but he wasn't able to
carry his team to Victory he needed a
little bit more help from his supporting
casts and perhaps he will get this help
next week well you will not have to wait
for next week for more PCL action
because we have another PC all day on
Friday with two more matches coming your
way uh in the morning we've got mg D1
against the blitz 7 30 a.m Pacific 10 30
a.m Eastern start time followed by the
Berlin Bears against Levy rosman's much
anticipated Gotham Knights featuring
some guy named karanakamura one of the
PCL favorites that will come right after
at 10 A.M Pacific 1pm Eastern ladies and
gentlemen if you enjoyed today's action
mark your calendars for Friday because
we will get more of the saying Tanya
with more amazing players and crazy
action and I'm just sad today has come
to an end I'm out of breath it was still
one Daniel and this is why we love the
protest league and I cannot wait to see
how this pans out what a day it's been a
super fun and thank you to chat for
joining us through through this entire
crazy one crazy ride that we were on and
of course we'll be back with the action
we will indeed Tanya this is our first
time compensating together I've been a
big fan of your commentary for a while
and uh I honestly had a blast you're
amazing and it was it was a great
pleasure to cover these these matches
with you
and folks it is time for us to say a
goodbye the Sun is setting here on the
East Coast we're all gonna get some rest
we all might need to pinch ourselves an
extra time today but no you are not
dreaming this is just what chess looks
like in 2023 make sure to join us on
Friday and finally we'd like to thank
everybody in the chat and our amazing
team at chess.com our producers dick and
a hall up are working so hard in
creating an amazing broadcast couldn't
do it without you I know that note
ladies and gentlemen from the 2023 Pro
chess League this Grandmaster Daniel
nerdinsky International Master Tanya
sachdev we did you goodbye and we will
see you on Friday for more PC election
so long
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign